is
TensorFlow's
High-Level APIs
Getting Started with
TensorFlow's High-Level APIs
.
>> Should I kick it off? Yes!
Good morning!  Thank you for
coming so early!  I'm Josh
Gordon and I'm Laurence
Moroney and we're here to speak
about Getting Started with
TensorFlow's High-Level APIs and
I have good news for you and I
hope this talk will be concrete
and useful.  An area I'm
particularly passionate about is
making machine learning as
accessible as possible to as
many people as possible.   The
TensorFlow team has invested
heavily in the same thing.   We
have spent energy making
TensorFlow easier to use.  .
pgh I would like to show you
basically
a demo of what is in my opinion
the easiest way to get started
with TensorFlow today.  There
are three things that are
concrete that I would like to
walk you through the first, even
if you're new to TensorFlow,
machine learning, even new to
Python, an area that's silly but
non-trivial, it is installing
TensorFlow in different areas
and it can be hard for people
that are brand-new.
I'll show you something called
Colab and I'll wake you through
it.  It is a server running in
the Cloud, free of charge with
TensorFlow preinstalled, come
was a GPU, it is awesome.
I'll walk you through how to use
that, get started with
TensorFlow.
TensorFlow has many differents
APIs and my personal favorite
and what I
recommend to you, it is an April
that's implemented in TensorFlow
and it is great.  I can't tell
you how fun I have had using it.
I will walk you through writing
hello world for it Tf.keras and
it is good for GS and I'll point
you to educational resources to
learn more.
Cool.
These are the APIs I want to
briefly introduce.   Tf.keras,
it is like Lego-like building
blocks for building and defining
models, tf.
data, when they learn ML, they
learn that the neural network is
composed of layers and they can
adjust the neurons per layer and
there are hyper parameters and
they spend time on modeling.
Something that's really, really
important, but doesn't get
attention is how to get the data
in the network.  Writing input
pipelines is  non-trivial.
I'm going to show you an API
that's easy to use and
high-performance way of writing
the pipelines.
I'll show you eager execution.
If you're -- Lawrence will give
you more depth on eager.
When you hear eager execution,
if you're new to TensorFlow,
ignore that, think this is the
thing that you always do.  You
debug the TensorFlow programs
and it makes TensorFlow feel
like regular Python.  This is a
short talk.   I won't go into
all details of how TensorFlow
works under the hood.  This is
the right way to do it if you
learn TensorFlow today.
Briefly, this is what I would do
if
you want to try TensorFlow and
Tf.keras and this is the fastest
possible  way.  All of the APIs,
they're fully implemented
working well.
We are just now starting to
write all the samples and docs
around them.  I have a feeling
the samples I was
able to cook up for this talk,
they're quite rough.  Stay
tuned, and check back in the
next few months as we flesh this
out.   Let's dive right in.
If you go to this website, it
will bring you -- can we switch
to the laptop for a minute,
please?
Thank you.
It brings you to
the site and you scroll down to
lead me and you see a few
notebooks.
I want to show you how easy it
is to get started.
Click on one.  They open up
immediately in Colab.  Now you
have a June tar notebook running
entirely in the Cloud.
You can hit connect to connect
to
it, and now I can start running
these
cells and I'll wake you through
this in detail in a few minutes.
This shows you the first nurl
network using Tf.keras, there is
preprocessing but the notebook
is short.
The next notebook, shows you how
to do the same thing with Tf.
keras and eager execution and we
go in more depth.  It is that
easy to get started.  It will
take about 5 minutes
end-to-end to try it out.
Let's switch back to the
slides, please.
I'll give you a bit more depth
of
what's happening in the
notebooks.  Using Tf.
keras, this is the complete code
minus lines of preprocessing,
formatting the
data, to write, train, evaluate
and make predictions with your
personal network in TensorFlow.
If you were using TensorFlow
about a year ago, it would have
been substantially more code.
There is several great
high-level APIs that are great
for production but for learning
ML I strongly recommend this.
I'll walk you through what the
lines are doing.  At one point,
I want to make this point, the
code is concept heavy but code
light.  Writing the code itself
should no longer be a barrier to
getting started with ML.  I hope
far fewer people will spend
energy and time on the syntax
and debugging, and that you can
spend more of your time and
energy thinking about
what you're trying to do and
why.
Before I dive into code, I want
to make an important point:
Machine learning is a broad
field.  By far, enormous take a
lot of students make when
they're learning is they learn
how to train an image classifier
like we'll do in a moment and
they find when he they write the
classifier they start evaluating
it and
see the numbers like 99%
accuracy.   They find out that
by tweaking the network you can
get to 99.6 or whatever.  In
reality, it almost never really
matters.  The most important
thing you can spend
your time on is designing the
experiment.  Concretely, think
about what you're trying to
predict and why?  How will it be
used in practice?  What could
can go wrong?  Where is the data
coming from?  This Iing through
the design of the system as you
would in any type of
software is much, much more
important than messing around
trying to get higher accuracy.
There is a whole talk on that.
I won't share that with you.
Today, I'll show the code.
Always think of what, why in
addition to how.
Before I dive into this, a
couple of cool things, not
enough time to introduce
TensorFlow, I wanted to call out
the community, it is an
important thing about
TensorFlow.   In addition to the
1 #,000 plus folks that
contributed code there are many,
many more who are doing things
like  teaching, organizing
events, writing articles, these
things are incredibly valuable
too.  There is a few more things
I want to call out.  This came
out two days ago.  There is
another library called
TensorFlow.
js, it is in Java script, same
APIs, the same Tf.keras that
I'll show you today --
>> LAURENCE MORONEY: Were you
going to act this out?
>> JOSH GORDON: There is a
great sandbox to try it.
It is TensorFlow running in a
browser and it runs in realtime.
There is two links on the
bottom, there is a great demo to
play with on the blog and you
can find the code on the
website.
Another thing, there's a pair of
links here that I encourage you
to try.
This is Ma again at a and it is
a -- magenta and it is using
TensorFlow for ex peer.S in art
and music.  This is
computer-assisted drawing.
It helps me draw a duck with the
mouse and it is kind of auto
complete for drawing.  There is
a great game, quick draw, I
encourage you to try, it is
great for
kids -- yeah -- quick draw, and
the magenta demo is great to
try.  Fun stuff before getting
into code.
On a personal note, a reason why
I care about the machine
learning so much, because of a
project called  Cellbot and
it is a project from 2004, it
was in a biology lab and it uses
a neural network
to identify specific types of
cells in solution and then sort
them.  What was so cool to me as
a student working on this, it is
that machine learning is not
just for computer scientists.
The fact that biologists were
trying to do something useful
using technology that originated
in our field was really
meaningful to me.  It is how can
we use machine learning for
medicine, for art, for
healthcare
just to do useful things in the
world.
That's sort of the thinking
behind
everything behind ML, how can we
help people.
>> Colab, it is short for
Laboratory.
It is inspired by Google docs,
it is a
code editor and basically you
can save the notebooks in Google
drive and get them back in as
notebooks.  A lot of people are
not from Python I know.  I want
to spend a minute and introduce
Jupiter notebooks.   Broadly,
here is Colab and there are two
types of cells.   There is mark
down cells, which contain mark
down.  If you edit a mark down
cell like I'm doing with hello
world and you execute it, it
renders that mark down.  The
other type of cell, it is a code
cell.  If you edit the code,
execute the cell, it executes
the code.
>> LAURENCE MORONEY: They give
you access to GPUs, I have
spoken to a lot of   em that
find it difficult to set up the
GPUs or maybe they're in a
university environment and they
don't have the access to that
the expensive
GPUs and you can connect to a
GPU in the data center to check
out the code
running on GPUs.
>> JOSH GORDON: A really good
point.  another thing if you're
new to this, you can create
visualizations in line.   I'm
using the maps for the plots and
data and it goes in line with
the notebook.  It is important
because it helps you share
results.
Another thing to mention
quickly, you
can install libraries, you're
running in some containers but
you can install whatever library
you need.  Here I'm doing the
map and you have the root access
to it.
A lot of people miss this
feature, it
is snippets and it is hidden in
the table of context.  What I'll
do, create data and download
the data off of Colab back to my
laptop and to find out how to do
that, I click on this thing and
start to search for
downloading data and Colab --
you can't see it -- there is
code that I can copy and paste
in notebook and run.  It has
examples of installing
libraries, things like that.
Super useful, don't have time to
talk about it.
It is great for reproducible
examples.
Let's jump into Tf.keras for the
first nurl network.  I talked
about it earlier, but no one
has ever looked at the code to
write the first nurl network no
matter how smart you are,
doesn't matter if you have a PhD
in physics, whatever, it is
impossible to learn this stuff.
It is completely normal to see
lots of concepts and have no
idea what they mean.  I'll at
least introduce you and then
point you to a course you can
use to get more depth.
The other thing I should look at
my slides, right!.
You will see lots of parameters
when you define the networks.
Really only one, two are
important to spend time on.
I'll point you to what they are
as we go.
There is broadly five steps to
write
hello world in TensorFlow with
Tf.keras.  The good news is,ing
3, 4, 5, it is one line of code.
That's all the work of training
the network, evaluating and
making predictions.  Creating
the dataset in reality takes
a long time, preprocessing data
is a long time, building the
model is where the concepts are.
We'll see what this looks like.
We'll use MNIST, you know MNIST
code for machine learning
experts, the reason I picked it,
so we don't have to worry about
the data.  If you're new to
MNIST, it is the hello world of
computer vision, it is a
dataset of about 60,000 plus low
resolution handwritten digits
and we are
training it to recognize digits
that it has not seen before.
Here is what we'll do:  We'll
import TensorFlow and on the
second line we
import MNIST, and it is easy, it
is baked into the TensorFlow, if
you're new to using Tf.keras
with TensorFlow, it is included,
you then have access to the
complete api and there is
nothing else to do, it is there.
This is awesome.
By the way, there are many
advanced things you can do using
Tf.keras and it is grates.  Here
I'm trying to show the straight,
easy as possible way.
Here is the format of the
dataset.  It is divided already
for us, train
and test, 60,000 and 10,000, the
top right, a diagram of the
format of the images.  If you
look at the notebooks in the
directory, the best thing you
can do when you impoverty a
dataset is to spend time asking
basic questions.  When you
import the data, print it out,
print out the shape print out
the
single vision, is it floating
point, an imager, the
dimensions, how many do you
have?  Spending time
understanding the format, the
plumbing will save you a lot of
headache later on.  It is always
okay to ask basic questions.
In the bottom right, there are
many neural networks working
with 2D and we're going to
unroll the thing.
Rather than a 2D image we'll
unstack the rows, when we
unstack them, we have
a vector that's 28 times 28
equals 780 something Pixels in a
line.  It is a simplification
that's all it is to import the
dataset, I didn't show the code
which is just to reshape it.  It
is in the notebook.
Now we'll build the model.
Here are concepts that will be
probably entirely meaningless to
you if you're brand-new to ML.
A funny thing about neural
networks, there are many
different types of
classifiers and most of my
background, I was really
invested in tree-based models
before deep learning was a
thing.
The reason I like tree-based
models like random forests, I
look at a tree and my brain
understands what the tree is
doing to classify the data.  I
get it.
It clicks.
Neural networks can be
counterintuitive.  It is hard to
describe s I'll tell you what
we're doing and take the course
to learn more.
We're defining a fully connected
deep neural network.   There are
two layers to see.  First we're
saying -- defining the model.
First we'll use the sequential
API which is the simplest to
define the model.  The model be
will a stack of layers.  The
first layer that we're stacking
on, it is going to be a dense
layer.  Dense means it is fully
connected.  .
I'll show you a diagram of this.
Sorry.  It is just one layer
network.  The notebooks have an
exercise where you can add a
second layer.
We have an output layer with 10
outputs and each will gather
evidence that the image we feed
through the
network corresponds to each of
the digits.  This slide -- I was
editing these slides last night,
this one is a little bit
different.  Here we have two
dense layers.  The point that I
want to mention,
there is a couple of points I
want to make.
One, this is the complete code
to define the network.  It is
code concise.
Two, broadly, the more layers
you add
to the network, the more
neurons, units
a layer, the more capacity the
network has.  The more patterns
it can recognize.  The problem,
the more things that the network
can recognize, the more likely
it can memorize the training
data.  In machine learning there
is tension between memorization
and  generalization, you don't
want to memorize the training
data but learn patterns that are
useful to classify digits that
you haven't seen before.  It is
very easy to get very high
accuracy on the training set by
building
a deep neural network with knew
Rones and training it for a long
time.  It is not necessarily the
right thing to do.  When you do
this, start simple and slowly
expand from there.
.
You then exile it, there is
two concepts, I'll get to the
optimizer in a second.  The lost
function, it is the objective
that the network is trying to
optimize.
Good  news, this is a fancy
word,
categorical cross entropy, you
feed an image of a tube through
the network and you have a
probability distribution overall
of the digits it could be.
With 10% probability it is a 0
and
with 5, it is a 1 #, with 90%
probability it is a two.  This
is a fancy word that compares
the things the network predicted
to the thing you wanted it to
predict and what you want it to
predict is all of the evidence
is on it too.
The other thing, the optimizer.
This is the method you're going
to train the network.  The truth
is, there is a whole bag of
different optimizers to use.
You don't have to westboundersy
on
what it means too much because
there are good defaults.  For
this, you'll use the category
Raleigh cross entropy and
rmsprop is good to start with.
There are goody faults.
Broadly, the way that the
network is
trained, using the gradients.
Here is how I think about this.
This is the simplest parameter
in my
head, if you think of linear
regression, you have points on a
plot and you're trying to find
the best fit line.  If you think
about from high  school, the
equation for the best fit line,
you have Y  equals MS plus B and
you have two parameters you're
trying to learn.  M is the
slope.  You have B, the
intercept.  For different values
of M and B you can calculate how
well the line fits the data and
look at the error.  There are
different ways to et cetera go
the error but maybe it is the
sum of the difference from the
line to the Pixels.
You can find the best fit line.
Nurl networks are trained in a
similar
way but you have hundreds of
thousands of parameters to learn
and they connect everything, and
the way they're trained,
using the gradient dissent and
there is a fancy diagram on the
right showing something that's
not relevant.   They all start
at random values and you adjust
them overtime until the network
is better at recognizing digits.
I'll point you to more
educational
resources in a second.
Here is the cool part.
Building your model is where
there are many, many machine
learning concepts that you have
to spend a lot of time learning.
The next three steps, they are
concepts that are involved with
running an experiment.   There
is -- here is the only
parameter.  You train the
model.  It is one line.  Fit, it
is synonymous with train.
We're training it using the
training images and labels.
Here is the only parameter that
really matters.
The good news is, this concept
is simpler.
So this epoch means a sweep over
the training data, one epoch
means that we're training all of
those at once.
Training a network is a bit like
tuning a guitar.   Think if you
have a guitar and you want -- it
starts  untuned.
You want to tune the strings to
hit a particular note.  You tune
it, you twist the wheel, you
think of that as an epoch and
you tune until a certain epoch
until you get a note.  If you
the keep going, it won't play
the right note and the string
will snap.  You have to stop
tuning it at a certain point.
you stop tuning it based on the
sound.   Neural networks are
exactly the same way.
There is basically one simple
plot and it is this that I
recommend you look hat while
you're training the networks.
On the Y we're seeing this loss,
this means error.
Loss is the same thing as error,
a fancy word for it.
We're trying to minimize the
error.  On the X, it is how long
we're  tuning the network in
terms of number of epochs.
If you notice, after a few
epochs, the loss reaches a low.
That's when the guitar hits the
right note.  If you keep
training, the loss will increase
again.
To find the right number of
epochs you make a plot like this
and plot the error
and look for the point of lowest
loss usually on the validation
data.
After that, you can evaluate
it.
Evaluate just means given new
data, classify it with the
network and take a look at the
accuracy in other metrics,
it is also one line of code.
When you train it, you can
specify the metrics you want
returned.  It is also just one
line of code.  There is syntax.
It you see the model.predict and
have an image.   The syntax is
funny, the model expects a batch
of data and a batch means it is
meant to predict on multiple
images at once.  You give it an
image and wrap it in a list and
that's just syntaxed to make it
happy.
We were making predictions on
the first image from the test
data and the
model, it gives back
probabilities that that
corresponds to different digits.
The lowest layer of the network,
you have all of the evidence on
the output nodes.  You find the
largest elements and that's the
prediction.  Here is predicting
it is a 7.
I'm going to give you a really
quick
overview of TF TF.data and hand
it over to Lawrence to tell us
more about  Eager.
Here is something to be aware
of, in TensorFlow there is many
ways to do things.  You should
always do the  simplest possible
thing that's adequate for the
problem.   Never -- basically
when starting with ML and
probably 90% of settings don't
worry about performance, try to
minimize the complexity.  Before
we wrote our hello world just
using the data in a pie format.
That's fine.  If we were working
with a much larger dataset or
reading images off of disk or
pulling them from the cloud
there is a lot of complexity and
the performance starts to
matter.
For example, there is lacy when
you pull images over network.
You want to hit a bunch of
servers at once or maybe you
want different threads.  You
have all types of functionality
to help you with things like
this.
A thing that happens, GPUs, TPUs
is
surprisingly fast and the la
la
latency, the question is can you
keep it Fed?  You have lots of
utilities to get the stuff,
prefetching it to the GPU if you
need to.
What we'll do, we imported this
and I'll wrap it up in a
dataset.
I'm creating a dataset from
slices, a fancy word which
basically tells it that hey,
this is a list of things and I
want every element in the list
to be an item on my dataset.
The next thing, you have a clean
API and I can say I want you to
shuffle the data.  Here the data
is the designed to work with
potentially very long lists of
things.  It could be an infinite
stream of data, you don't want
to shuffle the whole thing,
shuffle has a size for the
buffer.   I have a buffer of
1,000 elements to
shuffle them as they stream in.
Imbatch it up and get a batch of
32 things.   I'll show you very
briefly how you use it.
To use it, this is the plead
code by
the way, for images, labels,
print them out.  This looks
obvious to me and it is the way
things should work.
If you're new to TensorFlow it
didn't used to always work like
this.  If you have previous
experience in TensorFlow you can
take a look and notice nowhere
in this code is there a
session, no had placeholders,
I'm not mentioning Graph but
writing regular Python code and
the things just works.
This is eager execution, the one
thing I have to do, it is the
second line of code there, I
enable the thing, you need
to do this at the start of the
Python father notebook and now
you're running TensorFlow
eagerly which if you're starting
out, it is regular Python.  This
is the right way to use
TensorFlow.
It makes debugging much easier.
There's lots of reasons why
you would use graphs and we
still love graphs, there is
great talks from the developer
summit that goes into this em in
lots of details but when
hacking, definitely, definitely
do this.
For more context, all of that,
I have been talking for a while.
I'll hand it over to Lawrence.
>> LAURENCE MORONEY: Just a
quick survey of the crowd.   How
many software developers here?
We're at I/O, we figure ited we
would have a few.  That's good.
I have been working on
TensorFlow for a few months.  I
think forgetting started in
TensorFlow can be a little bit
difficult if you're coming from
software dev background and
started in any kind of ML can be
tricky.  There is so many new,
different concepts.  First of
all, there is all the math.  I
didn't understand this math when
I was in high school, now I have
to understand it again.  People
tell me about linear regressions
and my head explodes.  It is
learnable, something that you
can pick up.
Secondly, really the
programming model and what is
the programming model all about?
I come from a background of
traditional programming.  In
traditional programming, you
basically feed in the rules, you
feed in the data and you get
answers out so for example if
you're writing something like an
activity detector, am I walking,
running, biking, driving?  You
feed in rules about that based
on the speed.
I'm a very slow runner, it is
the 1.5-mile an hour, detecting
me as running, but Josh is a
fast runner.  So it would be --
it would think he's on a bike if
he's using my rules.  Those
things.  You're feeding the
data, the rules  in.  This is
what we have been doing for
years as  programmers.  When it
comes to inen learning, you have
to flip the axis on this a
little bit and change it to
this.   When it comes to machine
learning, this is all machine
learning is, you feed in the
answers and you feed in the data
and get back the rules.  When we
talk about training a model,
when we talk about building
these
models, what we're getting is a
blob that you can run inference
on and this blob that you run
inference on, it is effectively
has -- will give what you need
back out to you.
For example, in my example of
activity detection, if I walk a
lot, tell it I'm walking, it is
measuring my sensor data when
walking, if I run a lot, that
would be nice, right!  It if I
run a lot, feed in the back, I
bike a lot, drive a lot, go on
trains and airplanes and we feed
in the data and the answers
telling it, okay, right now I'm
walking, biking, on a plane,
then the idea behind machine
learning is that it will build
that blob for me which I can run
inference on, by doing that, it
is like okay, what am I doing
right now?  It will deduce what
I'm doing now from all of these
rules.
Instead of me trying to write
all of this, you know, I train a
system with data and with
answers and it gives me back
rules.
An example:  Let's building
something that will determine
from a picture what's a cat and
dog.  If I was doing it with if
then rules, I could do something
like, you know, if it loves you
unconditionally, no matter what
you  do, it is probably a dog.
If it is right in and out
plotting
your murder, it is probably a
cat.  Right now it is hard to
infer that from images.  I
couldn't think of what the rules
would be.  Sometimes you have an
image, if it has pointy ears it
is a cat but guess what, the dog
has pointed ears.  This is when
you start thinking about --
machine learning opens up the
new scenarios and ways that you
as a programmer can bring value
to your employers and to your
business.
Let's talk about the answers in
this case.
The answers here, it is this is
a cat.
I think it is a dog.  This has
pointy ears.  This guy.
This is clearly a cat.
Had this is a walking tongue but
also a dog.  This is what
happens after you feed after
midnight.  This is one of the
dogs in this set of the cats and
dogs.  I have got the data.
Here I'm giving the answers.
I'm telling the machine what all
of
these things are.  If I want to
as a programmer, all I have to
do is train the network by
giving it the answers, we call
them labels and the data.  As a
programmer, here is where it was
tough for me and I have only
very
recently been on TensorFlow
because first of all, you start
working in  Python, any
developers here for Python?  A
few of you.  It is a lovely
language but it is a
text editor rather than an ADE
and step through debugging, I
came from a
background with visual studio, X
code, Android studio.  It was a
big learning curve for me.  If
you go to graph-based execution,
you have the code and you load
up a graph and execute that
graph and what if
I have bugs in reading the data,
not reading it properly, if I
have not shuffled the data
properly f it is important as
was mentioned early on is to
shuffle the data or you can
insert a bias in the training.
I'm not a very good programmer.
I again lie like to write 2, 3
lines of code, step through
them, make sure they work, write
another, step through them, make
sure they work, that thing.
That was difficult for me to do
as a TensorFlow developer.
Switch to the laptop.  I want to
show why I'm really excited
about eager mode.
What I'm really excited about,
TensorFlow, it is -- I have
taken and Josh has written a
notebook with the cat versus
dogs and you can get this code
online and run it in the
notebook.  I'm running it in pie
chart because I'm not a very
good developer.  I want to write
a few lines of code, execute
them, write a few  more, and
this is a free community edition
which is what I'm running here,
if you use Android studio, it
looks familiar.
What I can do, I go in, run
debug.  I have to go, debug.
I'll debug cats versus dogs.
It starts to execute and I have
hit a break point.  it is
magical to me as a developer.
I hit the break point and I can
step through the code and see
what's going on in the code.
You know, I have hit another
break
point, I have shut one down
here, I execute that code until
the break point.  I see I'm
doing things correctly.  Okay,
my data directory is set up
properly.  I have defined my
labels, you know,
I'm going to put another -- I
have the break point there.
I'll Rundown to this break
point.  I can start looking at
what's going on in here.
I have the training images, if I
hover over that, it is too big
to print but I
look at this in the debugger,
but I see I have the arrays of
images.
The 0 here, it was cat number
921.
If I step through, eager
execution is giving me this -- I
hit a break point.  I didn't
want to hit.
I'm just going down to here.
We'll continue running.   If I
then step over this, it should
show me a cat.  Okay.   Okay.  I
have gotten this cat.  I'm
loading it in.  Is this the
right cat?  Have I written the
code badly?  Do I have the wrong
cat?  I say this is my training
data, I can
look at the cats, find cat
number 921 and hopefully it is
the same cat so I
know the code is working right.
Anyone else develop like this in
little steps?  Good!  It is not
just me.  I find it really,
really difficult to write a lot
of code in one sitting.  I have
to do baby step by baby step.
On 921, it is here, there it is,
it is the same cat.  I'm like
excellent!  I know my code is
working!
I know I'm loading properly from
my data.
I'll go through here, I can see
my load image code, what it is
doing, it is
reading the image, creating the
TensorFlow out of the image,
residing it to a smaller image
to use in training.  When you
come from a world where the
hello world in machine learning,
it is handwriting recognition,
you know, for me hello world was
S print F hello world, you know,
there was complicated scenarios
and it is complex scenarios and
it is brought down as a
developer.  We can start poking
through, looking at data in the
IDE and I understand what's
going on.
What I'll do, I'll just execute
the code a little bit more.
>> JOSH GORDON: A cool point on
this too, this load image
function, if you look at it, it
is TF operations.   We're saying
TensorFlow.read image.  These
are working exactly like they
would if you were using others,
because we're running eagerly,
this code is imperative and
executes right after you hit the
line.  You noticed when he was
hovering over
it, you see the data and not --
it is
concrete, not symbolic.
>> LAURENCE MORONEY: Of
course, if you're in Python and
like the console as well, a
thing that's nice, I have a
console window so if the
existing code is printed out to
the console, I can do that.
I'll step a little bit further
down and I want to go to the
training.  A nice thing that
Joshua is talking about, this is
it just an it rater in Python.
You know, I can step through, I
can take a look at what's going
on in the training.  I can look
at this batch by  batch.  If I
have 6,000 images I'm loading
in, I have split that into
smaller batches and then once I
have done all of those batches,
that's an epoch and I can go
through, I can look at my epochs
and look at the training and
step into it.   I can sea breeze
going on as I step into it --
>> Another quick point. to
show you how fast this is
evolving, you notice the value
of the images and values as of I
think a few days ago, it is no
longer necessary f you can fit
the models with the datasets so
you no longer need that
intermediate step so that's
great.
>> Thank goodness it still
works.
>> Yes!
>> A neat thing about it, of
course, because tenser flow is
Open Source, if you want to know
what's going on with your
training, maybe something is --
maybe you have loaded data
causing it to crash or something
along those lines, as you do
this, as you ex compute these
things -- let's see if I can do
it -- I have to hit pause at
some point and I
have jumped into the tenser flow
source code and not only can I
step through my source to see
what's goingen o, I can
jump in to the TensorFlow source
so maybe I have triggered a bug
or maybe
I'm doing something wrong and
TensorFlow is not cooperating
and I can if I it and
this is made by eager
anticipation and TensorFlow and
Python.  You have to use the
TensorFlow version 1.
8 and later and don't use the
executing eagerly.
>> Cryptic air messages are
mostly a thing of the fast.
The third promise --
>> Yes. Thank you very much.
I spent a lot of time in
eclipse, I like it a lot.
Before -- anyway -- to learn
more about the concepts.  I'll
recommend two sources.  First,
we have a machine learning crash
course, it is good, short.
This is probably a day, two days
of your time full time.  It
doesn't teach about ML but it is
a
solid, introduction of what is
lost.  I would like to recommend
a book, buy
a Googler and I will
mispronounce the name, it is a
wonderful, wonderful book, deep
learning with with Python.
There are many, many books with
very similar titles to deep
learning with Python.
The one you want is written by
francois, published by manning
and comes with a collection of
June tar notebooks
which are freely available on
github
that will teach you how how to
use this, because they're a part
of TensorFlow flow, all of the
the code will work with no
changes rather than the imports
and
that's a solid foundation and
then later you can learn about
FT data and advanced
features of TensorFlow to do
even more.  It is a wonderful
starting point.
Another thing to, I wanted to
show
TensorFlow GFSs on this, with
the model, you can do model.
save, one line of code, model.
save, you have some path,
whatever, you save the model to
disk.
Using the sensor flow, they have
the tutorials showing you how to
import relatively easily the
processer.
So the same APIs are compatible
across the platforms.
Check out colab regardless of
TensorFlow or not, TensorFlow is
a valuable resource.  Its
wonderful in educational context
if you're teaching after work,
something like that, students
can jump right in.
Check out the workshops, in the
next three months or so, we'll
be updating a lot of our
tutorials in TensorFlow but in
the meantime I'm hacking
Examples together so you can see
what it looks like.
We have an education --
>> LAURENCE MORONEY: Some
really fun demos, we can
actually train it to recognize
the face going left, right, up
and down and you pay pacman
going like this.  Its cool.
>> JOSH GORDON: Super cool.
>> LAURENCE MORONEY: Take a
look and it is Open  Sourced.
>> JOSH GORDON: Thank you. It
is early.  We'll be around
afterwards as long as you be
want to take  questions.Thank
you very much.  We hope this is
useful to you.
Thank you.
on the
Web
.
>> JOHN PALLETT: Hello. Good
morning.  Wow.   Interactive
crowd today!  Great!
>> AUDIENCE: Good morning!
>> JOHN PALLETT: You don't
even need a mic.  That's
incredible.
Welcome to the talk on Awesome
web media.  I'm John Pallett.
I'm a project manager on the
Chrome media team.  We'll talk
about several topics.  We have a
great talk.  For my part, I'll
talk about a if you updates in
the ecosystem and API updates
and changes in Chrome.  After
that, Jennifer will go into a
really important topic of web
media consumption, multitasking,
as more and
more viewers are using the
computers to consume media and
do other things at the same
time, it is really an important
topic.
Finally, Zoe Llu has an update
on video compression.
It is amazing stuff, I don't
want to steal her thunder,
she'll cover more details later.
If you attended last year, you
heard us say this is the decade
that's transformed consumption
of media, particularly in the
video space and the web has been
a big part of that.
Every day 30,000 hours of video
is consumed in Chrome.   That's
just video, not including audio.
There is a massive amount of
media
consumption across a very wide
range of  sites.
The ways that users are
consuming that media is
continuing to change.
That's driving new APIs that we
in the
Chrome team need to add and
support.  For example,
progressive web apps have made
an interesting difference for
media companies because it gives
them a way to
get to users that have limited
storage capability.  It let's
them get to them without
requiring app install.
For example, Instagram doubled
their retention of web users
when they larged
the progressive web app last
year -- when they launched.
An important case that's
relevant over the last couple of
years on the web is offline
media consumption.  As more and
more people get access to mobile
devices, they really want to
watch media or listen to media
and they want to do it even in
places where Internet access is
not available.   This is really
important in countries
like India and sites are adding
support for off 9-1-1 line play
back using some of the new web
APIs.
In this case, -- support for
offline play back
They're downloading to the
device and then they're able to
watch it offline.  This is
really coming together partly
because of progressive web apps
and the underlying APIs that
make it possible.
We covered a lot of this last
year at I/O and for those of you
that couldn't
make, it, the message, it was
that the mobile web is really
ready for media.
You can do great things with
media playback on the mobile
web.
For this talk, we're going to
There is a representative
assemble of what's available in
the link above and I encourage
you to check it out.
talk about some different
things.  Let's talk about
desktop.  What I want to do is
talk about a recent change that
addresses something
that users have been complaining
about for years.  That is
autoplay.  When a user goes to a
site and it
unexpectedly plays audio that's
not good.  In fact, we can track
this.   We know that a
significant percentage
of media that starts playing
when a user first visits a site
without them interacting with
the site tall is shutdown within
6 seconds.   That's shutdown by
either a pause or closing the
tab or  muting, doing something
like that.
We recently launched a new
policy in Chrome to address
autoplay.  It applies when the
user first arrives to the site.
This does not take effect after
they have interacted with the
site, if they click on it, tap
on it, the autoplay policy is
not applied.  The policy applies
when the user first arrives at
the site.
When a user arrives, muted
autoplay is always allowed.  If
you're wondering what can I
safely do, the answer is you can
do things that don't play audio.
If you have a video element, you
can play it.  There are a few
cases where you can also play
audio when a user first arrives.
Of course, after a click or a
tap, it is fine, you can play
audio.  When a user first
arrives, there are a couple of
situations where you can play
audio.
The first, if your app is a
progressive web app on mobile
and the user is launching it or
has it installed from the home
screen.  In this case, when they
launch this, autoplay with sound
is allowed.
The second case on desktop, it
is that
Chrome is learning which sites
users go to and it looks to say,
wait a minute,
if a user is going to this site
and  playing media most of the
time on this site with sound,
after a click, a tap,
they want media with sound on
that site.  Over time as a user
browses, Chrome will identify
the sites and say, okay, we'll
allow autoplay on a site where
the media is usually being
played with sound.  This is an
interesting case for Chrome
where it has the ability to
personalize the experience for
the user.
In fact, we launched this a few
weeks ago and as I mentioned, we
get a strong signal on autoplays
that are not wanted.  We know
that the ones that are shutdown
quickly are the ones that users
don't want.
We looked at the results after
this
and saw half of the autoplays
get blocked.
That's not 100%, that's half.
Why only half, it is partly
because Chrome is learning and
it doesn't always get things
right.  It is a massive user
benefit.  We cut out half of
unwanted autoplays when users go
to sites.  For you, the
developer what this means, it is
that you cannot always expect
that audio will just work if you
start playing it when the user
arrives at a site.  What this
means, what a user -- when a
user lands on the page, you
won't know
if autoplay with sound will work
until after the user gesture, a
click or tab.
After a click or tap, you're
fine, when the user arrives
first, you won't know.  If
you're using a video, audio
element, the way to detect it is
to look at the results from the
play premise.   You can tell by
looking at the results whether
or not autoplay started and if
it wasn't, if you tried to you a
toe play something with sound,
you know
that you can then try to play it
without sound.  If what you're
doing is hosting
embedded videos, so videos that
are in a cross origin timeframe
and you want them to have the
ability to autoplay in
situations where they're allowed
to, you
want to add a new attribute to
the frame, the allow equals
autoplay attribute.  This does
not mean that embedded videos
can always autoplay.  It means
that if you have a frame on your
site and the site gets the
ability to autoplay, then the I
mean, frame gets the ability to
autoplay.  If you don't include
this attribute, in I embedded
video in the cross origin
timeframe won't be allowed to
autoplay even if they say we
want to, they can't do it.  The
policy will prevent them.  If
you're embedding videos and you
want them to autoplay in sound
when Chrome allows it, use the
allow  equals autoplay
attribute.
The final thing here, web
audio.  What we're looking at
here, an example
of a web audio site and it is
typical which creates audio
context on load,
that's the top half of the code
up top.  What the assumption is
here, that audio will always
work when the user first arrives
at the site.  As I said, that's
no longer a valid assumption.
The good news  is, what will
happen under the hood, something
that you can
react to within o with only a
small change.  If you start the
audio context and don't know
whether or not it is running,
what you can do, you look for
the user interaction on the
site, a click or a tap and call
will resume on the audio
context.   On that point, the
audio will continue to work.
The other thing you can do, I
don't have the code sample up
here, you can actually check the
state of the audio context to
determine whether or not it was
blocked by the autoplay policy.
Check this state, if it is
running, then audio is playing.
If it is suspended, it is not.
That gives you an opportunity to
do things like update mute
controls to
reflect whether or not audio is
actually  playing.
I want to pause for a second to
say our team is, woulding hard
to improve
things for users and -- is
working hard to improve things
for users and developers.  We
could have done a better job of
communicating this policy change
to developers using the web
audio API, if you have questions
on this particular change, we're
available both at the web audio
office hours at 12:30 and in
addition, we have media office
hours
today at 6:30 and tomorrow at
1:30.  If you're not here at
I/O, if you're watching at home
or want more information on the
policy changes, the link on the
bottom on this slide, it has
everything I just talked about.
It also has more information
than you will want as you debug
the website
including instructions to
completely
disable or completely enable the
op
policy to
autoplay policy, if you don't
have this or don't get a picture
before I move to
the next slide, you can go to
developers.google.com and search
for autoplay.
What we recommend for the user
experience, what it should look
like.  The ideal situation from
our perspective is that when
users arrive and if you're not
allowed to autoplay with sound,
mute the media, play it to drive
user engagement.  When you get a
user gesture, ideally give the
user control to unmute the media
and they can turn on the sound.
Tapping or clicking on that
control will give you autoplay
policy and allow you to start
playing with sound.
Another alternative, move to a
click to play model.   Capture a
user gesture and then start
playing sound.
This is common, we have seen
this on a number of sites and it
will work under the current
policy.  That's it for autoplay.
Let's switch to Jennifer that
will talk about something
completely
different, multitasking.
>> JENNIFER APACIBLE: Thank
you.
I'm Jennifer Apacile, and I'm
a software engineer on the
Chrome team.  We have
multitasked while consuming
media, this could be anything
from watching a movie while
responding to emails, to
listening to live sports
commentary while cooking.  Some
of you on live stream may tune
in while doing something else.
Now as we started to spend more
time on our devices multitasking
has evolved where the screen
that we're using may be the
media screen or at least the one
used to control it.
Last year, we introduced the
media session API which allows
you to show
metadata and images on lock
screens and wearable devices.
This is great for users because
they know what's playing and
will be able to control it.
Let's take a quick refresher on
how to use it.
First, we'll check to see if
the device or browser supports
media session, and if so we'll
use it.  To make things appear,
we simply need
to provide
the metadata and the title,
artist and you can set up action
handlers, backward, forward,
play, pause, next track,
previous track.   We may also
want to control the play back
state.  If you're serving custom
controls you can also reflect
the media session state
outside of the lock screen or
notification.   What about the
desktop experience?
Personally I spend the majority
of the time on the computer
consuming media.  At the same
time I like to keep busy such as
messaging friends or reading the
news.  I find that whenever I
want to watch a video on the
computer I'll resize the window
to be really small and then move
it to the corner of the screen
so it doesn't get in the way of
everything else I want to do.
At the same time, I struggle
with covering that window with
one of the many other windows I
have open.  Sound familiar?
Today I'm excited to share that
we're
bringing Picture-in-Picture to
Chrome.
The window will appear on top of
other windows allowing you to
consume view while continuing to
interact with other content on
your device.   You will also be
able to interact with the window
such as with the play pause
controls, resizing, moving the
window to your liking.
You may remember that last
year we launched
Picture-in-Picture on mobile
with Android O with the native
API.  Today we're building a web
API allowing developers to
create and control the
experience around
Picture-in-Picture.   This will
be available for Chrome, on
desktop and on  Android.
Let's take a look at how to use
this.
First we'll need two things:
We'll need the window, video and
a way for the user to interact
with it.  Today we'll use a
button.
To start us off, let's enter
Picture-in-Picture.  We'll start
by adding an event listener to
the button.
When the button is clicked a
video will request to enter the
Picture-in-Picture mode.  Why
stop there?
Let's make it fun entering and
exiting Picture-in-Picture.
First we'll check if the
document's Picture-in-Picture
element is the video, if it
isn't, we'll send a request to
enter in the Picture-in-Picture
mode.   Otherwise, we'll leave.
Which means that the video will
abeer
peer back in the original tab --
appear.
The request Picture-in-Picture
function returns a promise and
if the video fails to enter
Picture-in-Picture mode for any
reason we should let the user
know.  The feedback of the user
is a great
way of letting them know what's
going on.
We can listen for two events,
enter Picture-in-Picture and
leave Picture-in-Picture.  By
setting event handlers he can de
pine the experience for the
users showing other content on
the page more
prominently, anything from
showing a
catalog of videos that you can
later watch or servicing live
stream chat.  Finally, in cases
where Picture-in-Picture is not
supported we can hide the button
so that the user
doesn't try to interact with it.
While Picture-in-Picture is
still
under development, you can check
it out Todd on Chrome Canary
with the flags enabled, the
first will be the web API and
the next two will be used to
enable the future.  You can find
out more about the API
and implementation status at
these links.
Let's say we have multiple
screens.  Imagine if you were
presenting in a meeting and you
wanted speaker notes or you
wanted to share photos and
videos to a large group of
people but you only had a small
laptop.
Presentation API makes displays
such as monitors and TVs
available to the  web.
Previously this is only
available for remote devices
such as Chromecast, but today we
now also account for wire
displays such as HDMI monitors.
With presentation API we can
build
experiences for it's user
users to see and control local
content and present other things
on the screen.  We won't be just
mirroring what's on the screen
to the other monitor.
Let me walk you through how to
use the presentation API to
present a webpage on a secondary
screen.  There are two
components needed to get this to
work, the controller and the
reserver.  The controller is the
page that we'll use to interact
with on the local -- on the
primary screen.  The receiver
consents will be displayed on
the other screen.
Today we'll call these
components receiver and
controller.  Let's put together
a controller page.
Let's create a presentation
object that will contain the URL
we want to show on the secondary
screen.
This could also be a absolute
URL or pass in a list of them.
Today we'll use the receiver.
HTML.  With our presentation
requests, we can get the
availability of the displays
or the second screens and handle
them however we want.
We should continue to handle
display availability changes by
adding event listener to the
change events.  This may happen
when monitors are disconnected
or we move to a network without
devices.
To show the presentation display
prompts we require a user
gesture, a click on a button,
with that in mind, let's start
our presentation request when a
user alcoholics on the button.
We'll wait for the promise to
resolve when the user selects a
display.  This promise will
return a presentation connection
and when that
happens the page we put in
earlier, the receiver HTML will
be presented to the other
display.  Once we have this
active connection we can do two
things.  We can close it or
terminate it.  Closing the
connection allows us to
reconnect later and terminating
the
connection means it is gone for
good.  How do you reconnect to
the presentation?  We do it by
calling reconnect and
passing in the presentation ID
of the previous connection
object.  There are two options
of how we want to handle this.
We can either automatically
reconnect
when the controller navigates or
we can reconnect when the user
clicks on a button.
We can also register event
handler for the presentation
connection events.
Connect, message,  close,
terminate.
With that in mind, we now have
the
components ready for our
controller to work
Next we want to have the
controller and the receiver
interact with each other.  On
the reserver side, let's first
retrieve all existing
connections and listen to any
incoming ones.  We'll keep track
of these as they come in.
Every time we add a connection,
we'll add event listeners such
as message and close events.  So
what does this look like put
together?  Our team published
this web app called photowall
showcasing the presentation of
API.  We used the controller to
select photos that we want to
add to the slide show and the
receiver to present it.
To get us start on the
controller, we'll use the
presentation requests and
retrieve the list of receivers.
Those are selected when you have
the presentation connection and
when connected the controller
will prompt us
to add images to the slide show.
What's more interesting than
searching for photos of dogs,
here picking a photo will add it
to the queue of images to share
on the slide show.  How do we
get that information to the
receiver?
We'll send a message between the
controller and receiver and vice
versa.
It could be a string, a buffer
or a ray buffer view.  In our
example, the controller will
send the description or the name
of the dog as well as the image
source to the receiver.   Upon
receiving this message, the
receiver will then handle it by
updating the slide show to
include the image.
What happens when we send these
to the receiver?  We'll get
something like this.
That's all we really need to
get started with presentation
API.  The APIs are already
available on
Chrome, check it out.
Media session, presentation API
and Picture-in-Picture, we
believe these are great editions
to the web media story.   You
can check out all of the APIs at
these links and we always love
feedback.  Let us know what you
think.
I'll hand it back to John.
>> JOHN PALLETT: I was saying
I didn't know you were putting
my face up there.  Thank you for
that.  Anyway.
The presentation API, that's
actually a really interesting
Example of how Chrome can work
across multiple displays.  If
you have multiple displays,
Chrome can use presentation API
and another capability in Chrome
for doing things with other
displays, and that's casting
Chrome.   Casting Chrome will
let you play
media or mirror the tab or
desktop to cast devices such as
Chromecast or a TV.  Let's talk
about mirroring for a second.
The thing about mirroring, if
you're mirroring a tab, what
you're doing, you're rendering a
tab and then you're capturing it
and then encoding it and sending
it over to the remote device.
If you're playing media, that's
an awful lot of work just to
capture the media, grab it,
encode it again, send it over to
the device which will then
decode it.  There's been an
important change here that
landed in Chrome during tab
mirroring, if the user goes full
screen with the video, that
eliminates most of the steps I
mentioned, no need to decode,
capture, end code.  Chrome is in
the middle, sending the frames
directly to the device without
modifying them in any way.  From
a user perspective they have
play become control in Chrome
like before but rather than the
video  playing on the local
display they'll see this.  .
This is good in some cases but
there are some cases where you
don't want the Chrome to remote
a full screen video.
For example, if you're doing
spherical video you're taking a
canvas,
rendering with web GL on top of
it a piece of geometry with the
video mapped on to it.  That's
good.  Behind that,   you may
have a full screen video element
including the entire video
that's effectively a texture
map.
You probably don't want that
video to be sent to the
television.  If you see this on
the site, it is very easy to
prevent it, it is an a I tribute
to add to any element, disable
remote play back and Chrome will
respect that.
If you don't want media remote
to work on a video element add
this attribute.  Why are we
doing this?  It is because it is
a significant optimization and
it happens automatically.  If
you look at the middle metric,
you
see the CPU goes down
dramatically
because we're skipping a decode
and a decompression step, if you
look at this, the play back
smoothness increases
significantly and freezing is
better as well.  Then the bottom
two metrics show the video
quality itself is better because
we're not decoding and
reencoding the video.  The less
the chrome touches the video the
better.  It let's you send the
original
compressed video directly to the
device.
That video is only good if the
settings are good and the
algorithm you're using for
compression is good
which is a good segue to Zoe Llu
who
will talk about the updates on
AV1.
>> ZOE LLU: Today I'll talk
about AV1.
Video has been one of the
significant
experiences over the web.
That's been used with intensive
bandwidth by users.  Compression
is the technology behind
the scenes that powers this
growth.  .
Why video code matters, this is
an example.  This is a minute of
high-definition
video with a size of 300
megabytes and
this is what we observed.  There
is a compressed version as
opposed to the unexpressed
version which
is as large as 25 gigabytes,
almost 100 times large.
For video, it can be 10 times
larger
and therefore compression as a
technology, without compression,
there
is almost no possible for any
video service over the Internet
and our users notice the result.
.
Back in
2013 there was a rollout as
opposed to
at the time, the code, the VP9
achieved
the 30% performance.
So here is a global map of the
watch
time of VP9 compared to that of
H.264.
As you see from the slide, the
darker
the color is, the longer
watching time by VP9 opposed to
H.264.
The reason for watching longer
with 9, it is three folds, first
it is the
fast loading time, secondly, the
less
buffering, and thirdly, the
higher
quality delivery.
The size of VP9 has helped our
users with longer usage.
The success of VP9 hat not gone
unnoticed.
The most recent video has been
developed by the Alliance for
Open Media, short as AOM.
It is a fourth generation code,
AV1.  AOM as you can see from
the slide
included the top media and
technology
companies from almost every
aspect of the industry.
Here you can see we have the web
platforms, the common providers,
hardware makers.
There are three goals to develop
AV1.
First we wanted to develop a
code for the web even though
that's been increasingly
overlapped with the TV, security
media, and all of the add
industries.
The same kind of target for AV1
is to
have
open -- it is a significant
change for the industry.
The last goal of AOM is to have
a real
deployment, so it is a target to
be   supported widely across all
platforms
and to be developed as a much
faster pace.
Here is a landscape of pretty it
complicated -- this is a major
area that
we had felt with the environment
of AV1
and we have developed over 100
compression technologies for
AV1.  Today I'm mainly going to
talk about two of them.  We're
going to have a little bit
deeper dive of the following two
technologies.
The first one is a wedge base
interprediction.  Here is a clip
-- here is a frame from
a video clip and this is the
next one.
For this two set of frames, you
can see a lot of similarity
between them.  The major task of
a video coder is to
remove the similarity between
them.  Most commonly, one of the
most
commonly used tools, it is
called Block hopping.
You can look at the previous for
the curve one to look at the
compression.  However, you look
closely, the shape
of the block, which is square,
it is not aligned well with the
object of the boundary.
If you look closely, somehow if
we can
introduce a wedge-based shape
which can be a lot better
aligned with the
boundary of the object as seen
in the  frame, there could be a
lot of potential
that we can have a fuller
compression.
Therefore, here is the
compression
update that we refer to as
wedge-based interprediction.
This is the first time that's
been
introduced by the video code and
for the first time it was
introduced both with
the square-based and rectangular
based
wedge interwedge for the
interprediction.   Because it is
better alignment with
the boundary of the object as we
just
showed, there is significance
that's been obtained.
The next two we'll talk about,
it is about the warped motion.
Let's look at a nice example.
Here is the frame.
Again, from a video clip and
there's
a notation for the next frame.
How do we describe this
location, and
then to obtain a compression so
that the
general use of the tool is to
describe
the motion info of all of the o
blogs
that carry this notated project.
If you look closely, there is
another way.
If somehow we can only signal
those
emotion info for the logs
located in the
top left boundary of this
located object.
Well, if there's a way we can
have the
motion info for the remaining
blocks of this object from the
surrounding Blocks within a
window, there could be a lot of
potential for us to have a
better compression.
Here is another tool to
introduce -- you have the local
warped motion.
AV1 has used a mathematical
model here
as the example of an affine
model and
then to see the type of block
from the
motion info from the surrounding
Block where you have the window.
In this way, a more effective
decision
to compress technology so that a
better
code again could be achieved.
To summarize all the
technologies we
have introduced in AV1, here is
the
result to compare
AV1 with
1, there is 30% improvement for
AV1 for
two scenarios, the video on
demand and the live streaming.
Here is another presentation of
this
result for comparing AV1 as
opposed to
VP9 obtained by Google.
Independent comparisons have
been conducted by Facebook
mainly on top of
their user generated content up
lo he
haded to their Facebook website.
Again, it has to be obtained and
achieved can be observed from
the slide.
Furthermore, you can observe
that with the requirement of
resolution, a
larger advantage of AV1 can be
observed
as opposed to 9 and another
State of code that's used for.
It can be expected that AV1 can
have a
larger gain for larger
resolution.
The last evaluation that we're
demonstrating down here, it is
conducted
by MSU who rolled out a
comparison result report for
almost all the top
video code collected.
They yearly conducted an
extensive comparison, especially
concerning
different categories such as the
encoder
speed, the quality metrics, as
well as
the strategies and also within
the
performance of the code.
This year, they include a
comparison
with AV1 # that can be seen
closely, they report a
consistent result for the
advantage of AV
What's New in Wear OS by Google
>> Welcome to the What's New in
Wear OS by Google.  I'm Dennis
Troper and I'm the product
director for Wear OS and I'm
really, really excited to be
here today.
Let me start with a little bit
of history.  By the way, I need
the  clicker.
You know, when we first started
Wear OS four years ago, we went
out to see what people were
wearing.  What we found was a
tremendous amount of diversity
out there.
People really care about what
they wear, it evokes their
passion, their style, their
personality.  The same goes with
what you wear on your wrist.  It
is a really, really personal
choice.
From the start, we made a
decision to
bring lots of choice diversity
into the wearable space.  Today
we couldn't be more pleased how
this strategy has played out.
We have over 50 watches that are
powered by Wear OS today out in
the
market from top brands
and many others.  Let me show
you some of the recent
launches of watches we have
introduced
in the market with our partners.
Back in the fall, for the
holiday
season of
2017Misfit launched their Misfit
Vapor smartwatch.  The team did
a great job with this watch.
It has a very sleek, stylish
design.  It fits great on your
wrist and makes for a great
fitness watch.
This past January, Kate Spade
launches the Kate Spade New
York.
It is a beautiful watch and
users love the choose your look
app that matches
your outfit with your watch
face.
This past March Hublot
introduced a
limited edition smartwatch
called the Big Bang Referee
2018.  It is a beautifully
crafted smartwatch.
Its body made out of titanium.
With a theme that celebrates the
most
popular sport in the world,
soccer.  Really excited about
this  watch.
I'm a big soccer fan myself.
Get this, referees are going to
be
wearing the big bang referee at
international matches to help
them
connect with the latest goal
line technology and that's
really, really cool.
We're really excited about all
these new watches coming to
market.  We have built a lot of
momentum with
our  partners to give you a
sense of that.
In 2017 we launched 26 new
watches, that's twice the number
of watches we launched the
previous year.
An interesting stat, we're now
seeing
a lot of iOS users users in the
Wear OS platform.
We grew 148% year-over-year in
iOS
users and today one out of three
new Wear OS users activate their
watches with an iPhone.
This is why last month we
decided to
change our name from Android
Wear to Wear OS by Google.
We want a brand name that really
reflects the great diversity of
users we have in our platform as
well as the wide range of
choices of watches that are out
there.  We're really happy with
the new name, our partners are
really happy with it
and users are loving it as well.
You know, we have learned a
thing or
two over the last few years
working in the wearable space.
I want to share a key insight
with you, it is a simple one,
perhaps an obvious one.  The way
people use watches today is
very, very different from how
they use phones.  They're very
different in how people interact
with them, how long they use it,
how often they use it and what
they use it for.  With a phone,
first of all, you carry
it with you all the time
.  You have two hands to
interact with
it, it has a large spring, and
you can spend a long time with
it playing games,
doing social media, responding
to an email.  With watches, it
is a very different story.
With watches, you use it, you
carry with you on your wrist all
day long but you use it very
sporadically.  When you use it,
it is just for very
short moments to get some
information, and then the faster
you can be back doing what
you're doing in the real world,
the better.
We have taken these learnings
to heart
in how we think about our
platform going forward.  We're
now focusing on three very
important areas to improve the
user experience.   Let me walk
you through them.
First, connection at a glance.
Second, health and fitness.
Thirdly, it is convenient help
from the Google Assistant.
Let's start with connection at a
glance.  You know, in this day
and age people
are expected to be connected all
the time.  As I said before, we
carry our cellphones most of the
day, but there are some cases in
which pulling out your cellphone
is inconvenient or sometimes we
just don't have it with us.  For
example, when you go out on a
run,
on a bike ride, or if you go to
a fancy
dinner dressed in an outfit with
no pockets.  In any of these
occasions, you still
want to be connected to the
people and the information you
really care about.
You know, I myself, I'm the
father of five  kids.  I also
like mountain biking.  I can
tell you from experience, having
to put my cellphone in my
backpack where I carry water is
just really inconvenient.
Watches, smartwatches fill this
gap really neatly.  They're very
easy toic a ses, there is a lot
of computing power in here and
this is one of the key reasons
why users love wearing Wear OS
watches, it is to help them have
the peace of mind that they can
be free from their phone, Burr
still be connected to the
information or
the people that they really care
about.
This is an area that's really
important, connection at a
glance.
We're doubling down on it to
increase the user experience and
to bring more to our users.
To give you a few examples of
things we introduced recently
with notifications and
connections, I'll show you real
quick  here.
Recently we introduced adaptive
text
sizing which essentially allows
the glancablety of notifications
to be much, much better.
When you receive a short text,
the size of the text gets bigger
so it is easier for you to read
it.
We also introduced recently
darker
backgrounds and a new phone type
so we can increase the
readability and fit
more information on to the
screen at a glance.  We have
also done things to improve our
complications.
Complications, it is the
bite-sized
chunks of information that sit
right on your watch face and
they're very handy little tools.
I myself, I use the Agenda
complication a lot.  It helps me
many times during the day to
tell me where I need to go next
for my meetings.
We have done more, because we
think it is an important area
for people to stay connected.
Very recently we introduced the
notification preview
complication.
This is a very handy
complication that
brings the top ranked
notification right on the watch
face.  Things like breaking
news, a chat message, your next
appointment will be
right there on your watches with
this complication.  We also
introduced another complication
we called the recently launched
app complication.  This is one
where it is very handy when you
have types of information that
you like to access frequently
throughout the day.  For
example, the weather, checking
the scores of a live game.
This is a few examples of things
we're doing to increase the
experience for
connections at a glance and as I
said before, we're doubling down
in this area and you should
expect a lot more from us
in the months to come.
Next is health.  You know,
health and fitness, it is
one of the most important
reasons why people buy a
smartwatch today.  People want
to be healthy.  Of course, and
we at Wear OS are very committed
to helping people lead healthier
lives.  We're doing more with
it.
We're helping, working
tirelessly to give users the
ability to track their health
much
better than ever before, and to
also
offer them a superior experience
to track their active fitness.
Let me show you a few examples
of
things we have done recently.
Very recently, we launched a
feature touch lock.  It is a
great feature, for example, if
you go on a swim, you go out on
a run on
a rainy day and you're tracking
your
workout with Google Fit or any
other
application like my swim pro,
strava,
run keeper, with touch lock
enabled, what happens your
screen basically gets disabled,
the touch screen gets disabled
to avoid any unintended
behaviors while
your watch is in constant
contact with water.  To disable
touch lock all you have to do,
click on the button and you're
back into normal mode.  Next is
music.
You know, music is a huge deal
for many people when they're
working out.
It helps them stay motivated and
energized.
We have made accessing the
media controls easier than ever
before, you scroll down from the
screen and get
to the immediate media controls
which will help you power you
through the rest
of your workout.  We're doing a
lot more with the heart rate
sensor.  We recently introduced
continuous heart rate monitoring
so you can check
your heart rate many times
during the
day and you can compute your
resting heart rate from Google
fit.  This is just a few samples
of things we're doing in health
the and fitness.
As I said before, we're helping
people
lead healthier lives, that's
core to our
mission, and we're working
really hard in many aspects of
health and fitness
and we'll be bringing a lot new
features in the coming months.
Stay tuned.
The last pillar we're focused
on, the assistant.   Convenient
help from the assistant.  You
know, today, unlike traditional
watches that only give you --
they're very good at giving you
the time.
With smartwatches, you expect to
get the best out of the time.
For example, in my case, very
busy during the day.  I quickly
look at the phone and am
able to check when the next
train leaves for San Francisco
so I can be home in time for my
daughter's soccer game.   We're
working really hard to improve
the experience for the assistant
to
optimize for the risk form
factor.  In a few short minutes
I'll invite Tom
to come on stage and I'll tell
us more about what we're working
on here with the Assistant.
There you have it, the three
areas we're focused on to
improve the user experience,
connections at a glance,
health and fitness, convenient
help from the Assistant.
In order to do this really well,
we
require a very solid and robust
foundation.  Here I'm talking
about things like
power, connectivity,
performance, companion apps that
go along with a device, so on.
Let me highlight three of them
very  quickly.
First, iOS.  As I said, we're we
will.
Coulding a lot of iOS users and
we want them to have a great
user experience just like
anybody else that's wearing a
Wear OS watch.
Very recently, for example, we
introduced a brand-new iOS
companion app
that brings Google Fit summary
stats right on the app so you
can see it from the comfort of
your own iPhone.  This is one
example of many things
we're doing to improve the iOS
experience.
Next, power.  Power is really,
really important when
it comes to smartwatches and
we're
working across the Wear OS to
optimize the battery
consumption.  Right after Tom
we'll invite my colleague Rati
and she'll tell us a lot more
about what we're doing with
Android
P and how this has a positive
impact in power.
Lastly, I would like to
highlight that we're bringing
faster and more frequent updates
to the platform.  That's really,
really important for
our users, that they get
continuous improvements to the
watch constantly
throughout the year with wear 2.
0 we made changes to the
architecture so that pieces that
were considered to be
traditionally part of the OS are
you no updatable platform
components and as a
result of that, this past year,
in 2017,
we're able to do 11 releases to
the
platform and introduce 49
features and improvements.  This
year we're on track to do the
same, or even higher.  We're
introducing a lot of features
really, really fast and I'm
really
excited about that.
As I said before, the Google
Assistant is a key pillar we're
working on, really, really
important for us.  I'll invite
Tom on stage to tell us a
lot more about it.
Thank you.
>> TOM RUDICK: Thank you,
Dennis.
I'm Tom and I work on the
assistant for we're OS.  We want
the assistant to follow you
across all deviceses.  When you
interact with the assistant, it
should adapt to the device
you're using.
For wear, we want to provide an
awesome experience on your
wrist.  With the last update
this week we completely
redesigned the UI with three
major improvements I would like
to talk about.
First, we have an always present
microphone which automatically
reopens
to continue the conversation
with the  Assistant hands free.
Second, support for text to
speech.
If puff a pair of Bluetooth
headset or a wearable device
with a speaker, when you talk to
the Assistant, now it will speak
right back to you.
Lastly, my favorite, support for
suggestion chips.   Suggestion
chips allows you to breeze
through a conversation just by
tapping.
The biggest new edition for Wear
is support for actions on
Google.  Actions on Google allow
anyone to write a great wearable
experience without writing a
single line of Android
code, even better, most existing
actions already work on Wear OS
today without any changes.
Let's take a look at how this
works.  You may have already
used dialogue flow to build
actions for the assistant.  It
is a platform provided by Google
to turn natural language into a
format that you can go and build
cool stuff with.  Starting this
week, you can also use
Datalogflow to create actions
for Wear OS.  Best of all, we
have already done all
the hard work of building out
response templates appropriate
for wearable devices, you don't
even have to think about it.
If you haven't used Datalogflow
yet, it is super easy.   Just
yesterday I was creating my own
action.  I only had to define
this action once.  We'll work
across all supported devices.
Here is what it looks like on
mobile.  This may look familiar.
Here is an action icon on the
top, a  tappable list of the
Google sessions I plan to go to
and a suggestion chip at the
bottom.
This is how it looks on wear.
All the same components exist
and now they're  tailored for a
smaller, wearable form factor.
We didn't have to do anything
special
for this to happen, it just
works.
Even if you're going deeper, you
use the action SDK or a Webhook
for fulfillment, we have you
covered.  In this case, I'm
adding a new card to the
conversation that has more
information about this session.
This is how the card will render
on both phone and  Wear.  It
automatically resizes and looks
great regardless of which device
is being used.
So over the past few months,
we have been building and
testing a lot of actions.  We
have come up with best practices
to
help your actions look really
great on Wear.
Let's start with an example.
Okay, Google, ask when is the
next BART from Fremont to
Hayward.
The next BART from Fremont to
Hayward leaving at 11:21 a.m.
>> TOM RUDICK: Cool. We want
users to have glancable
interactions and get tasks done
quickly.  We want to allow users
to complete a task with a single
phrase.  In the previous example
I was able to get the
information I asked for by
speaking a single phrase.
Imagine if I had to specify all
of that information separately,
the train I wanted, the station,
the direction of travel, that
would take way too long and I
would be far more likely to pull
out my phone.  Keep the
dialogues short, concise,
task-oriented.
There are cases where having a
back and forth dialogue is
important and maybe even
required.
That's fully supported on Wear
today.  Try not to make it part
of the core user journey.
As you may have just heard, wear
now supports vocal responses.
They don't have to be the same
as a visual.
In the previous example, both
the visual response and the
vocal response tell me when the
next train leaves.   That's what
I asked for.  The visual
response goes a step further
showing a more detailed list of
departures.  That information
would probably be too
dense to read allowed vocally
but visually, it works really
well.
Independently, both the vocal
and visual response makes sense,
but together, they really
complement each
other and make an awesome
experience.
Keep in mind, that not all
devices support vocal feedback.
You can use surface capabilities
to tailor the experience to the
device that's being used.
Vocal responses are cool, but
a
favorite new feature is
suggestion chips.
I have
to admit, I'm nervous, the last
few times I came to Mountain
View it rained, I forgot the
umbrella, got soaking wet.
Let's ask the assistant how
things look even though it looks
nice today.  Google, do I need
an umbrella today?
This want I was planning on
going to a hike and I can use
suggestion chips to get that
information quickly, the weather
forwarded the weekend, I can
drag uppal on wherever the
microphone is
located  revealing the
suggestion chips and I can tap
on weather this weekend to
quickly get the forecast for the
weekend.  The weather looks
great.
I should bring my sunscreen.
I love suggestion chips.  Not
only are they a great way for
guiding users through a
conversation, they also allow
users to discover what
your agent can and cannot do,
provide example chips whenever
possible to guide
users through a conversation.
When thinking about how to
build your
action, be  user-centric.
Someone may be using your action
in a lot of different ways.
They may be on the go, the hands
may
be be full and vocal responses
may be more appropriate.  They
could be somewhere noisy,
suggestion chips are the easiest
way for
them to tap through an
interaction.
Design with all these use cases
in mind.
We have had a lot of fun
building supports for actions on
Google and you can get started
building your own agents today.
I'm so excited to see what
you're going to build.   If you
need inspiration, we have a lot
of great partner  demos in the
sandbox and you can come by and
check them out.   If you're
interested in building actions,
I recommend that you check out
the design actions for the
Google session that starts right
after this one
on Stage 2, don'ts go just yet,
up next is Rati to talk about
the platform updates.
>> RATI AGRAWAL: Thank you.
I'm a technical program manager
working on Wear OS.
We just showed how to build
really
cool assistant actions in Google
for our app Wear users, let's
move on to the platform updates
that we have.
With the new release we have
platform features helping you to
offer delightfully stable and
battery efficient experiences
throughout your
apps and help you build really
cool watch faces with a few
lines of code.
To begin, I would like to talk
about a
feature that's going to impact
you as a
DeVop.  We are looking to
improve the app
compatibility and to prevent
apps from breaking.   Wear OS is
adopting the restrictions
for the goal of making behavior
deterministic and stable.  This
is similar to what developers on
my team face just before a
product launch.   The deadlines
and restrictions can
make people a little unhappy as
they're
trying to meet deadlines but
come launch date the team is
happy with a stable, reliable
product that meets our users'
needs.
To check out the app compatible
ility lig,
compatibility link, to
understand what the changes mean
for the apps, moving on to
battery.
Battery is precious on mobile
and even
more so on wear.
Last year, we highlighted that
most watches have just a tenth
of the battery
capacity of a phone and we
shared best
practices on improving battery
life.  We have indicated that we
will look for ways to be more
aggressive than the
phone in addressing battery
usage.
This year we're moving beyond
the mobile platform and
introducing features to reduce
background activity and
aggressively turn off radios
when the user takes off the
watch and enhance battery saver
mode.
I'll walk you through some of
them.  This is a snapshot of the
app stand begin feature that was
introduced yesterday in what's
new in Android P.
On Wear OS, we're
experimenting with a more
aggressive platform change.
Apps not active will not be able
to
create jobs or alarms when not
on the
charger
even when they're in the active
bucket, they can only start
jobs or alarm if they're in the
foreground.   What do you mean
by foreground.
An active app running in the
foreground is an example.
A watch face currently active on
the
dial and complications on the
currently active watch face and
in rare  circumstances, say if
you're a health monitoring app,
a full ground service running on
the watch.
All of these can create jobs and
alarms.
If you are a developer, look at
these in
the preview and provide us with
feedback.
.
Battery saver mode, we're
enhancing the mode to go beyond
the phone platform to
aggressively squeeze the last
ounce of battery and to prevent
the watch from turning off on
users' wrists during the day.
In this enhances version of
battery saver mode, we'll be
turning off all
radios, touch, tilt detection
and we'll
be defaulting to a battery watch
face.
Users are pressed to read the
time and
long press to resume full
operation.  This could be
particularly helpful if the
watch is running low on battery,
but
you want to quickly be able to
turn it
back on to make a payment or to
check an important message.
Continuing with efforts to
improve
battery life, last months we
moved to a team for the system
app.
Apps as mentioned by Dennis
earlier.  This teaming has the
duel benefit of
improving glancablety and
accessibility while reducing
power consumption.  In P, we're
bringing these changes to
the platform and updating the
default system UI to use.  Try
these out on your app using the
current developer preview.
I would like to leave you with
some best practices for watch
face design.
As you know, watch faces are the
most
active apps and frequently are
doing too much too often.
As developers, you have the
ability to
influence how long users can get
experience and enjoy the watch
faces using simple coding
techniques to save battery.
Let me share a few best
practices with you.
Display CPU and network are the
most battery intensive
components of the system.
Be mindful of the frequency at
which you are reading,
processing, displaying
information on a watch face.
For example, if you're reading a
sensor and doing calculations
every minute or sending an RPC
to the
companion every minute this can
significantly impact the battery
life and once you have the new
data from the center of the
network you will also have
to wake up the system to process
it.  Process and wake-ups,
they're more expensive for
battery life than the power
consumed by individual sensors
like the accelerometer and
that's the
request and the network cause
and that will go a long way in
conserving battery life.
Finally, developer tools, last
year Android and as a result
Wear OS
officially started supporting
Kotlin DSL
and you can take advantage of a
lot of language features like
compile objects and other
support but to get the best out
of Kotlin DSL we need to go
beyond
what the language offers by
default.
On Wear we're experimenting with
creating a DSL for batch faces
to get rid of the boiler plate
code.  The initial results,
they're quite exciting.  We
reduced the watch face creation
code of 600 plus lines to just
under 15 lines of code.
Here is a bit of what the DSL
looks like.   This simplified
interface allows you to focus on
the design and customize your
watch faces using just a couple
of
lines of code while
incorporating best practices to
boost the performance and
battery life of your designs.
We're very excited about the
opportunities that Kotlin
provides and we're just
beginning to scratch the surface
on simplifying the development
on Wear OS.  We look forward to
your feedback while we work
towards adding this to tour
official SDK.
Check out the code labs at I/O
and visit the Wear OS sandbox to
share your
feedback and ideas.
To summarize, use officially
supported
methods and APIs and insert the
private APIs to improve
compatibility and stability of
your apps.  Design your apps and
watch faces to be battery
efficient.
Remember, batching is your
friend.
Download the developer preview
and check out how the apps are
impacted by the battery-saving
features that we're introducing.
Finally, give Kotlin DSL a spin
using the code lab and let us
know what you think.
With that, let me hand it back
to
Dennis foreclosing.
>> DENNIS TROPER: Thank you.
All right.  To recap, we're
working really hard to
improve the Wear OS experience
in three key areas, connections
at a glance,
health and fitness, a Google
Assistant experience that's
optimized for the wrist.  We're
improving the platform with new
battery saving features and new
tools for developers.  Also you
can expect a lot more and
frequent updates from us through
the year.  Today's session is
just the beginning
for us here at I/O.
At 2:30 p.m.
we have office hours where you
can meet with our engineers and
developer
relation folks and come on by if
you have any questions and
they'll be happy to receive you
and talk to you about
anything you like to talk about
in regard to iOS.  At 11:30 p.m.
tomorrow, we have an app review
session
where we can bring the wear app,
the
complications, watch faces to
get feedback from our
engineers.
And we also have a sandbox,
here is a map of where it is.
Please come visit us and we'll
be there right after the session
as well as many colleagues at
Wear OS and we have
some cool demos there to show
you and a
lineup of the recent Wear OS
watches.
That's all.  Thank you very much
for coming.
Have a great I/O!
Building Real Consumer Devices
Using
Android Things
Building Real Consumer Devices
Using Android Things
Using
Android Things
.
>> ROBERT GINDA: Thank you for
joining us here at I/O today.
Hello to everyone on the live
stream today.
I'm  rob, an engineering lead on
the
Android things team and I'm
joined by Shikha Kapoor.
This is a Lenovo Smart Display
built with Android things, it is
a visual Google Assistant or a
smart speaker with a display.
Probably you heard in the
keynote already or maybe in the
talk earlier
today that these devices and
others will be available on
store shelves in July, a couple
of months from now.
Today we're going to tell you
the story of how we built the
devices from prototype up to the
production devices
that will be available in a few
months.
Before joining the Android
things team I spent most of my
career writing software that ran
on other people's
devices, probably like many of
you.  Building hardware to scale
is different from the type of
work I had done before and it
came with new challenges and
today we'll tell you about some
of them.  Our hope is that you
leave this talk with a better
idea of what it is like to build
consumer hardware to scale and
how Android things makes it
easier than it ever has been.
It is not that scary when you
know what to expect.  I hope our
story of prototype to production
will help you build a device of
your own.
>> SHIKHA KAPOOR: If you are a
software developer thinking of
the link
of consumer wise devices, here
are things you care about, first
you build the product features
without worrying about the
underlying platform.  You want
to be able to swap out
underlying hardware seamlessly
without affecting your
application layer as the
technology or product needs
evolve over time.  You want your
devices to be secure.  I think
it is obvious why security is
increasingly an essential
requirement for smart devices.
They hold the keys to our homes
and our personal information.
What's probably less obvious
is why it is hard to provide
this kind of security.
It is incredibly expensive to
have the products out of the
gate and to keep them updated
over time.
Meanwhile, there is cost
pressure from end customers and
it is hard to do this.
.
Coming back to you, finally,
if you're building a consumer
device, you would want to manage
release and update channels over
time.  Android things was
designed with all of these needs
in mind.  We provide turn key
hardware in the form of
recertified system on modules or
what we call a as the CPU, the
wi-fi, Bluetooth, memory, other
critical hardware components.
Think of this as a small
computing platform that you can
use to build a straighter of IoT
devices.
We bring up the operating
system, test it, certify it to
the suitability to production
devices so that you don't have
to do any of this.
Later on in the talk we'll give
you an inside look into some of
the work that Google handles for
you.
You provide the application code
and Google takes care of the
rest.
What you see here are smart
displays from Lenovo, and
others.  As mentioned, they're
build with Android things.   If
you look under the hood, all of
the products have the same song
which is pretty cool.
These devices have microphones
that
can hear you from the other side
of the room and built in
speakers that can answer back
across the room just like a
smart speaker, but now we also
have a touch screen which makes
it possible to see visual
results.
This is why there is a list of
restaurants nearby on a map
showing you your commute
conditions.  We announced this
earlier this year at CES and
we're really proud of the
reception we received.
Let's dive a little deeper and
see how we'll build these.
About a year back we at Google
were wondering if we could build
a visual Google Assistant.  This
would enable deep integration
with other services such as
YouTube,  photos, maps, so on.
Building the consumer device
though is
typically a long process, but
for a fast-evolving space like
smart home devices time to
market is extremely important.
We wanted quick turn around time
and
this is exactly where Android
things shines.  Our goal is to
make it possible for software
developers like you to build
consumer devices at scale.
That's the hard thing to try to
get in a vacuum.  It takes real
world experience and building
and shipping a lot of devices to
know that you have really done
it.  This project would give us
the perfect opportunity to do
that.
In this case, our customers were
software developers from other
internal teams at Google such as
the Google assistant team.
For smart displays, they took
the lead on the software, we
concentrated on the platform and
we were able to get them from
prototype to production super
fast and we have a stronger
platform for you to build on.
We started by building some
proof of concept hardware for
smart displays, our goal was to
launch from that and to use the
device to kick off broader
discussions across the company.
We took a few weeks and spare
parts and built this.
>> ROBERT GINDA: This is the
first proof of concept hardware.
This is running on some hardware
we
had used previously to deliver
Anair droid things powered smart
speaker.  I built this case with
my son, it cost me two poke
Monday cards, he wonders
when he'll -- P o.
Kemon cards.   This is missing a
camera, doesn't have the volume
up, down buttons or mute of any
sort but that wasn't the point
of the device.  For this, we
were trying to show the basics
of what we thought we could
achieve with the smart display
product to get the conversation
started.
The mic on this was tricky to
use, it was not meant for this
use case.  You needed a quiet
room and you had to
stand in the right sweet spot
but it was possible to pull up a
convincing demo with it.
On top of the Android things
platform and smart speaker code
we already had, we built a small
Android application to drive the
display and show off the key use
cases we thought would be
important for this device.
A first thing we did with the
display
is to transcribe your query as
you spoke it, the speech
recognition pipeline was up and
running and it looked cool in a
demo.
Next up, support for rudimentary
knowledge cards that I'll show
some small text and photo with
answers with certain questions.
This device couldn't play video
yet because it wasn't -- it
didn't have the hardware
required for that.  It could
stream music already just like a
smart speaker.
We added title track display and
media transport controls like
pause and skip.
Finally we took a rough cut at
the ambient screen which is what
the device does when it is not
doing anything else, it showed a
if he o toe slide show and a
weather forecast.
Like I said, a basic set of
functionality that we could use
to show people what we thought
we could build out of this.
It only took   about two weeks
and a small team of people to
get this working.  The results,
it was  surprisingly close to
the architecture of the final
products shipping in a few
months.  The changes between
what we built here and what
we're shipping, they're
basically incremental changes.
Fundamentally, what we built,
are shipping, it involves the
smart display application on top
of the stack on top of Android
things on top of it a certified
sum.
Android things brings the
hardware support, security,
application framework and the
update mechanism and the smart
display application brings the
Google Assistant integration and
the visuals for the device.
Don't get me wrong, there was
definitely a lot of work to do
between here and what we're
shipping this summer, as I said,
the fundamental architecture is
the same and it was a matter of
incrementally building out the
feature set from here.
We practiced the demo routine
with this.
Set up meetings across Google
over the next few weeks and
people got a kick out of the
brick case and we had a lot of
discussions and debate about
product features we should
support, Android
things and about what we should
do next.
Overall, the demos went well and
we got the buy in we needed from
key stakeholders across Google
to move on to
the next step with this project.
>> SHIKHA KAPOOR: Now that
this was
going to be real, we had a few
steps in parallel to scale up
the efforts.
First the business development
team started discussions with
potential OEM partners.
In this case, OEM, original
equipment manufacturer, they're
a company that will build and
sell the device, they come up
with the industrial design and
the physical look and feel of
the product, they also pick
parts like the
display camera, microphone,
other components.  If you were
to build a device on Android
things, you will be the one
responsible for case design and
confidence selection in place of
this step, you may find an
industrial design work forum to
work with or the factory -- and
a factory to build the product.
A lot of details here have been
handled by our OEM partners and
we're not going to cover them
today.
In parallel, we started to
finalize the hardware
requirements for the product.
The proof of concept device used
a Som
that we had used for smart
speakers but you can build
anything from it with similar
requirements as well.
For smart displays though, we
needed something more powerful
than the video play back.
Fortunately we had some options
in the roadmap.  Let me start
evaluating.
Finally, in parallel to the
selection, we got started on the
application software.  Google
had already built out the
assistant back in software for
smart speakers and only a smart
speaker into a smart display, it
is not just a matter of plugging
in a touch panel.  There is a
lot of new work around the home
screen, the video play back
experience, the maps and photos
integration and essentially all
of the other visual features
that we were trying to build
with us.   During the
application software from
a humble proof of concept
device, it would take a lot of
time.
Most of the software work was
responsibility of developers
outside of
our team and we needed to get
started right away.  The
engineers that are software
developers like many of you
don't want to have to think
about the underlying platform or
the hardware.  Because we are
building this on an tried things
they don't need to -- like we
mentioned earlier, we can be --
the application engineers work
on top of the Android framework
like any other Android developer
and the application can run on
any hardware with Android
things.
>> ROBERT GINDA: At this point
in the project, it is July of
last year, we're about a month
and a half in to the work.
We have the proof of concept
hardware, we have the business
development work underway, we
have the hardware selection
underway and we're nearly ready
to get started on the
application software development
in earnest.
In order to really kick start
development we have to get
actual hardware into the hands
of engineers, product managers
and other folks at Google that
will build it out.   As we said
before, the hardware we used in
that proof of concept device, it
was just a little too slow to
use for more than a demo.  We
looked through the sums that we
had in the pipeline and found
one that met
the requirements for this
category of devices and it
happened to also be very easy to
buy in quantity over the
Internet and we had Android
things running pretty well on
it.  We decided to use this as
the basis for some provisional
hardware that we would build to
unblock the application
engineers to get started on
that, on their job while we
finished out the hardware.  We
knew we would swap the hardware
out when it was closer to
production but that didn't worry
us, as we have said, we're
building on Android of things
and that brings the isolation
from the
hardware that you need to be
able to do that.
The second problem, the
provisional hardware, it is that
it was a development board kit
similar to kits that we're
giving out here at I/O which
means it had a display, camera
connected to the base board and
you can work like this, but it
is a little difficult to manage
if you have more than one on the
desk, for example, and we wanted
to give these out to a lot of
Googlers.  For the first few
weeks we literally held it
together at our desks with card
board and rubber bands and that
wasn't
going to scale to the quantity
we wanted to deliver.
For that, we needed a more solid
enclosure to keep everything in
one spot.  By the way, if you
complete the scavenger hunt here
and you get a kit, make sure you
keep the packaging, it turns
into a handy stand so you don't
have to build one yourself.
This is the enclosure we came up
with for the first provisional
hardware.  Honestly, Android
things didn't really help or
hurt either way in the building
of this case.   I had a lot of
fun making it and learned a lot
in the process.  I hope you
don't mind if I geek out for a
few minutes and tell you more
about this design and how we
built it.
It looks plain from the front,
the point is that it is enough
to keep the hardware together
and give you a rough sense of
the factor that we had in mind.
There is a camera module at the
top.
Some microphones we had
manufactured locally here in the
middle of the top.
Of course, the big touch screen
in the front.
Here is a quick view of the
back.
The SoM and carrier board are
mounted on the big piece of
wood, like most of the hardware,
you can get to the ports easily
from the top.  There is access
for the reset button on the side
which is important with
prototyping.  I want to point
out here that pretty much none
of these components matched the
final hardware.  As we have
said, the SoM is different, so
are the cameras, so are the mics
and the display.  Not an issue
because we're building Android
apps on this and they don't
really care so much about the
specific hardware underneath.
Building this prototype was my
favorite part of the project
because at the time the
deadlines were far enough away
that they don't make that
crushing sound they do when
they're closer.  We were still a
small team that needed to be
scrappy and pretty resourceful.
I literally built this case in
my garage over a few weeks and
the best part of  that, I got to
buy a new tool, not just any
tool, but a 60-watt laser cutter
which I got off the Internet!
I literally learned how to use a
laser cutter for this project
and it traded on the design in
my garage over the course of a
few weekends, it was my first
time using any kind of 3D
modeling package to do this kind
of design.  First time ever with
a laser cutter.  I basically
learned by watching videos
online.  The point here, if this
is the kind of thing you like,
yes, you can do it too and you
will probably have a lot of fun
doing it.
Material that I tried first
was this birch plywood, it is
3-millimeters thick and you can
get it in quantity from the
net, two-day shipping in stacks
of 25 or 60.  You go for the
bigger -- if you go for the
batch of 60s is 1.50 a sheet or
less.  It is cost effective.
When I first tried building this
out, I wasn't very efficient
with the material use.  It would
take maybe 2, 3 sheets of
plywood to build parts for the
case and eventually you want to
get more optimized, waste a
little less material and as you
see here, I imagined to fit the
whole case in a single 12-inch
square sheet of plywood.  I did
have to fit one of the sides in
front of that bessel to make
that work.
It was fun and a challenge to
figure out how to make it in one
sheet of plywood.  Fun to
overcome that.
Laser cut only cuts in 2D,
harder to work a fastener like
the screw in the design.  This
is all friction fit.   Came up
with a tab and slot design to
put together by hand and it
would stay together securely.
The best part of that, it was
actually really easy to service
in the field if a connector is
looes, you need to change a
jumper, you snap it apart with
the hands, you don't need a
screw driver, you fix it, put it
back together and you're good to
go.
We tried variations in other
materials
such as the acrylic here, it is
better than the wood, this is
semi transparent red is really
cool.  What we found, in
acrylic, the thickens for us,
the material that we had, the
thickens varied too much across
color or even within color so
that when we put some of the
cases together they just fall
apart on a desk or that they fit
together so tightly that the
acrylic would snap at the weak
points which turned out to be
the 90 cuts in the material.
We decided to go with the wood
after all because it would be
more robust for us.
I cut about a dozen Parts --
parts to make a dozen cases and
we brought them in the office,
had people assemble them so that
we could try out the design.  We
it traded on it a bit.
Eventually settled on the final
design and sent it to an
internal shop at Google with a
laser cutter that could cut them
in bulk if you work in a company
that doesn't have a laser cutter
shop, no big deal, you can find
plenty of places where you up
load the file and
they'll cut them, send them back
to you.
If you never worked with a
cutter before, I recommend you
try one first before sending it
out and committing to a bulk
order to get a feel for what
works and doesn't work in this
kind of design.
You can build an enclosure too
and laser cutters are cool, try
one out.  One more thing before
moving on though, I mentioned we
wanted to build a
lot of these.  We built 75 in
the first batch to spread around
Google.  We thought they would
be more than enough.  They were
so popular we built another 75
and even that, frankly we could
have used more.
.
When you have this many
devices, you have to be able to
tell which is which and somebody
will have a problem, hey, can
you look at this device, you say
sure, I'm businessy  now, drop
it off at the desk.  Maybe they
put it next to one that looks
just like it while you're away
and then you end up looking at
the scorch
marks on the Schayes case to
figure out what is which.
Think ahead, serial number, keep
track of  it, know what
inventory you have, who has what
and the history of the
individual devices.
>> SHIKHA KAPOOR: We have the
hardware protected type over the
application developers and in
parallel we were
working on finalizing the smart
displays and we evaluated
different options and kick
started another series of
discussions.  Only this time, it
was with the
vendors and we selected the
SDA624 for the Lenovo devices
that are launching this year.
Partnering this as an
A53 and a  Adreno506 of, it is
capable of driving the display
and a   bunch of other potential
devices you may want to build as
well.
On the SDA624 we'll offer free
stability and security patches
for three years with options for
extended support.
To give you a more concrete idea
of the hardware we're talking
about here,
here is a photo of the top of
the box,
you see the wi-fi, the flash,
memory, all on a board.  Here is
the underside of the Som.  The
main thing going on here, it is
the three high density partners
with 100 pins each, the pins are
the SoM interface to the outside
world.
Here is a little deeper dive
into the SoM spin out interface.
The pins have power, lines and a
wide water of personal buses.
It looks a little overwhelming,
doesn't it?
However, you don't need to worry
about designing this if you were
using Android
things to build your devices.
We have standardized the SoM so
that the underlying platform
knows the expectations.  In some
Schayess you have the option
of laying out the SoMs flat on
the board as exactly as
specified according to the
interface, however, it is much
faster and easier to just build
a carrier board
that the SoM can plug into.
>> ROBERT GINDA: Our
development Som, it has a
carrier board with common pins
broken out on to standard sized
header so you don't have to deal
with the high-density
connectors.  When you build the
device for real for mass
production, you will likely want
to spin your own carrier board
that connects to whatever
hardware you need for the
device.
For smart displays, we came up
with a reference carrier board
that we asked our OEMs to
follow.  You can see in the
slide here that in
the middle we have the SoM, the
CPU, wi-fi, other important
parts and the peripherals are
connected on the outside.
We standardized on button and
sensor connections in the
reference design and specified
which GPIOs they should connect
into to simplify our work on so
the of the wear side because
we're
working with three  OEMs
simultaneously
we wanted to avoid as much as we
could
unnecessary customizations
across OeMs, everybody for
example plugged the volume
up in the same GPIOU in the SoM.
Another thing referenced, the
microphone mute circuit should
be external to the SoM and
implemented in hardware so that
when you mute the
devices the mics are
electrically, physically
disconnected so that even in the
face of a successful exploit in
the
future, there is no way to
unmute the device in software.
Similarly, we specified as part
of the
reference design that the camera
mute should physically cover the
lens of the camera so that there
is no way to unmute the camera
so to speak in software.
We did leave some room for Oem
customization, for example, they
could select their own
microphones and they
could build their own audio
output
stages and they had leeway on
display choice as well.
This is the next revision of the
development kit.  This is what
came after the Wooden kits I
showed earlier.  This is built
according to the reference
design and it is using a lot of
the production components we
have in real devices.   This
time around the entire front
assembly was put together by an
outside firm and we didn't do
any of that.
This case happened to be an
acrylic with fiction fit gromits
to connect to the back, these
sometimes came loose if you over
tightened them and you could fix
it with super glue if you had
to.  From the front, same touch
panel camera and microphones
used in the production devices
for some.  We  added the acrylic
back at Google which held the
speaker in place and really just
gave the front something to lean
up against so that it was at a
similar angle to what we were
expecting for the production
devices.
Inside, these are essentially
the SDA624SoM plugged into a
carrier board matching the
reference design.
This is one of the earlier
versions, and in these versions,
the amplifier and the display
interface, they were on donor
cards that plugged into the
carrier board but on later
revisions we had it flattened
down on to a single carrier
board.  We completed the kits in
the beginning of December of
last year.
If you're not aware, CES is --
it is June --
>> SHIKHA KAPOOR: January.
>> JOHN PALLETT: January 9th.
We had just a month to go before
the Big Show.  We were going to
show off the devices at CES.
It was a little nerve racking in
the weeks leading up to the
delivery of the devices where it
was closer and closer.  In fact,
the application engineers had
gotten off to a great start with
the Wooden devices and we sorted
out the platform and brought it
up on the Android things side
relatively quickly.  It is
amazing that one month before
this huge demo at CES we were
able to completely swap out the
hardware.  We moved the entire
development team, platform,
application engineers from those
Wooden prototypes over to the
devices running on a completely
different SOC without a hitch.
This is because thanks to
Android things the smart display
application is totally
independent of the platform.
You can see how this was useful
to us, we had this provisional
situation where we needed to
bring up temporary hardware
before the real stuff was ready.
This can be useful in production
devices as  well.
You may ship this year with a
certain pro tile, a certain
piece of hardware that you need,
and then next year maybe you
want to cost it down or you may
want to add new features and
switch to a powerful piece of
hardware.   Because of this, you
can easily reuse the application
software across a wide
variety of hardware platforms.
>> SHIKHA KAPOOR: Around the
same time
as our preference hardware was
being
completed, our partners were
busy building out their own
devices based on reference
design that we showed before.
Those are even closer to CIS and
regarded with two to three weeks
to spare.  Again, the transition
was relatively smooth.  We hit a
few bumps, for example, on one
of the devices the camera looked
green which we traced to a
missing
capaciter but nothing we
couldn't start on time.  It was
a lot of work, I remember
cursing when it was so close to
the holidays, why we did that,
this is a picture of the war
room we set up a few weeks
before  CES.  We spent a lot of
time here planning
the demos, adding features,
fixing last minute bugs on the
device and back end servers that
make it work.
On the demos, we planned to show
rich integration with other
Google services
such as YouTube, photos, maps,
this is a little kids room we
set up that had cameras pointing
at it and we could check in on
our little Android baby all the
way from Vegas.  Our hardware
and careful planning paid
off and the demos worked like
they were supposed to.  We had
issues with the venue and
hardware glitches but we brought
you back ups expecting that to
happen.  The reception we got
from the press
and users at CES was
encouraging.  Many are hard at
work in something in secret, it
is hard to gage how the outside
world, how it will react to it.
Getting this type of positive
feedback was a great shot of
motivation for the
team and helped with the effort.
After CES it was time to get out
of
the demo mindset and back to the
work of  shipping.
At this point, we were flushed
with
hardware from our  OEM partners
and the program was ramping up.
Up until now we were handing out
a single software build to all
developers and we had to expand
out.  Fortunately Android things
makes this
easy using Channels and our
developer console allows you to
manage release and update
channels over time.  You can get
a lot more details on how
this works in a talk tomorrow.
For displays, we established
multiple channels for the
internal user segments depending
on the needs.  Of for example,
our developers have
medium to high-risk tolerance
and can replace components as
necessary and we have a Dev
channel for them.
We have a Ca had nary for
high-risk tolerant developer as
inwith he have a different
channel for our testing teams so
that we can give them only
access to builds we want tested.
At this point we have hundreds
of Googlers testing out the
smart displays, giving us
feedback on features.  These
people need more stable channels
and they have low-risk tolerance
so we rollout stable weekly
builds with them
with good functionality and we
look at issues.
We're getting close to the end
of the talk but I want to cover
one more thing before wrapping
up.
If you're  shipping software,
you never really need to be
completely done with it if
you're building a website, a
mobile application, you can
rollout bug fixes whenever you
want.   When it comes to
hardware, you only get one shot
at it.   Once it is in the hands
of the user, that's it.  There
are some things that even
software cannot fix at that
point.  you better get it right.
You also just cannot keep the
factory running continuously
though making small tweaks here
and there.  You need to purchase
your building materials in bulk
and since it is still early in
the process you're not going to
be ready to buy in mass
production quantities and the
cooling and testing takes some
time to set up and  change.
This process usually happens
across a few builds that are
standard in the hardware
development life cycle and you
can read more about it on the
Internet and I'll cover it
briefly today.
So we already talked about the
prototype phase and the next
phase is
the EDT or engineering
validation test.  For this phase
you're trying to
validate that you got it right,
no layout issues and the
components work the way they're
supposed to.  If you're still
considering different design
options you can concentrate on
them, this is a good time to do
so.  This essentially represents
the first
attempt at building the way
they'll
appear in the final device and
the enclosure is not final at
this stage,
you may want to keep the boards,
hard loads and keep them from
flipping around.
The next stage is the DVT and
the purpose is to verify to make
sure that everything is meeting
the final specifications.
The devices we got for CES, they
were soft tool which means
that the molds used to cast the
plastics were made out of a soft
material like silicone.  You may
want to do a few builds here
until you get to a point where
you know that there are no fixes
that you need with  hardware.
You ramp up quantities and you
get the
confidence and you want to get
with hard tool plastics.  The
production validation test is
typically the last thing that
transitions to mass production
hopefully by now you have logged
in the final software you will
be flashing in on these devices
and at this point you're
also hoping that the factory is
running on autopilot without any
manual intervention.
Finally, your product is ready
to go to mass production which
means that it
is ready to be on shelves and at
this stage you ramp up
production and focus on making
process improvements to improve
it.  You want to continue to
test it for the next few months
though as well as establish some
sort of reliability testing.
That's how we built the smart
displays
from prototype to production and
Android things helped us every
step of the way.
Thank you to the Android work
and we could focus on
application features
without worrying about the
unlying platform.  Our system
and software solutions
allowed them to swap out the
hardware seamlessly moving from
one prototype kit to another
without affecting it and yes,
while we needed to do a lot of
work to bring up the displays,
you don't need to do any of
this.
The smart displays will be ready
to use soon.  Our update and
management features
allowed for easy maintenance of
multiple
devices on the field and
finally, our security features
mean that our partners and users
don't have to worry about the
security of these devices.
>> ROBERT GINDA: We have a lot
more to
show you at I/O, see us at the
sandbox dome on the left side of
the map here.   The entire dome
is filled with Android things
demos and it is open after hours
as well.  You can see how we
leverage machine learning, buyer
base and the Cloud platform and
you can have an up close look at
the prototypes and the devices
we talked about here today.
By the way, you'll notice we
power
things outside of the sandbox
and there
is a large human-sized robot
roaming around, trying to take a
selfie with you!  You can look
at the codes as well shown here,
we have the code labs
talking about TensorFlow and
Cloud IoT and how we made the
survey boxes around I/O even
more.  There is 7 more sessions
on Android things coming up
today and tomorrow.  They go
even deeper in some of these
topics.  Finally, have some fun
at I/O.  We have a scavenger
hunt going on shown in the link
here, go.
co/io search, you will run into
some machine learning and
enhanced flowers which are cool
and if you solve all of the
puzzles and get to the end you
get a piece of developer
hardware to take home for
yourself.
With that, I invite you to go
build hardware and I hope that
we're leaving you with
confidence that you too can
build a device with Android
things.  Go to the link
mentioned here to get started
today.  Thank you.
The Future of the Web is
Immersive
welcome to our talk on the The
Future of the Web is Immersive,
I'm Brandon Jones
and I'm a developer on the
Chrome team driving forward
immersive web standards.
We feel like 2018 will mark the
true kick-off point for what we
have called the immersive web.
The technologies involved have
bonito stabilize enough so we
can expose them to the web
platform with can have deps
and the APIs we're discussing is
still under development, if you
start to learn how to use them
now, they'll shift by the time
you're comfortable with them.
What do we mean when we say the
immersive web?  It is a
collection of new and upcoming
tech that prepares the web for
the full
spectrum of immersive computing
including Virtual Reality and
Augmented Reality.
Generally we think of the
immersive web anything that
gives depth, volume, scale or
place.
This is how we think of the
technologies in general.
Virtual Reality or VR can take
you anywhere.
Augmented Reality or AR can
bring anything to you.  We'll
cover both in this talk.  First
I'll cover how we're bringing VR
to the web today and then John
Pallett will show you the
upcoming efforts to do the same
thing with AR.
Let's start with Virtual
Reality.  Chances are, you
already know about VR
headsets like the view, the vibe
or the Lenovo Mirage Solo
released last week.  They use
head tracking, screens, optics
and controllers to make you feel
like you're present in a
different place when you use
them.
Last year at I/O we presented
the web VR API as a way for web
developers to
communicate with the devices.
Web VR was really well received,
but it also had limitations that
became apparent as the VR
ecosystem grew.  Since then, we
have been collaborating
with content developers, device
manufacturers and other browser
vendors
to address those limitations.
The result is the new web XR
device
API, WebXR replaces VR evolving
to meet
the needs of a growing immersive
ecosystem serving as the
foundation for
the immersive Web Ex posing not
just VR but AR functionality as
well to web developers and also
it goes beyond the headsets to
make it accessible to as many
people as possible.  Of course,
we recognize that migrating
existing code to a new API is a
bit of a pain.  We also think
that the benefits will be well
worth the short-term
inconvenience.
The WebXR API was designed by
listening to a lot of feedback
from developers of real world
content just like you and
explicitly addresses many of the
issues they recorded.
Additionally, the new API
provides the platform for AR
features and will be more
forward compatible with the
wider range of devices.
It is also cleaner, more
consistent, more predictable and
enables browsers to
apply more optimizations.
What do I mean when I say
optimizations?  I really like
this part!
The design of
the
WebXR, as a result we're seeing
on
Android we can default to 50%
higher resolutions than VR
without impacting the
application performance and all
of that means that we're pushing
twice as many Pixels to the
display versus the
same content
in VR.
When can you start using it?
Today.  You can do so today in
Chrome 67 which is currently in
beta.  There are two ways to get
started.
First, the WebXR is available as
an origin trial today.  Origin
trials are a way for Chrome to
allow developers to deploy
features to users that aren't
quite finalized yet by
embedding a token
and in return, the developers
will provide feedback so we can
improve it prior to shipping.
If you're in the interested in
deploying the content today or
just want to play around with
the API you can
enable it by Chrome's about flag
page to start testing f you
enable the API
through either of these methods
you gain
access to a variety of different
ways of
viewing immersive content.
First, WebXR in chrome 67
gives access to mobile VR
devices on Android which enables
users to slide the phone into a
headset like the Daydream View
or card board and turn into a
virtual reality headset.  Of
course, we recognize that there
is a wide variety of mobile
devices and browsers out there
which is why we're making
Cardboard compatibility
available
for browsers like Mobile Safari
via Java script polly fill and
there is
limitations and it allows a
baseline functionality to all
users.
Next, chrome 67 supports
high-end
desktop VR headsets on windows
and they present the highest VR
experiences available to
consumers today and provides an
excellent opportunity for
progressive enhancement of the
immersive
apps adding room scale movement
and 6-degree of freedom input.
Finally, Chrome 67 supports what
we call magic window content.
Magic window refers to viewing
the
scene on a 2D webpage and tracks
the device and motion.  It
provides a hint to the users
that there is a larger world to
see and a way to consume a
content even with a headset not
handy.
So let's take a quick look at
how to
use this new API to create a
simple
virtual reality application on
the web.   We're going to assume
that you
already have a scene you want
viewable in virtual reality.
First we need to detect if there
is any WebXR devices available
and if so, we need to advertise
that functionality to the user.
To do this, we'll start by
calling the
navigating of XR request device
function.  The return will go to
a device which may represent a
mobile device with VR
and AR capabilities, a wired
headset, standalone headset or
some other immersive computing
device.  Next we check to see if
the device supports the mode we
want to use.
In this case, because we want
the VR
content to display on the
headset we ask if it supports
exclusive access by the page.
If it discus, we add a button to
the
page to advertise the feature
and when the user clicks on that
button we'll request what's
called an XR session.
The session is giving us access
to the capabilities of the VR or
AR device.
You get a session by calling
request session.
You call that down on the XR
device we retrieved specifying
you want exclusive access to the
display and when you have the
session, you need to create two
supporting objects, a frame of
reference and a web layer.  The
frame of reference tells us how
to position objects on the scene
relative to the user.  Here
we're asking for a stage frame
of reference which attempts to
put the origin on the user's
floor.  That way it is very
trivial to lineup the virtual
floor with the user's physical
one.
Next, we ask to create a layer
which
gives us the surface to render
the 3D scene on to.  You can
think of it as a canvas
element visible from within the
headset.  Then when the setup is
done, we'll kick-off Anair
medication loop by calling
request animation frame on the
session which is very similar to
the window request animation
frame you're
already familiar with.  With
that, we're almost researched to
begin rendering and first we
need to understand the first
concept introduced by WebXR and
that's views.
The WebXR renders a loop and
provides a list of views that
must be drawn with every frame
to make sure that the scene will
appear correctly on whatever
device you're viewing it on.
A view provides all of the
values
needed to render a single image
of a
WebXR scene such as matrixes and
view  ports.  Most headsets will
require you to draw
two views, one for each and the
magic
window scene will only require
one view.  You can imagine in
the future you may have more
exotic hardware requiring you to
draw more views than that two
account for different display
configurations.
The benefit is that WebXR can
use a unified rendering path for
a huge
variety of different devices and
display modes and here is how
that looks in practice.  A
request animation frame call
back is given an XR presentation
frame object which contains the
list of views that we need to
render.
It  allows -- it allows us to
querry the pose of the device
which is position
and orientation in space.
To display the scene on the
headset we'll find the buffer
created by the
layer that we created previously
and then begin looping through
each of the
views provided by the frame
drawing into the view port that
each of the views describes
using the view and projection
metricses that they provide.
When we put it altogether, we
can now provide an immersive
virtual reality experience with
the web GL scene we had
previously that works on mobile,
desktop
and standalone VR devices.
Of course, your users are not
content to just look, they want
to interact with the immersive
worlds you're creating.  We need
a form of input.
Now, WebXR took to heart a lot
of the feedback we got about the
difficulties
handling input with the APIs and
it attempts to address them with
a new system working across all
of the WebXR various forms and
factors.
The basic idea is this:  Any
time you interact with a scene,
by tapping on a magic window,
looking at an object, clicking a
button on a Cardboard style
headset or using a controller
point and click all of these
interactions can be described by
a ray, point of origin and
direction into the scene.  By
using the rays, WebXR provides,
you can trace into the scene,
determine what object the user
wants to interact with, and
respond appropriately no matter
what input method they're using.
Let's see how that looks in
code.
Al first the user needs to know
what they're pointing at.
We'll visualize whatever input
method they have by going
through and looking
at the list of input sources
from the WebXR session and for
each input source we'll get the
current pose which describes the
direction that the input is
pointing in and if it is
applicable the position and
orientation of the
controller as well.
Depending on the type of input
source we're dealing with, we'll
render a
controller model, a Pointer ray,
and a
curser to show where the input
is pointing.  Here you can see
an example of how an app may
visualize the controller
rendering a reputation of the
controller itself and a Pointer
ray and curser to help the user
better target the input.
If we used a gaze system like
Cardboard we render only the
curster because it is
distracting to have a  lacesser
coming from your forehead.
-- a lazer coming from your
forehead.
Now the user can see where
they're pointing, we have to
respond to what they're clicking
on and to do that, we look at
the selective.
That fires and tells us which
event was fired and we look at
the pose at the time of the
event.   This gives us the
Pointer ray.  The application
can then use the ray to perform
a hit test against the
internal representation of your
sequence.
If we detect that object was
selected, we trigger the
appropriate behavior depending
on the context of the app.
This allows us to provide users
with a way to easily point and
click and interact with any
object in the scene and have
that interaction be consistent
across all of the various
devices that
they may be using.
WebXR input system allows for
grabbing
and moving objects by looking at
the select start and end events.
Cruciously, the selective event
is selected to be a user
activation event which is not
the case previously with
web  VR and an issue that we
heard about from developers most
frequently.  This means that
applications can start
media play back with WebXR input
just
like they would a mouse or a
touch screen.
We now have an interactive VR
experience that's on the web and
that is awesome.
Not every user has a headset,
and even if they did, not every
user is using a
browser that supports WebXR yet.
We want your content to be
accessible by a billion plus
users, that's why
we're expanding the immersive
web reach
to 2 it D screens by a Magic
Window and with our Java script
polly fill.
Let's talk about Magic Window.
As I mentioned, it is a mode
that let's users view immersive
content on the phone without a
VR headset tracking the
orientation of your device to
let you look around.  It is like
you're holding a portal to
another world in your hand.
We have put effort into making
the
creation of Magic Window
experiences as  frictionless as
possible.
We'll rewind and look at the
code from earlier.  This is
going to display content on the
headset bit specifying it wants
exclusive access to the display.
With Magic Window, we want the
immersive content to show on the
page, not the headset.  To
accomplish this, we only need to
make a few changes.
First, we create a canvas we
want the Magic Window to display
in, the content, which can be
attached to anywhere you
want on the document and then
you need
to look at an XR presentation
from that canvas.
This works just like getting web
GL contents.  That goes to the
session request as the output
context.  This binds the
sessions rendered output to that
canvas.  We also notice that you
have ate the exclusive argument
from the request because the
output is not intended for
the headset.  Honestly, that's
it.  Like everything else is the
same.  The render loop we
described earlier, you request
the single view, the input
system now fires events that
correspond
to the screen taps rather than
the controller and everything
else workses.  Even better, it
is easy to use Magic
Window and VR on a single page
so users
can transition frictionlessly at
a touch of a button.
Let's talk about the WebXR polly
fill
for browsers that do not support
WebXR, it provides an
implementation of this in one of
two ways.  First it offers a
Java script only implementation
working in any mobile
browser with orientation events,
even Mobile Safari.  Secondly,
if a browser implements the
older web VR API, the pollyfill
can immolate on top of that
taking advantage
of the native hardware features
that web VR exposes.  This means
that you can instantly make your
new WebXR content accessible to
a much wider range of users
simply by
adding one script to your page.
WebXR isn't the only way we're
bringing the immersive --
grinning immersive computing and
the web together.  With the
Chrome 67 beta, you can launch a
VR optimized version of Chrome
right from daydream home.  We
have put a lot of work in making
the browser -- into making
browsing the traditional web a
great experience in VR and it
also really shines as a way to
browse immersive web content.
The ability to hop from 2 it D
web to VR content and back at a
push of a button, it makes
discovering new VR
content online really easy,
fluid and
honestly just a little bit
magical.
Chrome is fully immersing the
immersive web through VR
browsing and web apps, what
about Augmented Reality?  To
talk about that, I'll hand it
over to John Pallett.
>> JOHN PALLETT: Thank you.
I'm John Pallett.  I'm a product
manager on the Chrome team.
I'm going to talk to you about
Augmented Reality.  For those of
you that don't know what
Augmented Reality is, if you
have tried
out AR stickers in photos or
used
Pokemon go or snap shat filters,
you have used the Augmented
Reality.  Unlike VR where you're
completely
immersed in a virtual world, AR
overlays in the real world.  If
you have used these experiences,
you have tried AR.
What's great about Augmented
Reality is that there is over
100 million phones
and tablets already available
that support Augmented Reality
and that number is growing
rapidly and generally
speaking those devices already
have web  browsers.  That means
that Augmented Reality can be a
real convenience for users.
They can walk around, experience
Augmented Reality and they don't
need a new app every time.   It
is great for developers, if you
want to have an experience, you
throw up
the URL and a user jumps right
into it, do the experience, they
leave.  The web will make
Augmented Reality
super convenient and accessible
for everyone.
That's great.  The web is a
great fit for AR.  How many of
you are web developers in the
audience.
How many of you have a website?
I hope that's the same number
since you're web developers.
The flip side of this, great,
web helps A, are but does AR
help you, a web developer.
There are a lot of ways that
Augmented
Reality can help you enhance
your site and I'm not going to
talk about it in anymore, I'll
show you what I mean.  I'll give
you a preview of what's
coming soon to Chrome Canary.
Can we switch to the device,
please?
In this demo -- it is working.
In this demo, it is somewhat of
a true story.  In this demo my
daughter and I are
researching in Mexico city a
temple and
it is -- it was a center of
Aztek worship built in the 14th
century.
The temple was built for the God
of agriculture and the God of
war.
What we're learning about here,
these
statues, they're used to make
offerings to the God of rain, so
we're learning about that here
and if we go down on this page
what I can  do, I can jump into
Augmented Reality mode to learn
more.   It is learning about the
scene.
What I can do, I can place the
statue right in the stage in
front of me.  This really let's
me get in and get a sense of the
real world sense of scale.  In
reality, it is 45 inches long
and
36 inches high.   We see it is a
life-sized representation of a
human being.   You notice on the
website and through
others that we saw a lot has
this 90 head orientation.
If I go into here we can learn
that
that 90 head orientation is
fairly common but so is the
pose.
This -- you see this is
reKlining on the back with the
knees, and the arms bent.
That's traditionally in art
forms of
this kind a symbol of humility,
submissiveness of being a
prisoner.  In this, it is
humility to the day, there is a
bowl for making the offerings
here and what's interesting, I
can see a
little bit on the arms and legs
representing  iconography.  It
is interesting.
If you have this and it is
celebrating
the rain God, it is normal to
see symbols of water, frogs,
things like that.  I don't see a
lot here.   Something
interesting on the cheek.
There is not a ton of that
iconography here.  It is
interesting to wonder how do
they know that this statue what
is associated with this?  If we
go to the feet, what we learn,
is that the feet are red and
they have a
hint of blue in the sandals and
this  coloring actually helped
researchers connect -- let's get
a better view of the blue.
You see it is tucked in on the
corner.  So this actually gave
researchers the
clue that they needed to connect
this particular one, the first
full color bowl that was ever
discovered with original paint
back to other pieces of artwork
from the same period which
talked about the rain God.
This was 3D scanned in 2016 in
collaboration with the temple
museum, the data is available to
anyone, you can download it, use
it for educational purposes
through the open heritage
project on Google arts and
culture.  I want to stress, this
is not available to all Chrome
users today.   These APIs for
this, they're in development.
What we want to do is show you
how to
use them and get feedback before
they're filmed up.
Let's go back to the -- before
they're firmed up.
Let's go back to the slides
please.
You saw the ability to take an
existing 2D webpage and add
Augmented Reality to it.
This is a big possibility, you
can take amazing new experiences
and add them to the existing
website and there is a lot of
different websites today that
can get value for users by
allowing you to place virtual
objects in the real world.  A
few examples:  One of them is
shopping.  In this case, we're
looking at a furniture website
and it would let me place
furniture elements in the real
world.  My family recently
bought a new couch.  We ended up
cutting and measuring pieces of
paper and placing them on the
floor to make sure that the
couch would fit.  I can tell you
from personal experience, this
would have been a lot easier.
As you saw, another great use
case, education.  Anybody can
drop an object in the real world
and look at it.
It is great for statues, you can
get a better sense of what's
going on and as we explored that
statue, I hope you saw it, you
can get a lot more information
and learn more than you can from
just a static image.
There are a lot of other
opportunities
as well such as avatars, games,
AR stickers and more.  In a
mobile context there are tools
we can provide right now to you
that would make your webpages
more delightful and increase
their value to users.  This is
coming quickly and it will make
the mobile device a hand-held
window in a new reality.
Let's talk about how these
APIs are taking shape.   They're
being developed in the WC3
immersive web community group.
Its a cooperative forthwith a
number
of companies,
and web developers.
There are also more bleeding
edge APIs being worked on within
that community group.  Some are
more baked than  others.  I'll
spend most of my time talking
about the top two, AR sessions
and hit tests that are the two
building Blocks of the demo I
showed you earlier.
You notice that hit tests are in
the
experiment stage and that means
it is more than discussion but
not quite ready for origin
trials and practically
speaking, the demo from earlier,
it will work in Chrome Canary in
the next week or two.  When you
go home, watch it on YouTube, it
should be ready to try.  When
you do that, you want to enable
the two flights we saw here, the
devices
and flags and the WebXR hit test
flag.  This is great.
It means that an early version
of Augmented Reality is coming
quickly to Chrome Canary and
I'll tell you how you
can get started using it.
Good news, because it is based
on the
WebXR API a lot of the code that
Brandon already covered around
VR applies here as well.
What that means, things like
capturing  devices or
orientation and position, it is
the exact same.
Switching from VR code to AR
code, it is mostly doing the
same thing.  What I largely will
focus on here is the
differences.
The first thing to point out,
AR sessions are still in the
proposal stage, we're still
having conversations about the
best way to do this.
What that means, we enable the
flights in Chrome Canary, you
have a temporary way of
enabling the AR mode.  You may
recognize pieces of this code
because it is similar to what
Brandon
showed earlier when creating a
magic window session when it is
not an exclusive session.  If
you enable the AR flights in
Chrome Canary we're going to
make the assumption that you
always want AR.
What that means, that the camera
will be rendered behind the
zoomty and kept
in sync with the device pose.
In addition, the community group
is discussing how we'll extend
and allow the declaration of an
AR session, it is likely that
the properties will be part of
request session, it is not
finalized yet so just for now,
if you're trying this out, you
enable the flags in Chrome
Canary know it will go in AR
mode automatically as long as
you create
magic window and will keep
everything synchronized.
Another difference from
Brandon's example is the frame
of reference.  In VR you were
using Stage, a I lining with the
floor, here you will use eye
level.  What it mean, the first
recorded position and forward
orientation of the device
becomes the origin.
Every other motion is relative
after that.
The Y axis is aligned with
gravity and when you use eye
level it starts where the phone
is and then everything else is
relative after that.
It is important to use that
when you try out AR mode.
Let's talk about the real
building Block that allowed the
demo to happen, the hit test
API.  It is a foundation of the
demo I just showed you.
What it let's you do, you cast a
ray
in the real world and detect
real world geometry and shapes.
If I were standing here, I can
cast that and it will tell me
there is a
podium there and I don't think
it goes all the way to the edge
at this point.  to demonstrate
how we use the hit test
API, think about a reticle, what
it is,
it is an indicator drawn on a
real world surface.  In our
example, this was useful because
it allowed the user to figure
out where they wanted to place
the object in the AR scene.
What you're doing when drawing
this, you continually do hit
tests in the real world and use
the results to place
geometry in the scene so it
appears as if it is on top of a
real world object.  Before I
show code with this, I want to
say we're using three.
js, a helper library for 3D
graphics on
the web and it takes care a lot
of the code and some of the code
is specific to that, if you're
interested in learning
more, go to three JS.org.
What we'll do here, we'll create
a
mesh, geometry for the reticle.
So the circle you saw on the
slide and the box before, it is
3D geometry with texture on it,
it doesn't matter what geometry
you will use, I won't go in
details and neither does the
permission in the scene.
You create it, add it to the
scene and we'll update the
position on the fly as
we get back our results.
Everything we do next, it will
be a part of the request
animation frame loop.  This is
basically the same as you saw
in VR and it is brokered through
the WebXR session.   You request
the frame and execute on it and
at the end you request another
frame and you continue to do it
that way.
Now a key part of this example,
it is
that we'll use our three.js
camera and one is for rendering,
we'll update it with a view and
projection matrix from the
device posed.   This ensures
that the camera is aligned with
our augmented reality device
pose and is using the correct
frame of reference.  Important
for rendering.  We'll use it for
something else as well.
In every frame, we want
something to place our rectangle
on, as I mentioned earlier, the
hit test will allow you to cast
a ray in the real world and get
back to the section points with
real world objects.  To do that,
we kind of need a ray in the
right coordinated system with
the right frame of reference and
the great news is that three.js
creates that, we take the
camera, generate a ray from it.
What we'll do, we'll use the 00
in accordance to the system
here, it is in the center of the
screen, if you try to cast a ray
based on a user tap, you would
use anything from negative one
to positive one.  In this case,
we'll stick with 00, that's
where the ray center of the
screen will go.   Then we'll
pass that in to the camera and
get back a ray.
The next thing we'll do is use
our XR session to request a hit
test.  This is the new API that
is available when you turn on
the flag and this is the one
that's going to be coming to
Chrome Canary in a couple of
weeks.  When we do the hit test
what it
accepts is the origin and the
direction of the ray.  You can
see above, we extract that from
the ray that we generated.  It
also accepts the overall frame
of reference as a parameter.
What we get back, it is a list
of hits.  They're ordered in
terms of how close they are to
the cameras.  The first hit, it
is the nearest one to the camera
and they're sorted by distance.
We want our rectangle to be on
the
first
-- we want the
reticle to show and at this
point it is positioning itself
in real world objects within the
request animation frame as you
move the device around.
Let's talk about placing objects
in AR.  There is a slight
difference to consider.  When we
get back the hit test, what we
get back, it is the position of
the hit
and the normal of the surface
that the ray detected.  We
didn't dissect that because we
wanted reticle to appear like it
is in
the surface and you want to
specify your
own orientation, especially
which way is
up and instead of using the real
world object that was detected.
This is fairly straightforward
and we'll decompose the method
which will detract the position
and the scale from the 4 by 4
method.   Now that these are
extracted, you change the
orientation of the object to be
whap whatever you want by
generating a new matrix or
setting rotation on the object
directly.  The key point, there
are situations where you'll want
to decompose the hit test result
and use pieces of it.  In this
case, for object the placement
but for other cases, you
generate the understanding of
the real world in the
code, you get a lot of useful
information from the hit test
results.
The last thing I want to
cover, an API that's only in
discussion at this point.  this
is not coming in Chrome Canary
but is really important to
augmented reality and I want to
cover it so that you have an
introduction to it right now.
This is a core concept to
augmented reality which is why
we'll cover it here.  The
concept is anchors.
Anchors allow the augmented
reality system to keep virtual
positions and
orientations, poses, always
correct and up-to-date as a
system learns over time.  What
do I mean by that?  What I mean,
you think about the augmented
reality system, it doesn't have
perfect information.  Everything
it is getting is from the camera
and from sensors and so forth
and it is learning about the
real world.  As I move the
camera around, it is more
information, it is improving the
understanding of the world.
What that means, sometimes it
was wrong previously and it
learns that later on.  That's
where anchors come in.
It allows the underlying
augmented system to keep track
of poses you care about and
improve their accuracy later.
To give you an example, suppose
that the augmented reality
system thought my camera was
here when I did the hit test and
later it realized that the
camera was over here.  What it
could do with that knowledge,
ifty anchored the object it was
adjust the location after the
fact, when it realized the
mistake.
Anchors are useful in a lot of
places.  For example, when real
world objects start to move.
As you can imagine, the idea of
anchors is useful and one that
is deep enough that it continues
to go in conversation.
It is not ready for you to try
right now.
How to do this as a web API is a
topic of conversation, how to do
it properly.  Even with the hit
test, it is all that you saw,
the session was created, a hit
test API, there's a lot of
opportunities for you to look at
how you may enhance your
existing web pages.  The hit
test I showed you, it can let
you do pretty much everything on
the
screen now, shopping, education,
more.
Really, all I showed you, it was
placing one virtual object in
the real world.  There's a lot
of information you can get from
a hit test and a lot of things
you can do with it.  Frankly,
we're all really excited to see
what you come up with and ideas
that
you have for ways to make your
website better.  This brings me
to another point.  there are
over 100 million devices that do
AR today and not everyone does.
So what do you do in that case?
I mentioned earlier there is a
lot of code similarity between
AR and VR.  This is really
important if what you want to do
is create a new  AR experience
and then also make it available
in VR for  users that are not
using a device.  For example, a
desktop that doesn't have a
camera and they're not picking
it up and moving it around the
room.  What you may want to do,
have the exact same code driving
a VR experience on desktop with
a Magic Window.  In that case,
you have to adjust your user
experience and your user
interface, so instead of walking
around with the desktop you get
them to zoom in and zoom
out, but if you think about the
demo, you still explore the
statue and learn from it.  That
ability to do progressive fall
back is super important on the
web and we're really excited
that Web Ex allows
us to do that without having to
rewrite the same experience
twice.
To recap, we have talked about
the WebXR device API for VR
sessions that are available for
origin trials today and  AR
sessions which are still in
discussion.
We also  previewed some
Augmented Reality APIs which you
can try in Chrome Canary,
actually one augmented reality
Chrome Canary which you can try
in a few weeks.  As I mentioned,
the conversation is ongoing for
sessions and anchors.
If you're interested in tracking
that conversation, this is the
slide you should take a photo
of.  We would like you to learn
about this, what we really want
is your feedback.  We would like
you to try it out and let us
know what you think.  If you try
the API and you want to suggest
changes, this is where you
should go.  If you want to
trackhoe things are progressing,
this is where you should go.
Please do visit the community
and file issues if you have
questions or file issues if you
find things you think should be
different.
Overall though, we're very
excited to
see what you create with this
both for
VR as well as for Augmented
Reality
.
>> BRANDON JONES: A last thing
to mention, a lot of the 3D
media you saw on the slides
today was taken from
polly, an excellent depository
created by tools like blocks and
tilt brush all
available under the creative
license and
credits, and you can check it
out at poly.google.com.
>> If you want to start with
development, there are links on
the screen where you can see how
the community group is
progressing as well as seeing
code samples and the app spot
link there is the demonstration
that I showed you earlier.  It
will not work today if you pull
out the phone and go to Chrome
Canary and turn it on, it won't
work.
Give us a couple of weeks.
Please do try it out and let us
know what you think.
>> If you have more questions
for us, we'll be available in
the VR -- excuse
me, the web sandbox which is
over on that end and thank you
so much for joining us today and
please enjoy the rest of Google
I/O.
Connection test.
(Standing by
for session to begin at two
thirty p.m.
2:30
.)
.
"Realtime KANGS
Realtime captioning on this
screen.
Cube
Kubernetes
.
>> How is everybody doing?
Wow.  You guys are very
enthusiastic.  Fantastic.
May time in is Terry Ryan and I
a developer advocate for Google
Cloud Platform.  My mission
today is to kind of walk people
through what is a typical
journey through taking an App
that you have had somewhere else
and bringing it to Google cloud.
And my focus is on virtual
machine technology.  So a
pattern we see from a lot of
people is when they first come
to GCP they want do what they've
done elsewhere but on us.  How
do you do that?  How do you get
started? That's my goal today.
So, if that's what you signed up
for, great.
If not, well hopefully you'll
stay.
So before I get started, it's
really important for me to know
who everybody in the audience
is.  I'll probably do this with
a show of hands.
Who here is a developer all the
time?  Okay.  Web developers?
Mobile developers?  Back end
developers?  How many people
here do systems work?  I see
some overlap with the
developers.  Is it because you
love dev-ops or because your
company won't hire more people?
Which is it?  Okay.  Anybody
else?
Are there designers or UX
people, UI people?  Fantastic.
Any managers in the room?  So
there's a lot more of us than
there are of you.  One, manager
jokes fly.  And two I hear you
systems people could use more
people.  Just I hear that from
the crowd.
All right.  So I know what jokes
I can make.  I know who you guys
are.  What are our goals?  Our
goals to take someone from a
journey I've got an App and I
want to get it to Google
platform.  My secondary goal is
to point out a
whole lot of things about GCP.
But I'm going fall way short on
that.  Hopefully I'll point you
in directions where if you like
it you can start learning more
and go that way, but just
be aware that this is not super
comprehensive.
So you have an App, you have it
running some place.  We usually
do what we call lift and shift.
Where we pick something up and
just plot it on our cloud
instead of running it on your
own data centers.  So I want to
show an App here.  So I'm going
to switch over to my laptop.
This is a super, super simple
App called tagger that I wrote
just to kind
of -- it's minimum viable
product.  It's just to show what
I am trying to do off here.  You
see a have a bunch of tags and a
bunch of kids because, you know,
you can always get points from
the audience for showing cute
kids.  I'm going go ahead and
just show you this is a real
thing.  It's running locally on
my laptop but it could also be
running, you know, in a
data center somewhere in my on
PREM center.  I'll hit gladiator
and hit open.  Nothing up my
sleeve.  I've got a real App
running.  I'll upload and there
we are.  App is working.
Now I'm going switch back and
talk about
the architecture in slides
.  So very, very basic, simple
App.  Again, written to
illustrate this stuff.  I've got
one single box which may or may
not be the way you want to run
your stuff.  If you are, it's
okay.  And if you are not,
please don't judge me too
harshly.  I have a single server
here.  And it's running the
application code.  It's running
the file system.  And it's
running the images.  All of that
is on one space.  I want to move
this to make it cloudy.  So our
eventual destination with this
will look like this.  Where my
database is in the cloud and my
files are in the cloud, but my
App still sits on a VM.  Which
also is in the cloud but, you
know, it's still virtual machine
I'm not
trying to get you to move to
Kubernetes
or con server list or anything
like that.  Well I'll talk about
those topics but we're not going
to move to them in this App.
We talk about virtual machines
on Google Cloud Platform.  They
are we call it compute engine.
We have several engines.
Compute engine is our virtual
machine.  It has some properties
and things I'm going to talk
about.  You can dial in how many
processes you need from 1-96.
Then you have a range of MENLry
based on that from point 6-624
gigs.
You have digs you can install 64
terabytes of persistent disk.
Three terabytes of SSD and you
can go up to 208 gigs of ram
desk with the memory on your
system.
We have images that go with
these machines already that have
operating systems set up.  But
you can configure your own.  I'm
going shove that off in the
interface.  I'm going to switch
to do another demo.
And you should -- ut-oh.  It was
working two seconds ago.  No,
all right.  It's working.  All
right.
So I am going to go ahead and
create a
new entrance I want to run my
stuff on.
I want to hit create instance.
When I do that I can give it a
name and I can put it in a data
center.  So why don't we do US
west because that's where we
are.  But note we can go all
over Asia and Europe and South
America and Australia.  But I'll
stick to being close to her.
When I go to set up my machine,
there is a whole bunch of set
types of machine.
Like sixty core and 32 core.
But one of the cool things us
can dial in.  If you have a use
case where you only need 44
processors to do the work you
need to do, with other kind of
choices you have to go either 32
and be under inspect or go 64
and waste all that money on
processors you don't need.  With
us you can dial NP exactly to
what you want and see exactly on
the right what the impact of
those choices are.  Right?
I got a little warning, at some
-- there we go.
That came up -- I hit didn't it
hit right.  Basically a warning
that says you could probably get
a better price if you configure
it this way.  Which is kind of
cool.
I'm going stick with our set
images because I don't want to
pay that much.  Then I'll go to
the boot disks.  With boot disk
I have a whole bunch of choices
of different operating system.
Container OS and red hat and
Windows even.  Yes you can do
Windows on Google Cloud
Platform.  But I'm going to go
ahead and keep with the
defaults.  I'm going to hit
select.  You notice I have
another couple options.  I can
activate each GTP.  I can open
up the fire wall.  Not going to
do it this time around.  But one
of the favorite things about
this interface is down at the
bottom there's this equivalent
rest or command line link.
So after I configure this whole
thing I click on this and get
this box that says here's
exactly how to do this on the
command like.  Then I can
configure it once in the
interface, and then take this
and
automate it and use build
scripts and I don't have to
write these things from scratch.
Which is really helpful.
Why don't we create this.  We
like to say these spin up in
tens of seconds.  Meaning when
I'm in a hotel room practicing
this because I'm doing it at I/O
it takes ten seconds.  When I am
in front of people it takes
longer.
I don't know how it knows but
somehow it knows.  All right.
Good.  You don't register.  So
I'm happy.  It doesn't know you
are here.  So I'm going to hit
SSH.  When I do instead of
having to pull down Certs to
connect to this VM I can do it
right through the interface,
right through the web.  Which I
love because I can travel
without my laptop as long as I
can get
to a browser I can take care and
manage my stuff.
First time you have SH in a box
it takes a little time.  At this
point and I wouldn't worry about
the text here too much but I
will blow it up a little bit.
At this point I would go through
an App and get update right.
Then it will fail because I
should have SA dueed it.
I will do App get update then
start rolling through and
installing software.
I feel like that would strain
our relationship as an audience
and speaker
if I were just sit here an
install lamp.  If I sat there
and installed all those things
over and over again I feel like
I would lose you.
So I have a solution for what
which is I have already done
that on another machine.  I've
then taken that machine and
created what we call a disk
image from it.  I said you could
use ours but you could also use
your own.
So I'm going to create a second
instance.  I'm going to open up
the firewall.  Open up the HTTP
port.
When I go to select images,
instead of
using OS images I am going to
use custom images.  We'll see
that I have one called tagger
latest which I already built.
I'll hit select.
And now when this App comes up,
it
will be running completely the
whole software stack.  None of
my software is on there, but all
the supporting software I need
is there.  Hopefully in a second
this will come up.  Hopefully it
has not identified that you are
here.  And when it comes up you
will notice that I have these
external IP addresses here.  And
some of them are linked and some
aren't.  The one I just created
wasn't linked
because it didn't open up HTTP.
But on this one when I click on
it should go right to the
default page.  I've installed.
I have software running.  It's
all set and ready to go.
One last thing I want to show
you before
I switch back to presenting is
up here in the upper right I've
got this little command prompt.
Another one of my favorite
features.  Instead of having to
inSaul all the SDK and all the
stuff it takes to manage Google
cloud on my laptop I can use
cloud shell.  It spins up a VM
under the covers that I don't
get charged for.  It's got a
home directory so I can use it
over and over again.  I can save
scripts there.
But now I have a one-way or I
have access to this without
having to install all the stuff
on my computer.  So really
helpful.  Really, really great
for trying stuff out.
So, with that, I'm going to
switch back
to presenting.  And talk through
a little bit of what I did here.
So, if you want to start doing
this, you know, programatically
and repeatedly and put it into
your build cycles, you can do
all of what I did here with G
cloud commands.
This one is G cloud compute
instances create.  Then I would
probably want to run commands on
those boxes.  So I can do that.
G cloud compute SSH virtual
machine name and the command I
want to run remotely.  Then
finally I have files that I want
to get on to those VMs.
I can do that with G cloud
compute SCP.  Between these
three I can completely automate
the creation and configuration
of a machine repeatbly.  I do a
lot of this.
I do a lot of scripting because
I don't want to do it by hands
because I make mistakes.
We talked about virtual machines
and disk images.
You can start with ours like I
did.  Put all the software on
it, make a disk then save it as
an image.  But you can also make
them from scratch.  Use virtual
box to make images from scratch
and upload them to us.
Networking I talked about a
little bit about that you get
external IPs.  One of the things
I didn't talk about is that any
-- you can always get an IP
address and it will always be EE
term RAL.  Meaning if the
machine goes down when it comes
back up it will get another IP
address.  But any of those
addresses you can grab and say
make static and keep.  So, if
you start fooling around with a
box and set it to ephemeral and
you are worried you can grab it
and hold on to it.  We don't
charge you for those.  The only
time we charge you and this is
something that members of my
team just learned.  We only
charge you if you don't use it.
If you have an IP address and
it's in use statically we don't
charge for I.  It's when you
#35SHG on it we have a nominal
charge.  A couple cents.  Just
to disincentivize you from
holding on to IP addresses for a
long time.  Or a lot of IP
addresses for a long time.
Showed off the fire wall.  I
just did the HTTP rule.
But you can create arbitrary
rules.
They get this tag that gets
applyed to your machine and that
is what will determine whether
or not your firewall is open on
the machine.  One thing I didn't
show off is something called
cloud launcher.
Our cloud our V MZ, UR images
start at the software layer like
the OS layer.
But if you want like Cassandra
or word press or droople or
something like that on your
machine, you can use one of
these and sort of shortcut
having to do the whole build.
Now it's important to know that
we don't manage it once you
build it.  We just help you
build it.
I'm going on take a slight
detour and I talked about the
cloud shell for a second.
That's really important.
It's a little VM and you have a
home directory that follows you.
You shove scripts in there that
you use and it will be there the
next time.  It basically means
while I love having my laptop I
never actually have to have it
somewhere when I might need to
log in to Google Cloud Platform.
We're back from that little
diversion.  So now let's talk
about storage.  Because that's
the crux of what this App does.
It stores files and stores data.
I'm going start with the files
part of it, the images.  So for
images we call that blob data.
Because I don't know that sounds
gross I guess.  Cloud storage is
the tool for that.  So it's for
files, for videos, for
pictures, for unstructured
documents.  Now there are four
types and I'll talk about them
but they all have the same
interface.  The metaphors you
have seen with other cloud
providers the idea of a bucket
and objects in that bucket.
That's what cloud file store --
that's how cloud storage works.
So we have the four types.
We've got multi-regional,
regional, nearline and coldline.
They all have different use
cases and different costs
associated with it.  Long story
short, multi-regional is for
global data.  For you pushing
the data as close to the people
that are going to be using it.
So it's for people outside your
company.  For web presence, Webb
Apps, mobile Apps, streaming
video.
Regional in contrast is you want
to keep the data close to where
it's being used just like in
global but for this it's being
used for internal purposes.
It's for running data jobs and
doing big data analysis on large
data sets.  You want that data
near the computers that are
going to be doing that but don't
necessarily have to be near the
public.
Another thing to note here is
just because it's regional
doesn't mean it's only access
TIBL from the region it's in.
It just means it is fastest in
that region.  You can still pull
this data from other places
around the world.  So you are
not restricted where you can use
this data from.
Nearline and coldline are long
term options.  In case of
nearline it's for backups and
long tail media.  Stuff that's
going to be used regularly but
infrequently.  And for coldline
it's things like compliance and
disaster recovery.  So, if you
are pulling down data from
coldline, you are probably also
loading your resume in an editor
just in case right.  So that's
the distinction we use for
these.
As we go to the right the price
goes down because it's less
accessible and less easy to get
to.
The time to first byte for
global or multi-regional versus
coldline, coldline
is slower time to first bite.
So accordingly the costs go
down.  But for nearline and
coldline, when you retrieve the
data you get charged for it.
And, in this case, it's one
gigabyte per -- I'm sorry.  All
those prices were gigabyte per
month.  This is per gigabyte.
When you pull down data out of
nearline it's going to cost you
a cent per gigabyte.  Out of
coldline it's going to cost you
five cents per gigabyte.  The
idea here is we want to
encourage you like to store
stuff and hope you never need to
use it.  And that's why the
pricing is set up that way to
enKUBLG that sort of use.
I'm going to do a quick demo of
cloud storage.  So I'm going to
switch back to my laptop.  I'm
going show how easy it is to set
one of these up.  Like I said
it's a bucket.  So I'm going to
create a bucket.
I'm going call it tagger 102.
Because the names have to be
unique.  I am going to go ahead
and create it.  It's
multi-regional.
I'm creating a multi-regional
bucket.  I'm going to upload the
files.  I'm going take my files
from here that I already had.
I'm going to upload them.
And see how our network is
doing.
Okay
.  WiFi network is -- there we
go.  All right.
So you will see I have a bunch
of images now loaded in.
Now I can't get to any of these
-- I mean, Google cloud can see
these and share them along
Google Apps but the public can't
see them.  The way I enable them
to the public is I can click
this little thing here and say,
I don't know, share pubically.
When I do that I get a public
link.  So even though I just
uploaded it it's now globally
available and able to pull down.
If I were to URL hack and change
it to one of the other images
was that kid in
the Ewok costume I hit Ewok JPEG
and it's not there.  So you can
be gradualar with what you share
and don't share.  I'm going
switch back to presenting.  Wait
I'm not going to switch back.
It will switch back on this.
And let's talk about about what
I did.  I wanted to upload
files.
You can do that with the GS util
command.  I don't want to
manually put all my files
through a web interface.
I can share pubically using GS
util.  You can do them per file.
You can also do them per bucket.
That's how I tend to do it.  I
share the bucket then I try not
to have shared and non-shared
stuff in the same.  Even though
you can.  Just saying for me I
don't want to accidentally share
something.  So I usually try to
make that distinction at the
bucket level.
Now my App was writing to file
storage on the server.  I now
need it to write to the cloud
storage.  So for that I want to
use our client libraries.
You will see there's a whole
list of languages available.  If
your favorite language is not
here, one, I apologize.
Two, we have a rest API and it's
pretty well documented so you
can sort of do this stuff
without needing the client
library.
But this App is PHP so I don't
have a problem.  Please don't
judge me for PHP.  I figured it
was very readable.  Move
uploaded file.  Source
destination.  Something has been
uploaded to the server and we
move it to a file location.  To
do the same thing but point it
to cloud storage I have to pull
in the storage library then
create a storage client and
bucket and upload to that
bucket.  It's a little bit more
code but not tremendously more.
And dropping it in was
relatively simple and painless
to do.
So that is client library.
We've carved off images we now
have our application code and
database together.  We need to
fix that.
We'll go to application storage
and get the SQL versus no SQL.
That is not anything I I want to
wade in.  I am sure we all have
beliefs.  It's okay.  I'm not
going to question them.  But
I'll talk about what we have for
these two types.
So we have cloud SQL which is a
tracing
didal excel -- traditional excel
server.  It's what we called
vertically scalable.
You can keep making the its
running on bigger and bigger.
But when you need to scale out
these don't scale out perfectly
well.
You can do reply cat sets but it
is
still good old-fashioned my SQL
and postscripts.  We manage the
backups and make it easy to set
up replicas and take the pain
out of running these machines.
We also have cloud spaner which
like let me put in context you
would never use on this App.
It's for gigantic worldwide
companies
that have, you know, very high
rates of queries per second.  It
is not for this tagger App.  But
that's also available to you.
It has a SQL interface.  It's
structured data.  Highly
available.  Strongly consistent.
Our network makes that work
where we can make those claims
that it is both those things.
It's horizontally kaleable.  But
keep in mind it is definitely
cost-effective when you have the
scale for it.  Like this small
App it would be overkill.
Now let's talk about no SQL.
We've got cloud data store and
fire store.
Anybody here use fire base?
Cloud fire store has a lot of
integration with fire base and
there's a similar product called
cloud fire store
-- I forgot the branding of it
but it is the same thing.  It
allows you to use fire base's
APIs
to write to a guy JONTic no SQL
store in the back end.  It's
great when you are writing
clients that you don't want to
back end at all.  You just want
the front end App to talk to the
data store.  That's what fire
store is for.
Data store is more for I've got
an App that I've written that I
want to store stuff to and
that's running on the back end
and that communication will
happen
between cloud data store and
your App.
Big table.  You don't see it a
lot in applications.  Very
rarely someone will use this for
an application because it's got
low latency.  Where it really
sells is big data jobs.
You put a whole bunch of lobs in
there and stole them.  That's
SCLOUD big table.  It's only
cost-effective at scale.
Which one should we use?
Well I kind of set this up so
there is an obvious winner.  I'm
not going to rewrite all of my
logic from SQL to no SQL so I'm
not using any of the no SQL
solutions and cloud spaner is
overkill so I'm going to use
cloud SQL.
And use my SQL because I don't
want to rewrite stuff.  I'm
going do a quick demo to show
you what this interface looks
like.
I've got SQL here.  I have the
database set up but I'm going to
create a new one.
You will see I've got options my
SQL versus postscript.  We help
you like what you are going to
do it for.  For development,
taking or production?  I'm going
to use staging.  Because among
its many features it has this.
Which is automatic increases
storage.  So when I set up my
disks in the back
end, it will automatically make
my disk bigger if I start to run
afoul of the size of the disk.
Up to 64 terabytes.
So I'm going configure one of
these.  I can choose version,
machine type.  So I can make the
machine bigger.
They're based on our VM images.
They kind of fit with the VM
standard images.
You can choose SSD or standard
disk.  One of the cool things
you need to know is if you need
higher read write
performance to your disk you
need to get bigger drives.
When I change this number from
twenty
to 200 I get more loTts.  I
think that's what I am going to
show off about cloud SQL.
I'm going stitch back to present
mode.
How do I get my stuff in to
cloud SQL?  I take it and upload
it to cloud storage.  From
storage I ingest it in to cloud
SQL.  Which brings up something
kind of important which is this
work flow moving it to cloud
storage then pull it somewhere
else is pretty common.
You have a whole bunch of lob
data you put it in cloud storage
and ingest it into big query.
You have a images you want to
analyze put it in cloud storage.
You will see two tools.  Cloud
storage acts as a hub and the
other is called pub sub.
There's a cool demo in the cloud
dome.
What pub/sub does is it is a
messaging bus.  You say I am a
publisher and a whole bunch of
people subscribe to the channel
that you publish to.  You send a
structured piece of data that
does something and it gets
communicated out to all the
people that are -- all the
subscribers of that service.
It's very high through put.
Basically allows you to off-load
stuff to other pieces of the
cloud when you
need do and doo it with a cuing
system that's fast.
Let's talk about common problems
people have when they start
running database servers on us.
One problem I feel like I should
communicate it to you is that
when you run G cloud SQL to
ingest the SQL you might get an
error.  That error is going to
look like this.  Internal error.
Then you raise the VER bossty of
the G cloud command you get that
it is a SQL error.  What you do
is in the SQL interface there's
this tab called operations.  And
in operations we can see that
there's an error and we can see
the line number.  We see all the
SQL data we need to trouble
shoot this.  For this particular
error it was that
I had done a my SQL dump like
you normally do but I had super
permissions which you can't have
on cloud SQL so it balked at
that.  So just a couple things
if you are switching over to
this you might want to
know off the top before you head
(?) Trying to track down what it
says.
What happens if we, Google
cloud, don't offer something you
need?
Like we have my SQL but you want
co Sandra or one of the other
storage solutions.  You do two
options.
Build it yourself from scratch.
Mixing metaphors.  Or you can
use cloud launcher to build one
of our existing solutions.
Like Cassandra, REDIS, Mongo and
a whole bunch more.  In each of
these cases it's important to
know we don't maintain the
software.  We maintain the OS.
So in all the cases with compute
engine, I didn't mention this
earlier, but we do live
migration.
So when you update the machine
it will continue running even
through the update.  You'll
never have down time because
we're updating the hardware.
We migrate and solve that for
you.  In each of these cases you
get that with whatever solution
you build.  But we won't update
the software or run backups for
you for them if we don't say we
do like we do with cloud SQL.
All right.  So now here we are.
We have taken our App we've
moved it
to cloud and put it on a VM then
we've off loaded database and
storage to different parts of
the cloud.  Now I'm free to
start thinking like well since
all of the data, all of the
State of this application is
WHELS elsewhere I can start
making decisions about how to
run this.
Do I want to run a group of VMs
behind a load balanceer?  I can
do that.
If I want to go to a serverless
solution I can do that.  I will
talk a little bit about how to
do this with a VM.
How do I scale this system?
I am going to switch to demo one
last thing I believe.  And
that's going to be something we
call managed instants groups
.  So these take minutes to get
rolling instead of seconds.  So
I'm not -- again, not going to
strain our relationship and do
things that take that long in
front of you.  But I will kind
of walk you through
creating and managing instance
group.  So, basically, I define
a group.
I say I want this to be a group
of tagger machines.  I want them
all to have tagger on it.  I
want them all to run with the
same software.
So what I do is I can put this
in single location or multi-so I
can have these groups all around
the world.  I put it in a
particular zone then I can be
managed or unmanaged.  Managed
means that every machine is
based on a template and they
look exactly the time same.  We
can do things like say auto
scale.  So all the machines are
exactly the same.
If the CPU utilization ever gets
above sixty, spit up another
one.  Then another one.  Until
it gets below sixty.  I can say
things like make sure
they're there are always three
no more
than ten and scale with sixty
percent process utilization.  I
can build that and you will see
that I did here on this
interface and that so I have
these three machines.  If I
click through I can see that
each one of these machines is
running.  Each one of these
machines is open to the
internet.  And each one of these
machines is running Apache just
like I want it to.  So we're all
good.
So the next thing I want to do
is take this and make it
redundant.  Basically share it
with the world.  To share it
with the world I need a load
balancer.  So I'm going to pull
in tagger load balancer.  Again
this takes awhile to go.  So I'm
going to walk you through the
way it's set up.  I say give me
a front end.  It's HTTP.  It's
on port 80.
I serve it up on an IP address.
I say from the back end serve
this instance group.  So this
instance group everything is
open on port 80.  You are
listening on port 80.  Combine
them and make that redundant.
Once I do that I have this set
up the way it is.  Each one of
those machines is answering
calls to the internet.  But if I
go to this machine this IP
address that I get here, it's
also up and running.  And so
like I said, these will scale,
all of that scaling can happen
usually within a minute to two
minutes.  So, if you start
getting a load spike we can
scale upload relatively quickly.
But not necessarily
instantaneously.  Okay?
So that is scaling out this
application with the load
balancer.
So, with, that I'm going to
switch back to presenting.  And
take you through a couple more
things.
We talked about instance groups
which can be managed or
unmanaged.  Why would they be
unmanaged?
Maybe you want to combine a 2CPU
box and 60 box.  I don't know
why but you want to.  That's
cool.  No judgment.  You are
responsible for scaling and all
that.
Because we couldn't figure out
CPU utilization like what should
we add.  We are not using a
template.  So you can manage
that.  But if you use manage, we
can auto scale and we can auto
heal.  You have health checks on
your App and it goes down, we
can rebuild a VM for you and
bring it back in to the instance
group.
Networking talk about load
balancers.
We have HTTP and
TCP and UDP and we have IB
certain only that are accessible
within your project.
Now that's how I scale VMs.  But
I do work for Google cloud and
we
use the bus words container and
serverless a lot.  So I felt
like it was necessary to talk
about these.  How many people
here are using docker?
How many people are using
Kubernetes?  Okay.  All right.
For those of you that aren't,
I'll
give a quick what is containers
at a very, very high level and
watch the faces of the people
that raised their
hands as they squirm and scheme
through this over simplified
definition.  Containers are
basically a package
that contains all the code and
run-time components to run your
App.  Then there's an
environment, docker or
Kubernetes, that will trick the
process into thinking it's the
only one running on the machine.
So you can do crazy things like
have multiple versions of of the
same software running on the
same machine.  You can stack as
many more processes on the
machine than you can do VMs on
the same hardware.
So, basically, there are a lot
of efficiencies you get from
switching to this model.  We
have two products that we say
are our container products on
Google cloud.
They're Kubernetes engine which
is managed Kubernetes.  If you
don't know what Kubernetes is
basically you have dozens or
hundreds or thousands of
containers all doing different
things.  You want to run them in
a way that you are not managing
individual containers.
You put them into a Kubernetes
cluster with instructions on how
to run them and it will keep
them running whether they're
micro-service, a web App or a
batch job somewhere.
App engine flexible is you have
one App that you just want to
scale that's already in a docker
container you can push it to App
engine flexible and we'll scale
it for you from one to as many
instances you need.
What is serverless?
Serverless is a marketing term.
It is right?  There is a server
there.  There's not some beast
living beyond space and time
running your load for you.  But
it describes I think a really
important distinction.
Different type of App.  Which is
you pay as you go.  Whatever you
use you pay for.  If you don't
use it, you don't pay for it.
And you don't care about the
underlying infrastructure.  You
don't have to know about number
of servers or nodes or anything.
We'll just run it for you as
much or as little as you need.
So when we talk about serverless
on Google Cloud Platform we're
talking about cloud functions.
Which the unit of an abstraction
is a function.  And you attach
that to some sort of event.
Someone drops a file into a
bucket.  Someone sends a message
to a pub sub cue.  You respond
with that cloud function.  We
also have serverless solution
that's App based.
It's very restricted in TERMs of
what you can do.  You can only
use certain languages.  You can
only use code in that language.
But what you get for that
restriction is incredible
scaling.
App engines can scale from 0 to
pretty much infinite in a
relatively short period of time.
I have a demo where I will scale
an App that's cold, like I
didn't use it,
to about 8500 queries per second
in about five minutes.
And to put that in perspective
8500QPS is what Wikipedia gets.
So I'm able to go from nothing
cold to a Wikipedia scale
application in five minutes with
App engine.  But it comes as a
cost.  Restricted abilities to
do things.
So the question is should I
switch over to one of these?
That's like a whole talk.
That's a whole separate talk of
whether or not you should use
serverless machines or contain
errs.  But for this App without
any context no.  It's working
where it is.  I'm bringing it
over some place else.  I don't
necessarily want to put a lot of
effort into it.  Lift and shift
is absolutely fine.
If I have plans to grow this App
bigger, or to grow the whole
bunch of other applications
maybe it might make sense to
containerize.  But that would
depend on the context.  If I am
going to have inconsistent use
maybe serverless would work out
too.  But for this particular
application with no context I'm
not switching I'm staying on
VMs.
We've come to the end.  I've
taken you through a pretty good
tour of what we have.  We've
started with a single App all
running on one machine.  But we
ended up here where we've
basically taken all the state
and pushed it elsewhere and we
can now grow and expand have a
lot of different options with
the computing level.
There was so much I couldn't
cover.  I was pretty vicious
with my editing pen because I
wasn't getting under forty
minutes.
So I didn't talk about our NL
APIs which are awesome.  Same
sort of inserting the code the
way we did cloud storage.
You can grab with vision API --
I'm not going to -- don't switch
over, but you will notice that I
have tags that I got from cloud
vision API instead of making
people do it.  So this App I can
just completely replace data
entry on this App with cloud
vision if I wanted to.  I think
it's funny.  It thinks that the
Ewok, the kid in
the Ewok costume is carnivorean.
Which is kind of scary.  But I
don't know how he is raised.  I
don't know.
So just see a kid in an Ewok
costume be afraid.  But cloud
vision was able to do that for
me.  It also picked out skin and
children and picked a whole
bunch of details from those
images.
I didn't talk about the API
library.  If you are using any
of the other
Google APIs like maps or ads GS
you can manage them and use them
in your Google
platform project with the fault
credentials.  You can just run
it with kind of very
minimal authentication but
securely.
Talking about stack driver.  If
you need your lobs or monitoring
and all that stuff, stack driver
can do this for if you.  All
this stuff I didn't get a chance
to talk about will all help you
run in this scenario.  If you
look at Google cloud as a whole
I talked about the computer
platform.  We covered a lot of
it.  We covered storage and
databases.  We covered a little
bit of networking.
We covered a little bit of big
data in that I mentioned pub
sub.  Mentioned the machine
learning APIs.  Mentioned
developer tools.  And mentioned
management tools.  But if you
look at this whole list there's
a lot missing because there's
just a lot more to the platform.
So I'd ask if you have any
questions or if this has ignited
anything in you please make sure
you stop by the cloud booth.
There's everybody from Google --
not everybody but a lot of
people from Google cloud are
there and can answer your
questions.  And hopefully I
showed youed how you could
on-board and get started with
Google cloud.
If you sign up you get a three
hundred dollar free credit for
twelve months that you can use
to kick the tires and hopefully
you go from here to discovering
more about what's on the
platform.  So thank you very
much.  I'm Terry Ryan.  Please
feel free to heckle me on
Twitter @TP Ryan.  If you have
any questions I'll be around but
I think I'm running short on
time.
So have a good rest of your I/O!
This screen used
Realtime captioning on this
screen.
>> Thank you for joining this
session.
Brand ambassadors will assist in
directing you through the exit.
If you have registered for the
next session in this room we ask
you that please clear the room
and return via the registration
line outside.  Thank you.
Cube
Kubernetes
Realtime captioning on this
screen.
Sys
.
>> RICHARD UHLER: Hello.
Welcome to everyone here.  And
those of you following along on
the live stream.
My name is Richard Uhler.  I am
a software engineer on the
Android run time team.  I've
spent the last three years
trying to better understand
memory use on Android.  And more
recently I've been working with
first party App developers to
tackle the challenges of
evaluating and improving Android
memory use.  It's great to see
so many of you here interested
in Android memory use.
To start off why should you as
an App developer care about
memory use?  For me it's really
about the Android ecosystem.
The ecosystem of applications,
of devices, and of the users of
those devices.
Where memory comes in to Play is
not so much for the premium
devices where you have a lot of
memory available but much more
for the entry-level devices.
Because these devices need a
decent selection of low memory
Apps to work well.  If
application memory use and
requirements grow, then the
entry-level devices won't work
as well.  If they don't work as
well, OEMs will not want to
produce these devices.  If they
don't produce these devices well
we're kind of excluding a bunch
of
users from our Android ecosystem
and that's a bad thing.
So App developers have a role to
Play when they're developing
applications to do whatever they
can to be efficient in your
memory use, to reduce your
memory use, keep it from growing
too much so that we have a nice
selection of low memory
applications so that entry-level
devices behave well, they work
well.  And if that happens, OEMs
will produce these devices and
we can put them in the hands of
users to use our applications.
So in this talk I'm going to
talk about three broad
categories.  Three areas.
First, I'll talk about the
mechanisms
that come in to Play on Android
device when it's running low on
memory and how that impacts the
user.
I'll talk about how we evaluate
an application's memory impact.
And in particular very important
FALTH factors to be aware of
that come in to Play with that.
Third, I will give you some tips
for
how to reduce your
applications's memory impact
especially given a lot of this
allocations going in your
application originate deep
within the Android stack
on which its running .
Let's start.
What happens on a device when
it's running low on memory?
Well memory on device,
physically memory is device is
organized or grouped into pages.
And each page is typically
around four kill OE bites.
Different pages can be used for
different things.
So pages can be used pages.
These are pages actively used by
processes.
They can be cache pages.
Pages memory being used by
processees but the data they
contain also lives on the device
storage.  Which means we can
sometime reclaim those pages.
Then there might be free pages
of memory sitting on the device
you are not using.
So what I've done is I took two
gigabyte device and I started it
doing nothing.  So at the very
beginning of time the run time
is not running.  And then I
started using it more and more.
So lots of different
applications, exercising them
which has the affect of using
more and more memory on the
device over time.
So we can see at the beginning
the flat line there is before I
started the run time.  Then I
start the run time up.  There's
plenty of free memory available
on the device.  And this is a
happy device.  Because if an
application needs more memory,
the (?) Can satisfy that request
from the free memory.
Over time as you use more
memory, the free memory gets
exhausted.  It goes down.  And
to avoid very bad things from
happening, the Linux colonel has
G swap D.
And K swap D's job is to find
more free memory.
This kicks in when free memory
goes
below what I call the KSWAPD.
And the main mechanism used is
to reclaim cache pages.
In an App goes to access a cache
page or a memory that was on a
cache page that's been reclaimed
it's going to take a little
extra time to reload that data
from device storage.  But
probably the user's not going to
be noticing this.  So that's
okay.
Now as I exercise more and more
applications, they use more
memory, the
number of cache pages is going
to fall
as K swap starts to reclaim
them.  If it gets too low the
device can start to thrash.
This is a very bad thing because
basically the device will lock
up.  On Android we have a
mechanism called the low memory
killer that kicks in when the
amount of cache memory falls too
low.  And the way this works is
low memory
killer is going to pick a
process on the device and it's
going to kill it and it's going
to get back all the memory that
that process was using.
Now this is an unhappy state to
be in especially if the low
memory killer
kills a process that the user
cares about.
So let me go through and tell
you a little more about how the
low memory killer decides what
to kill.
Android keeps track of the
processes running on the device.
And it keeps them in a priority
order.
So the highest priority
processes are
native processees.  Ones that
come with Lynn IKS.
Things like init, KSWAPD, net D,
LOGD
and ADBD, basically any native
process that is running is
categorized into this.  The next
highest priority process we have
is a system server which is
maintaining this list.  Followed
by what are known as persistent
processes.  These are core
functionality.
To NFC, SMS, those kind of
things.  Next we have the
foreground App.  So this is
going to be the application the
user is directly interacting
with.
In this case perhaps the user's
viewing a web page so they're
interacting with the Chrome App.
Next in priority are what are
called
perceptible or visible
processes.  These are not
processes the user's
directly interacting with but
perceptible in some way.  For
instance if you have a search
process maybe it has a little
bit of UI on the screen.  Or if
the user's listening to music in
the background, then they can
hear that music through their
headphones.  They can perceive
it.
After the perceptible Apps we
have services.  These are
services started by applications
for things like syncing or
uploading, down loading from
cloud.  Then we have the home
App.  This is what you get when
you hit the home button.  It
often hosts your wallpaper if
you have something there.
So in addition to these running
processes we also keep track of
what the
previous application user used
was.
So maybe they're using this red
App and it brings them to Chrome
with a link.  Then when they
switch to Chrome that App is
going to be the previous App.
And we also keep in memory a
bunch of
other processes which are cached
applications the user used
before.  Some of them maybe
recently.  Some of them not for
a little bit of a while.
I want to point out here these
cache
processees, when I use the term
"cache" this is different than
the cache memory pages I was
talking about previously.
Okay.  So the reason we keep
around previous
and cache process eeee because
if the user wants to switch to
one of these applications and
say they want to switch to the
previous application it's very
quick to switch to that.
I should say this is for device
in a normal memory state.  So if
you want to switch to a previous
application that's very quick.
But also if you want to switch
to an application that happens
to be in a cache process, that's
very quick to do because it's
already in memory.
If we step back though and say,
well, what happens when the
device is low on memory?
In that case, we can imagine the
memory used by the running
applications is growing.
The number of cache pages drops
below the low memory killer
threshold.  The low memory
killer now has to come in and
kill something to free up some
memory.  Well it's going to
start killing from the bottom of
this list.
So maybe it kills this blue
application.  That's gone.  We
get more memory back for the
applications that are still
running.  But if the user now
wants to switch and start using
that blue application, it's not
cached any longer.
It means it's going take a
noticeably long time to launch
that application.  It could be
two or three seconds and maybe
it's lost some state.  So this
is where the user first starts
to real feel something's going
on here
that's making things slower .
If the processes that are
running continue to use more
memory, so we get under more
memory pressure, low memory
killers going to start to kill
more cache processes.  If they
continue to grow more and more,
until eventually there's only a
few cache processes left, at
this point we see the device
memory status is critical.  This
is a very bad place to be.  If
the running processes continue
to use more memory, low memory
killer is going to have to kill
more processes.  Eventually it's
going to end up killing the
whole map.  At this point the
user's going to ask, hey, what
just happened to my wallpaper
because when they go home it's
going be a black screen for a
few seconds before the wallpaper
starts up again.
If it's even worse, maybe a
perceptible process is killed.
The user is going to say what
just happened to my music.
I was listening and it just
stopped.  Really bad case.  The
foreground App is killed.  To
the user this looks like the App
crashed.  And the most extreme
case you can get
in to for low memory killer
basically it needs to kill the
system server.  This looks like
your phone has rebooted.
These are all very visible
impacts of what happens when a
device is running low on memory.
It's not a good user experience
when this is happening on your
device.
I want to go back to this graph
that I was showing before about
what happens to the memory pages
on the device as you use more
memory.  This was a 2 gigabyte
device.  What do you think it
looks like, this
graph, for 512 Meg abate device?
I'll give you a few seconds to
think
about that
megabyte device?  I'll give you
a few seconds to think about
that.  Do you have an idea what
it looks like?
So I tried it for a 512
mega-bite device.  Start the run
time and used more memory and it
looks like this.  Because
there's so little memory
available at the beginning,
there's very
few free pages we can use up
before the
K swap did D has to kick in and
very few cache pages we can
reclaim before the low memory
killers needed to start killing
things.  So you can imagine if
you have this device and the low
memory is always
active and always killing
processes and leads to a bad
user experience, then maybe OEMs
are not going to be too
interested in shipping this
device.  Because it just doesn't
work well and that gets back to
the ecosystem challenges I
mentioned in the beginning.
So this is why we care about
memory.
Now how do we figure out how
much memory an application has
used?
How do we know your
application's memory impact?
I told you that memory on device
is broken down in to pages.
The Linux KOL NERL is going to
keep track of each device.
Maybe we have a system process,
Google Play services process, a
couple of Apps running on the
did device.  We want to know
each of their memory impacts.
Just count up the number of
pages it's using.  It's a little
bit more complicated than this.
Because of sharing.  Because
multiple processes on the device
can be sharing memory.  For
instance if you have an App
that's calling in to Google Play
services it's going to be
sharing some memory, perhaps
code memory or other kinds of
memory, with the Google Play
services process.  Then we can
ask:  How should we account for
this shared memory?  Is that
part of the responsibility of
the application?  Is that memory
impact something that we should
care about?  And there's a few
different ways that you can
approach this.
One is to use what we call
resident set size for RSS.  What
this means is when we're
counting in Apps RSS we're
saying the application is fully
responsible for all the pages of
memory that it's sharing with
other applications.
Another approach is called
proportional set size, PSS.
And, in this case, we're going
to say the App is responsible
for those shared pages
proportional to the number of
processes that are sharing them.
So in this case two
applications, processes sharing
these bakes, the application is
will say is responsible for half
of them.  If there were three
processes sharing the same
memory, we will say the
application is responsible for a
third of them and so on.  Then a
third approach you can take is
called unique set size where we
say the application is not
responsible for any of its
shared pages.
Now in general which approach to
take really depends on the
context.
So for instance if those shared
pages were not being used in a
Google Play
services App until your App
called in to Google Play
services, then maybe it makes
sense to say the App is
responsible for all of those
pages.  We want to use RSS.
On the other hand, if those
pages were sitting in memory in
the Google Play services process
before the App called in to
Google Play services, they were
always there, the App is not
bringing them in to memory, then
we wouldn't want to count them.
USS would be more appropriate.
In general we don't have access
to this high level context to
know, at least at the system
level, so the approach we take
is the most straight forward one
which is proportionate set size
with equal sharing.  One benefit
of using PSS for evaluating
application's memory impact
especially when looking at
multiple processes at the same
time is it will avoid over
counting or under counting of
shared pages.
So use PSS for your applications
memory impact.
And you can run this command.
ADB shell dump sys MEM info-S.
Give it your process name.  Or
give the process ID if you
happen to do that.  This is
going to output something like
this.
An App summary view of the
application's memory.  At the
bottom there's a total and that
number is the application's PSS.
This is ADB shell dump sys MEM
info-S.
Let's say you do this and figure
out what the PSS of your
application is.  There's a very
interesting question to ask.
How much memory should your
application be using?  Because,
you know, I say earlier if we
use a lot of memory, that's bad
because low memory killer kicks
in.  But we're actually using
memory for a reason.
We're using it to provide
features, to provide user value,
to provide delightfulness.
Everything that makes our App
great is going to be taking up
memory.  So we have this
tradeoff between user value and
memory.
That's what I am showing here on
this graph.  The tradeoff space.
In an ideal world we're kind of
up and to the left on the graph.
We're providing a lot of user
value without very much memory
impact at all.  But in practice
this is going to probably be
technically infeasible.
Because you need memory to
provide value.  And there's only
so much value you can
provide with a limited amount of
memory.
On the other hand, the other
extreme would be if you are
using a lot of memory to provide
not much value.  And I think
it's safe to say this is not a
great App.  Because it's
basically providing too much
memory.  Using too much memory.
Unfortunately, my slides are not
showing up right.
But imagine a curve on which
there's too much memory for this
App.
It's not worth it to the user to
use.  There they go.  Wonderful.
Next we can look at this corner
of the graph where we're not
providing too much user value.
We're not using too much memory.
We can say this is like a small
application.  Maybe a desk clock
App.  At the other end we can
have Apps that use a lot of
memory to provide a lot of
value.
These are large ap applications.
Maybe a photo edit or something
like that.  We can say what's
better a small App or large App?
In this case they can both be
useful.  Except that when I said
that an application is using too
much memory, that really depends
on what kind of device you are
running on.  If you are running
on a premium device it can
support much larger
applications.  But on a smaller
device, an entry-level device,
maybe this large App uses too
much memory to make sense on
that.  So really I should be
drawing a line and say too much
memory depends on the device.
Premium, mid-tier and
entry-level
might not support that large
App.
For better or for worse what I
see happening often is over time
as you develop your application
you tend to add more features.
It tends to take more memory.
So you tend to go up and to the
right in this graph.
Now this is actually good for
mid-tier and premium users
because they're getting more
value, more bang for their buck
memory wise.  But, in this case,
it's a little bit unfortunate
for the entry-level device user
because while he could use the
older version of your App you
have now added so many features
and it's using so much memory it
doesn't work as well on their
device.
So the points that I want to say
here, the takeaways.  Anything
you can do to improve your
application's memory efficiency
is good.  So, if you can move to
the left on this graph.
So less memory use without
sacrificing user value is great.
And just be aware that when you
are
adding new features while it's
good for -- it can be good for
mid-tier and premium device
users there might be a negative
consequence for entry-level
devices.
There's something wrong with
this graph.  Does anyone know
what it is?  Well let me see.
The problem that this graph is
it's suggesting that an
application's memory use is one
number.  So you give me this
application and I can tell you
it's PSS.
But in practice that's far from
the case because an
application's memory impact
depends on a whole bunch of
different things.
Such as the application use
case, the
platform configuration, and
device memory pressure.  And so
this is important to be aware of
when you are testing your
application's memory.  Perhaps
testing for regressions or to
see if an optimization is
working to make sure that you
are testing the application use
case you care about, and
you are controlling all of the
other parameters so that you are
doing a proper Apples to Apples
comparison.
Let me go into a little bit more
detail.
So how does an application use
case impact memory?
What I've done here is I started
using G Mail.  And I've switched
to different use cases in the
application over time.  So every
twenty seconds I switch.  I
started by viewing the inbox.
That's using just a little bit
100 megabytes.  Then I switched
to using an email that had text.
Using a little bit more memory.
I switched to a different
memory.  This one this time with
pictures.  It uses more memory.
Then I started to compose an
email.  Used a little bit less.
I stopped using the App and it
used less memory.  So you can
see here that depending on
the application use case, memory
impact varies significantly.
And it doesn't necessarily make
any sense to compare your
application's memory from Point
A and Point B because
these are different use cases .
Application use case is pretty
straight forward factor.
Something that's less obvious is
that your memory will change a
lot depending on what your
platform configuration is.
So what I am showing in this
graph is I've picked one of
those application use cases from
the previous slide.
G Mail looking at an email with
pictures.  And I've run it on a
bunch of different devices.
Soo nexus four, nexus 5S and a
number of different platform
versions within the same device.
For the nexus 5 I ran it on
Android M and O.  And you KAen
see there's quite a variation in
how much memory this application
use case is taking up.
This comes about because well
for different devices we have
different screen resolutions,
different screen sizes which
means bit maps take up different
amounts of memory.
You might have different
platform optimizations on the
different devices.
You might have a different SDIEG
oat configuration.  It's running
code differently.  There's a lot
of different factors going on
here which means when you switch
to a different plat form
configuration you are going to
get different memory use.
So I would say when you are
testing your application's
memory use, try as hard as you
can to use a consistent platform
set-up, the same kind of device.
The same platform version and
the same
scenario of what's running on
device .
Now there's a third case I want
to talk about which is pretty
interesting because it's a
little bit counter intuitive.
Which is an application's memory
impact depends on the memory
pressure on device.
So here what I've done is taken
Chrome
application and I started
running it on a device that had
plenty of free memory.  Then I
set up some native process in
the background that's going to
slowly use up more and more
memory on the device so that I
can see what happens to Chrome
when the device gets under
medium memory pressure or high
memory pressure.  We can see
when there's plenty of free
memory on the device, so low
memory pressure, Chrome's PSS is
pretty flat except for that
little spike which is
probably some variation in App
use case of the platform.  When
the device gets under enough
memory pressure that K swap D
kicks in and starts to reclaim
cache pages.  While some of
those pages reclaim ready going
to be from the Chrome process
and that's going to cause
Chrome's memory impact to go
down.  Its PSS is going to go
down.  Until eventually if the
device has so much memory
pressure the low memory killer
is active and it decides it
wants to kill Chrome, then PSS
for Chrome is going to very
quickly drop to zero.
So what you can see here is that
even for the same application
use case, the same platform
configuration we have a
wide range of PSS values we
might get.
So you have to be a little bit
careful.  Imagine I've come up
with this optimized version of
the Chrome APK.  And it has this
kind of lighter blue line for
the memory profile.  I'm
confident that this is an
optimized version of the APK
from a memory standpoint because
for every level of device memory
pressure it uses less memory.
But if I'm doing a test and I
sample
the PSS of the original Chrome
version
at Point A but I sample the PSS
of the supposedly optimized
Chrome version of
Point B, and I compare, and I
say oh well A is less than B so
A has less memory, I might
falsely conclude that the
original version of Chrome is
better than my optimized
version.  So you really have to
be careful when comparing PSS
values to make sure that
the device memory pressure is
the same otherwise you can get
these funny results.
My advice, because it's pretty
hard to
control for device memory
pressure, is to run your tests
on the device that has
plenty of free ram so there's
low device memory pressure and
you can see the PSS numbers will
be much more stable in that
area .
So we talked about why you want
your applications not to take up
too much memory.  How you can
evaluate your application's
memory impact.  Let me now give
you some tips for how to reduce
your application's memory
impact.
And the first tip is check out
Android studio's memory
profiler.
Profile your application's Java
heap.  This is going to give you
a ton of information, useful
information about the Java
objects on your heap.  So where
they're allocated, what's
holding on to them, how big they
are, pretty much anything you
want to know about the Java heap
you can see from this.
My tip for you is to focus on
the App heap.  So, if you open
this up in DROOID studio you
will see three heaps.
SDIEG OT, App.  The image teen
and SDIEG OT are inpartyed from
the system when your application
first launches so there's not
much you can do about that.
But definitely you can do a lot
on the App heap.
I'm not going to go into a ton
of detail how you would use this
tool.  Or actually not very much
at all because Esteban is going
to be giving a
talk tomorrow at 12:30 on
exactly how to use this tool.
His team built the tool.  He's
going be talking about how to do
live allocation tracking and
heap analysis.  So I highly
recommend you go check out
that talk tomorrow at 12:30 .
So you say, Richard, you have
told us that we should care
about PSS.  That's our
application's memory impact.
You just told us we should use
Android
studios memory profile to
profile a Java heap.  But if we
look here we see the Java heap
is not actually all that much of
the overall memory impact of the
application.  What about all the
rest of this memory?
What should we do here?
This is ticky because most of
these
applications are or allocations,
sorry, are originating deep
within the platform stack, the
Android stack.  So, if you want
to know about them and really
understand them it helps to know
a lot more about, say, how
frameworks is
implementing the view system of
resources.
Am how the native library and
web view
is working from the Android run
time.  How it's running your
code.  From the hardware
abstraction layer.  How graphics
is working.  Down to virtual
memory management in
the Linux colonel.
By the way I live in the orange
block in the middle of the
Android run time.  That's where
I am in this stack.
So you might ask, okay, so this
memory is coming from the
platform or within the platform,
should we be using
platform tools to diagnose this
memory?
For instance in dump sys memo-S
isn't
enough you can try running it
with dash A to show everything
you can see from a platform
perspective about your
application's memory use.  This
will give you a much more
detailed breakdown.
For instance instead of seeing
your code memory regressed you
can see is it
because my dot SO memory
mappings have regressed?
Or dot APK.  It will also show
you a break down of the
different categories of
memories.  So private, clean,
shared, dirty and so on.
Private dirty memory is like the
used memory I was talking about
at the beginning.
Private clean memory, clean
suggest it's like the cache
memory that also lives on dis.
Ifs that not enough detail maybe
you (?) There's show map you can
do run on your application and
it's going give you a more fine
grain breakdown of your memory
mappings.  And it will give you
specific files
that are being memorymaned in
your
application and this can help
pinpoint what files might have
led to regressions.
In the platform we have a heap
dump viewer that I've developed.
Experimental heap dump viewer
that try called ahat.  You can
try using that to learn more
about your Java heap.  Though
Android studios memory profile
will have all the same
information.
And then we also have on the
platform something called debug
MALLOC.  You can instrument your
application so that every native
allocation it makes it's going
save a back trace, a stack trace
to that allocation.
You take what we call a native
heap nap shot of your App when
it's running instrumented and if
you have the symbols you can
de-symbolize the stack traces
and you can get native stack
traces for all of your native
allocations.
This has quite a bit of overhead
at run
time so it can be a little bit
tricky to work but it provides a
lot of insight.
So we have these platform tools,
should we use them, can we use
them.  Certainly you could.
They're all available.  But some
caveats with these tools.  They
tend not to be well supported .
They have very clumsy user
interfaces
as you just witnessed from my
snapshots.  This approach
requires quite a bit of deep
platform expertise to understand
for instance what's the
difference
between DEX M map, and where are
these things coming from for
instance.  You might need to
have a rooted device such as in
the case for show map and de-bug
mall OK you might have to build
a platform yourself if you want
to get
your hands on ahat or the
symbols that
debug mall OK needs to
symbolize.  The numbers tend to
be pretty noisy.  And a lot of
the memory use you will see from
these tools is outside of your
control.
So you might see ZYGOT
allocations and run time
allocations that aren't related
to code.  So I don't think this
is the best use
of your time to try to use these
tools.
I'm going give a bit of a
different suggestion.  If you
want improve your overall memory
use, do two things.  One.
Profile your Java heap using
Android studio memory profiler
like I showed before.
Two, reduce your APK size.
Let me tell you why I think this
is a reasonable approach for you
to take to reduce your overall
memory impact.
First is that allocations that
are outside of the Java heap,
many of those are tied to Java
allocations.  So your
application is calling to the
Android frameworks which is
calling in to native libraries
under the cover which is doing
native allocations or even
graphics allocations whose
lifetime
is tied to Java objects.
For instance, just to give you a
sampling, in Java on your Java
heap if
you see these kinds of objects,
so a SQL light database, web
view, patterns,
those all have negative
allocations associated with
them.
If you have thread instants on
your Java heap that's a
associated with stack memory.
If you are using bit maps or
surface
views that can lead to graphics
memory use.  And there are many
others.
So if you want -- if you are
focusing on your Java heap and
worried it's not going to help
anywhere else, that's not true.
Optimizations on your Java heap
are going to help with other
memory categories as well.
I am trying as part of my job to
surface better this information
about these non-Java heap
allocations.  And you start to
see that if you look
at Android studios memory
profilers it will report a
number called native.  And I
just want to let you know this
is kind of an approximation or
suggestion of some of the
non-Java memory that might be
associated with the Jaffa
object.  Take it with a little
bit of a grain
of salt but it works really well
for surfacing the memory impacts
of, say, bit maps .
My second suggestion was reduce
your APK size.  Why do you do
this?  Because a lot of things
that take up
space in your APK take up space
in memory at run time as well.
For instance, your classes.DEX
file is going to take up space
in terms of class objects.  It's
going to take up code memory for
the memory map DEX file.  It's
going take up what shows up in
private other in the App summary
review.  Run-time metadata.
Representations for your fields,
methods and STRIJZ and so on.
If you have bit maps in your APK
when those are loaded at
run-time the pixel data is going
to take up space depending on
the platform version or how you
have loaded them in the Java
heap, native heap or as
graphics.
Resources in your APK take up
space on the Java heap.
Say you can an asset manager
object.  On the native heap you
have a parsed zip file structure
that shows up there and you are
going to have code memory
for your APKM map.
And dot SO files if you are
shipping libraries when you are
accessing those libraries at run
time it's going take up space.
So all of these things if you
can shrink
them, reduce your APK size, you
reduce your memory size.  I will
tell you that measuring APK
size reliably is much easier
than memory because for an APK
you actually do have one in UB
for this size.  If you measure
the APK size for a single APK
repeatedly you will get the same
result.
Very much unlike memory .
There was a talk at Google I/O
last year called best practices
to slim down your App size.  I
recommend you check that out.
That will give you more advice,
more concrete action items you
can take to
shrink these.
Let me do a quick recap why we
care about memory.  What I
suggest you to do improve your
application's memories.
First, I talked about how as we
use more memory on device, the
low memory killer is going to
kick in and it's going kill
processes.  If the user cares
about these processes, that's
bad.
If the device is getting low
memory killers running too much,
then OEMs
won't want to produce the entry
level device then we use those
devises and
lose those users.
To evaluate your application's
memory impact, use PSS.
Anything you can do to improve
your memory efficiency is good.
When you are testing for memory
regressions or optimizations,
make sure you are targeting the
application use
case you care about and
controlling for the platform
configuration.
Test on a device that has plenty
of free
ram to help control device
memory pressure.  And to reduce
your application's
memory use, do try out Android
studios
memory profiler focus on the App
heap.  Go to the session that
Esteban is giving tomorrow to
learn more about how to do that.
Do what you can to reduce your
APK size.
Check out the talk from last
year on how you can do that.
So thank you all for coming.
I would love to chat with you
more and hear more about the
memory challenges you are
facing.  So you will find me --
I'll hang out for a little while
outside after the stage.  And
you can also find me at the
Android run-time office hours
which are
5:30 to just a couple hours in
tent F after this talk.  Thank
you very much.
(Applause).
Connection test.
ADREE
Andrian Secord
drian Secord
.
YOOEZ
MOOE
DC.
.
Realtime captioning on this
screen.
KASH
Cache
.
>> LYNN JEPSEN: Good afternoon
everyone.  Welcome to our
session on how to incorporate
what's new in material design
into your existing code base.
My name is Lynn Jepsen.  I'm the
engineering lead of materials
web team.
>> ADRIAN SECORD: My name is
Adrian SEecord.  I'm the lead
for our shared code libraries.
>> LYNN JEPSEN: We're going to
show you how to incorporate all
the new goodness of material
design into your existing
developer work flow.  You are
probably in this talk because
you've already built an
application.  And you are
wondering, all these new
material tools and components,
they sound awesome, but
realistically speaking, can I
incorporate them into my
existing code base? .  The
answer is yes.  Okay we're going
to show you how to
update pieces of your App to use
material design without feeling
like you have to rewrite your
entire application.
First let's talk about some of
the new things in the material
design ecosystem and how that
supports our existing MDC
libraries.  Then we're going
does a walk through of the code
and show you some example code
using MDC.  Then we're going to
talk about some of the benefits
of using MDC in your existing
code base.
So what's new in material?
There are a lot of new things in
material design this year.
We've done a lot of
announcements.  We've done
improvements to our guidance.
We've had improvements to our
components.
And we've launched a brand-new
material tools suite.  We're
going to show you how each of
these tools supports developers.
The first tool you should
absolutely know about is
material design guidance.  We've
really expanded and enhanced
these articles this year.  So it
starts with an overview of the
material metaphor.  And then it
dives into some of the
foundational UI practices around
color, typing on RA FI,
elevation.  This is all really
good interesting reading, but
perhaps a bit theoretical when
you are trying to incorporate
material design into your
existing code base.  So material
design guidelines also provides
tactical guidance on how to use
our components.
Like button, App bar, text
field, et cetera.
These articles they're
policticable to developers not
just designers.  So let me give
you an example.  Say your
designer makes a mock with a
material design button.  When
you go the button it shows text.
But when you go to put the text
inside your application the text
wraps to two lines.  You are not
sure if you should increase the
width of the button or just let
the text wrap.  If you read the
article for the material design
button your question is answered
quite quickly.  There is clear
guidance that you should not let
the text wrap for a button.
These articles, they help
developers guess correctly when
you are in the middle of feature
development F. To make sure
these articles are applicable to
developers, we have our
own engineers like myself and
Adrian, actually collaborate
with designers as they're
drafting these articles.  Our
own collective engineering
experience, provides a lot of
perspective on what sorts of
problems
developers frequently encounter.
>> ADRIAN SECORD: So that first
part with all the guidelines
feeds into the second part we
want to talk about which is MDC.
So MDC stands for material
components.  And it's our set of
shared librarys that you can use
to build material Apps and
websites.  It's actually four
separate libraries.  And they're
built to match the guidelines
that we see on the design
website.  We want to support
developers where they're at
right now.  So the library is
the platforms we choose are
chosen based on where you are
developing.
So the first one isn't going to
be too surprising.  We have a
library called MDC Android.  MDC
Android is the open source
evolution of Android's previous
design support library.  So
we've taken a piece of what used
to be inside of Android and
pulled it out into the open
source in to GitHub so you can
use it directly to interact with
us
and work with on us on the
GitHub Reno.
The second one is MDC iOS.
This is the open source
application of Google's internal
UI library.  You might be a
little surprised that Google
does iOS development.  I'm not
sure if you are or aren't.
But Google is dedicated to
serving its customers on
whatever platform we find them.
Fun fact actually.  MDC iOS was
the first open source library
that material put out way back
in twenty 15 and it's been
hanging out
on the GitHub reap repo since
then.
Another fun fact actually at I/O
twenty 18 there are as many
developers
who say they're developing for
iOS as for Android.
The third platform you might be
not quite as familiar with
depending on sort of what talks
and things you have GEN going to
I/O at this year but it's
flutter.  So flutter is a UI
framework.  It's written in the
dart language.  You wrap your
application once then it
compiles down to native Android
and iOS Apps.  Flutter is in its
first public beta.  It's
developing a lot of buzz with
developers.  You might have seen
the talk earlier today by one of
our colleagues called code
beautiful UI with flutter and
material design.  If you didn't
see the talk and you are
interested in seeing it you can
catch it
on Youtube in a couple of hour
Zs.
>> LYNN JEPSEN: For web we
focus on providing two core web
technologies.  CSS and Java
script.  So as many of you
probably know the web is a very
diverse platform.  There a lot
of ways to do web development.
We found that providing CSS and
JAV ave script makes MDC web
usable by multiple web
frameworks.
We've also developed a way of
wrapping our Java script so we
can use it in other web
frameworks.  Now we've heard
that a lot of existing code
bases are written in one web
framework in particular --
react.  Which is why today we'd
like to
introduce a new MDC library for
react.
It depends on the CSS and
JavaScript of MDC web.  This
library is still in Alpha, but
we encourage you to go and check
it out and
give us feedback on what's
working.
>> ADRIAN SECORD: So we want to
emphasize all the MDC libraries
are open source.  They're out
there on GitHub for you to see,
to Play with, to interact with,
hopefully contribute to.  Even
at the very worst if it's just
sending us issues when you find
a bug.  And we want to make sure
these libraries use modern
development practices and
they're lined with the kinds of
development work flows that you
yourselves are using.
A second piece I'd like to
introduce here which we've seen
in previous talks is the
material theme editor.  This is
a plug-in for sketch.  If you
are not familiar with sketch, it
is a very popular design tool.
People use it for mock-ups for
prototyping, that sort of thing.
And if you use the material
theme editor inside of sketch,
the cool thing is it knows all
about the MDC components.  So
you have a lot of confidence
that whatever gets designed by
either yourself or your designer
will translate really well to
code.
A second piece that compliments
the material theme editor is
gallery.  So gallery is really
cool in that you can -- sorry
gallery you can use to sort of
share different mocks,
collaborate, comment on them
with all your different team
members.  But the neat thing is
if you are using the theme
editor, gallery basically sucks
in a whole bunch of metadata
that came from using a theme
editor and can display
interactive things like
measurements, tonights, what the
colors are that are set.  And
even probably more importantly
for developers is that you can
tap or click on any of the
elements that you see in a mock
and get the link to the
appropriate code documentation.
So here though you can't see it
because it's probably really far
away
the user has highlight Thad
first text field on the top and
is showing measurements in red.
Even more importantly is the
part on the right where it's
giving you a link into the
Android docs for the MDC text
field.  This is great because
you know that you are jumping
right into the right thing and
not trying to figure out where
did that doc go and how did I
get there.  This is a fantastic
way to collaborate with design.
So using MDC in your code base,
you know, we've been talking
about this, let's get right down
into some code.  We developed
MDC to be incorporated directly
into your code base.  We really,
really wanted to avoid
havings -- forcing you in to
getting into some huge framework
where you had
do a whole bunch of set-up or
had something that sent its
tentacles into all the aspects
of your App.
We wanted you to take say MDC
button and plunk it down and get
it using and working right away
and not have to necessarily buy
into a giant framework.  So you
are going to see next examples
from Android, iOS and the web.
So first let's pretend that you
are
about to go and get yourself a
new puppy.  So you are very
excited about this.  And you are
up on the dog adoption websites
as one does.  And, of course,
everyone knows the most
important part about bringing a
new family member into your
family is or maybe the most fun
part is choosing the name.  So
you're developer.  You've got to
choose a name.  You're coming up
with all sorts of different
suggestions from yourself and
your family and friends.  You're
going write an App to track all
these names.  We're going build
our own App.  This is our view
controller.  This is going to
start in X code.  So it's
written in swift.
It also MDC works just fine with
objective C.  This is just
starting with the standard
template that comes out of X
code.  X code by the way is
Apple's ID for generating code.
And this just comes straight out
of the default template.  And
loads up some example data then
just gets a view on the screen.
So, if you start with this you
get
this very, very basic dog
tracking, dog name tracking App.
So we have our dog names here.
It's wonderful.  We've collected
a whole bunch of them.  But, of
course, as you go about your day
and talking to people you are
going to find even more dog
names that you want to track and
rank in your dog name tracking
App.  Of course so this is a
great example of using a
material floating action button.
Instead of you having to go into
the code and add something to an
array somewhere you can just tap
the button
and add a name that way.
First you got to get the code
right.
So our code of course exists in
GitHub.  You can download that
immediately.  But at least on
iOS the standard way
to get codes to use a package
manager.
A cocoa pods is a package
manager on iOS.  And here is a
pod file.  If you are not
familiar with this it's not
exciting.
But you have to reference this
material component's pod then
run pod install to download
material components
and all of its dependencies on
to your local disk so you can
use them.
The next step is just to wire up
this
material button the exact same
way you would normally.  Back in
the swift code you can see at
the top we're importing material
components then next we're
creating a floating button.  So
the class name in this case is
MDC floating button.  So we're
createding that new button.
Then we're setting its icon and
its background color and putting
in the view hierarchy just as
you would a normal button.  So,
if we do all this you get this
nice list view.  And in the
bottom corner we have a nice
purple fob that you -- sorry
floating action button -- that
you can
tap and you get all the ink
ripples and different effects
you inspect for pretty much for
free.
>> LYNN JEPSEN: Let's talk
about a completely different
example for the web.
Say you have an existing HTML
form.  I'm guy to be to show you
how to replace this input
element with a new MDC text
field.  MDC web is installable
through node package manager.
You just run this one line
command.  It's easy and fast to
install our code in to your code
base.  You will need to update
your source code to use MDC web.
So let's start with a text
field.
You just need to copy our text
field HTML in to your form.
Our text field HTML is
documented on GitHub.
Here we have the documentation
for the text field component.
The structure is called out
quite early this in the
documentation so you can quickly
copy/paste.  And each of our
components for web follow this
documentation format.  The next
step is to actually import our
sass files into your sass files.
Sass is a technology which
compiles into CSS and works with
existing open source bundle
systems like web pack.
Finally you need to initial IEDZ
the Java script on the HTML
element.  This is all you need.
You get a nice lovely text field
working on your website.  Users
can interact with this text
field like they would any text
field on any website.  And check
out the animation of the line
ripple and the floating label.
This is material design approved
animation.  It provides valuable
feedback to the users who are
interacting with your website.
>> ADRIAN SECORD: So back to
our little dog name tracking App
which, you know, the first thing
you should probably do is come
up with a better name than that.
But let's pretend you are really
into this App.  You are very
excited about it and think it's
the best one out there and you
decide to push it a little
further.
You work up with maybe a friend
a branding story for your App.
So you are not just -- it's not
just a simple App.  You want to
make sure you have
expressed all the right
topography and color system and
different elements of the App so
it all comes together and works
as a branding story.  Let's
pretend in your graphic design
aspect of your brand you are
more in to sort of like sharp
corners and edges
than you are of these round
circle type things.  This is an
excellent example of something
that we can use material theming
for.  You might have heard
material theming.  I hope you
have heard about material
themeing in the other talks in
I/O.  But this is a great time
where we can take a little bit
of branding, sharp
corners, and apply it to a
really visual, very forward
element in your design which is
this fab.  We're going transform
it from the
circular we get by default into
a nice diamond shape.
So back in the code anything in
MDC OS
that you can affect its shape
takes a shape generator.  The
highlighted codes we're creating
the shape generator and we have
given you in the library a few
standard Jen BRATors that you
can use.  They do simple things
like take rectangles and cut off
corners at various angles or
maybe round off
corners at various RADi.  In
this case we're going talk a
square them the bounding box of
the original button.  And we're
going cut off its four corners
at 45 degree angles.  So we get
this nice diamond shape.  That's
all that's happening in this the
highlighting cold.
When you assign it to the fab
and if we rerun our code you get
this.
You have this nice diamond
shaped fab popping up and you
get all the normal effects you
expect like the ripple and
different animations for free
and every time your users go and
interact with your locally fab
down there they're getting a
little burst of your brand in
that button.
>> LYNN JEPSEN: All of our
components allow for
customization.  So let's talk
about the text field example on
the web platform.
Say your designer wants to
customize all the colors on the
text field.  He wants the line
to start at gray on Page load
but then when a user hovers over
the text field he wants it to
change to orange.  Your designer
also wants the line to change to
a slightly different shade of
orange when the user clicks on
the text field and starts
entering text.  And your
designer wants to make sure that
the label matches the color of
the line.  How do you build all
this?
You build it
using MDC web sass mix IBs.
They are APIs that developers
can use to customize components.
Here we have the code to
customize the text field.  At
the top we have code to
customize the gray colors for
the idle state of the text
field.  In the middle, there's
code to customize the hover
state.  And in the -- at the
bottom there's code to customize
the focus state.  Focus state is
when the user clicks on the text
field and starts entering text.
You can implement a lot of
customization using these sass
mixuns and you don't
have to worry about all the
choreography of the color
changes.
For those that have Android
applications that are already
built using material design, the
MDC Android team has made it
really easy for you to upgrade
your
existing MDC text fields to new
outlined variant of this text
field.
Here we have some code for a
form in an Android XML file.
All you have to upgrade is add
this one line of code to the
style attribute.  With that you
get a new form of text field
which looks like this.  You cap
think of this outline version of
another form of customization.
If this outline version looks
better with your App's existing
graphic design, then use it.
Because this is an Android
component we've also made sure
that it works with existing
Android theming.  So, if you've
already set your Android theme
colors to the right shades of
orange then text field will
inherit those colors.
We've shown you a lot of code
here at I/O but perhaps looking
at code from the back of an I/O
stage is not the best way to
learn.  The best way to learn is
to actually write code.
Which is why we've created 30
code labs for you to go and
enjoy that work with MDC.
We have code labs for all of our
platforms.  Android, iOS,
flutter, web.  For Android we
have code labs in Java and
Kotlin.
For iOS we have code labs in
aJEKTive C and swift.  We don't
have any code labs in react yet.
But if you want code labs in
reABLTHD or other technology you
are using, let us know.  We
really want to make sure that
we're targeting the technologies
that
developers are already using.
>> ADRIAN SECORD: So now that
we've seen some code and some
examples of getting some MDC
things in to code, we want to go
back a step and say why use MDC.
We really believe that using the
MDC libraries helps you create
beautiful products.  We believe
that they should be pretty easy
for developers to use.  And we
definitely believe they provide
an excellent user experience to
your users.  So not only do you
get this sort of like experience
of using the code and hopefully
it's smoother and easier to use
but it brings a lot of value to
your users.
Let's go into more detail .
So each one of our components is
built to be pixel perfect.  We
collaborate with the designers
infinity to add polish , to get
all the details right.
We worry about the fills and
strokes
and raidi.  And we also do a lot
of research and user testing.
Materialize an organization has
researchers on staff that go out
and take our components, put
them in front of people and test
them and see what works better
and what doesn't.  We actually
have a very good example of this
with the text field that we are
seeing before.  Might have seen
it had heavy outlines and very
prominent fills.  Our original
text field that we released in
twenty 14 when we went out and
did some user experience, some
user research, we found out that
people didn't actually in the
middle of a busy screen with a
whole bunch of different things,
people didn't know if they were
supposed to tap in and fill out
the text.  So they were missing
filling out an important part of
the form.  We went back and
re-designed based on that
experience and republished maybe
a
year ago the text field spec,
updated all the code so that it
became a better text field for
everyone to use.
The other thing that we do is
designers of course are not sort
of one size fits all.  There's
many different kinds of
designers.  So in material we
have visual design errs.  We
have interaction designers.
People who do motion design.  We
work with all of them to make
sure that every aspect of these
components is as good as
possible.
The other piece is that MDC is
production ready.  We work very
hard to make it optimized for
performance metrics.  Memory,
CPU, that kind of thing.
We test on a wide range, an
exhaust UF
range of browsers.  We also
stress test things with the open
source community.  You can
manage that maybe Google only
uses these components in a
certain way and no one else ever
uses them a certain way but
that's okay because we have open
source contributors using them
in all sorts of different ways
and we get all that and fold it
back in so that everyone gets
the benefit of that experience.
The other thing that's really
important is this is how Google
ships its Apps world wide for
quite a number of years now.
All our Android and iOS Apps are
out there using this code to
ship.  So we're used to do the
Google scale performance and
optimization that you get the
benefit of too.
>> LYNN JEPSEN: The third
reason why you should use MDC is
because it helps you COMBILD
features faster.  Using our
components can really speed up
your development time.  We've
already spent months of
developer and designer time
building
these components from scratch.
So we want everyone here today
to feel like they don't have to
build components from scratch.
They can just quickly install
and use
our components in your code
base.
In fact, we also don't want you
to be tied to material designs
visual expression.  So, if your
designer wants to make changes
like customizing the color of a
text field or the shape of a
floating action button, there
are APIs developers can use to
build that customization.  We
want you to express brand
through our APIs.  We ave APIs
for color, typing on RA FI,
shape.  We want our components
to feel like they belong within
your existing application.
The fourth reason why you should
use MDC
is because using MDC is
leveraging MDC engineering.
We're going to be releasing new
components and new features
through
twenty 18 and beyond.  MDC is
the only component library which
evolves with material design.
So our MDC engineers, they
collaborate
directly with the designers who
are writing material design
guidelines.  That's why you can
depend on us to
make sure that we release new
components that evolve with the
material design spec.
I hope you all have learned a
lot today about how to
incorporate material design in
to your existing code base.  You
have seen some new material
tools and how they work with
MDC.  You have seen some example
code actually using MDC.  And
you have heard about some of the
benefits of MDC in your existing
code
base.
That's all we have.  Thank you
so much.  We're going take
questions here in a second.  But
I just want to let you know that
we have a dome F which is the
design/accessibility dome.
We're hanging out there all day
tomorrow so you can come ask us
questions there as well.  But
thank you so much.
>> ADRIAN SECORD: Thank you.
(Applause).
>> LYNN JEPSEN: Any questions?
>> ADRIAN SECORD: Please use
the microphones.
>> LYNN JEPSEN: Anybody?
Anybody?  No.
They just all want to go do code
labs, Adrian.  Thank you.
>> Do you have any ways to make
it
easier to export setting s maybe
Android that I want to be able
to share with my iOS App that I
want to be able to share with my
web App?
>> LYNN JEPSEN: Lynn the
question is
from Android to web sharing
code?
>> Sharing all the work that I
did to customize my material
theme.
>> LYNN JEPSEN: We're working
on it.
Right now they're visually very
similar API wise.  The question
is how do you make sure all the
work you have done to customize
your theme for Android you can
reuse in other platforms like
web or iOS.
Right now those APIs are super,
super similar because our
engineers for Android and iOS
and web all sit next to each
other and collaborate.  We
haven't made it a simple run a
script and it works.  But we're
working on it.
>> ADRIAN SECORD: Also there's
different platform adaptations.
Android code is not iOS code.
And Android designs are not iOS
designs.  But we hope to make it
easier in the 80 percent case
where the designs are the same.
>> Thank you.
>> ADRIAN SECORD: . Thank you.
>> Is it possible to go too far?
Like say you shaped the fab like
a bone or something.
I don't know is it till
material?  Like the original
material was like paper and ink.
The same customized but what
makes it material design.
>> LYNN JEPSEN: The question is
it
possible to customize a little
too far.  Yes.  But we also have
a lot of guidance to help guide
you in the right direction
that will sort of help you.
>> ADRIAN SECORD: In the design
guidelines there's a great
customation section.
That's a top level session
section for theming but in over
component there's
like here is how you customize.
So you are totally right.  If
you start fiddling with all the
knobs you can generate something
that's maybe not so great.  But
we're hoping with the
combination
of the guidance and also the
tooling, so
one of the things that not maybe
wilt into the MDC libraries
themselves but we have tools
like the material color tool
that will help you choose color
pallets that look great and will
work well in your App.  That
sort of tooling we're hoping to
build more recommendation type
things or sometimes we call them
guide rails to kind of make sure
you don't get too far off the
road and we end up with
something that should be usable.
>> Support Windows. Because so
far it's been sketch.
>> In a web browser, yes.
(Laughter).
>> LYNN JEPSEN: Thank you.
>> I wanted to know if our
designers styleize an entire
material theme are there tools
within the sketch plug-in or
gallery to output that as a
style sheet
or Android styles XML file?
>> ADRIAN SECORD: Not at this
time.  That's something we're
excited about but don't have
anything we can announce.  It's
an obvious I'm with you.
>> I was holding my breath
waiting to are that.
>> LYNN JEPSEN: There is a fair
amount of guidance within
gallery in particular that tells
you what customization has been
applied to those components.
But we're going to be improving
that so that it really lines up
with our
components and we'll hopefully
get to the point where we can
magically export something.
>> Excellent. I've been looking
for to a style sheet driven
development.  Thank you.
>> I was wondering, how do the
MDC libraries Play out with
other libraries like the Android
design support library
or the Polly MER project on web.
>> ADRIAN SECORD: Are you
asking how they compare?
>> How they compare and how are
we supposed to use them.
>> LYNN JEPSEN: MDL did you say
material design --
>> ADRIAN SECORD: You meant the
Android support library.
>> LYNN JEPSEN: We upgraded the
support library.
>> ADRIAN SECORD: It is a bit
of a complicated situation and
it's evolving.  We expect the
MDC libraries will be
the home for future going
material on all the four
platforms -- now five platforms
that we're supporting.
>> Does that include the Polly
MER project for web?
>> LYNN JEPSEN: Polymer.
That's a great question.  Sorry
I couldn't quite hear.
So with polymer we're actually
working on some new web
components that similar to the
react library are going to be
using the Java script, NCSS from
MDC web but sort of
encapsulateing it in this web
component you can just drop in.
So the polymer team has been
doing announcements today.  I
didn't mention it as broadly
here in this talk but it's
happening under the same GitHub
repo.  It's called material
components web components.
Check it out and follow it
because we're doing a lot of
work there for polymer support
in particular.
>> Thank you.
>> Historically the Android
design
support library has lagged
behind the material design
specification.  And I've often
found myself in a situation
where our designers picked up
some awesome cool new thing from
the
material design spec and said do
this in Android and I've had to
say there's no way to implement
this yet which is quite
embarrassing.  With the new
material describe components
does this mean you are going to
be working them in lock step
where the guidelines will be
updated and we'll be able to
implement that in code.
>> LYNN JEPSEN: As much as we
physically can, yes.
>> ADRIAN SECORD: It's again a
complicated situation.  But MDC
Android is meant to be tracking
the guidelines, updating much
more quickly.  And we totally
hear you.  We have the same
pain.  Updateing with the
guidelines themselves.  Pretty
much I, I mean, you should look
for changes monthly.  Should be
coming out pretty quick.
>> LYNN JEPSEN: I like that
term lock step.  That's what
we're aiming for.  Lock step
with everything, yeah.
>> Hi. Maybe you can answer
this or not but my question is
about material design light and
what's happening with that.
>> LYNN JEPSEN: Material design
light.
So material design light is this
web style sheet, component
library that we built.  It's
right now not officially
supported.  So it still exists
you can still use
it but we're not adding any new
features.
It basically came down to a
limitation of sort of the
technology.  MDL is built on
this concept that you
have mostly CSS, HTML, not a lot
of Java script.  We found that
in order to accurately support
material design and build all
the cool new things that our
designers were coming up with we
had to stretch into more
sophisticated technologies like
Java script, like sass, some of
the tools you could use.
Especially with our
announcements of material
theming it was really difficult
to customize MDL without sort of
running in to fragile issues
with the HTML.  Which is why
we're really pushing this new
MDC web as much as possible.
>> Does that mean that MDL is on
the way out?  Is that what you
are saying?
>> LYNN JEPSEN: It's still very
useful if you want to get a
website running like super
quickly and you are messing
around with it.  So I recommend
it for that.
We're just not adding ini new
tee features to it.
>> I have a question about the
MDC
performance or does MDC affect
the performance on the cheap and
slow devices?  Because we are
currently applying material
designs to our App.
But our App has a huge
percentage of
users who use cheap and very
slow and very, very cheap like
ten dollar devices.
And our developers, sometimes
they
think using this subtle and
elegant MDC elements would
affect the realtime rendering
and the performance of our Apps.
So just to confirm, does it
affect the performance?
>> ADRIAN SECORD: An which
platform are you talking about.
>> Android.
>> LYNN JEPSEN: We optimize
performance as much as we can.
But that still is good feedback
I think for our open source
community.  If you are using a
component in a certain App and
you are not getting the
performance you expect like let
us know on the open source.  It
will help us test it and figure
out better ways to improve it.
>> ADRIAN SECORD: And we will
make changes based on
performance.  One of the great
things of working with design so
tightly, TEFRL is engineers and
designers all working together,
is we the engineers will go back
to design and tell them like
this
is beautiful but we can't ship
it to these phones.  If you file
bugs and help us we can make
that better for everyone.
>> LYNN JEPSEN: And it's a
really good market that we need
to make sure we are addressing.
So make sure the lower band
width and memory still get a
good design experience.  So we
love that feedback.
>> ADRIAN SECORD: . Thank you.
Great question.
>> Thank you.
>> Hi there. So one of your --
in one of your
examples you showed the fab
floating on an iOS device.  And
you said that you get for free
the ripple effect.  So, if that
is the only thing that the
user can (inaudible) and have
the ripple effect that might be
a bit week.  Is it possible to
remove it or even better to be
able to apply the ripple effect
in anything that is not part of
your library and get like a --
>> ADRIAN SECORD: So that's a
great question.  Just to be
clear really that button is
packaging.
The ripple and the shadowing
effects,
the shadows are not the default
shadow on iOS.
And to at least answer the
second question.  You can take
that, I believe it's called an
ink layer.  You can take that
ink layer and apply it to
anything you want and fire it
off on touches.  So if you are
making your own custom component
and want some ink, some ripple,
sorry, rink and ripple are
interchangeable, then you can
use that layer.  It's a normal
CA layer.  You can use that
layer and apply it to your view.
And then fire off the ripple
based on interactions.
>> Thank you very much.
>> ADRIAN SECORD: Any
questions?
>> LYNN JEPSEN: I think that's
it.  Thank you.
>> ADRIAN SECORD: Thank you so
much.
(Applause).
.
Romain
SRGB
.
Realtime captioning on this
screen.
SK
DK
IOS
>> LUCY ABRAMYAN: Romainen
welcome everyone
>> LUCY ABRAMYAN: Welcome.
>> I'm Romainen from the
framework team and I can reveal
some of the stuff I've been
working on.
>> LUCY ABRAMYAN: I'm Lucy and
I am an engineer.
I am going to start off BU
telling you something very
personal to me and that I'm very
passionate about.
But it's not just one thing.
It's actually a combination of
things that I love.
Every since I was a child I've
been
marveled by space.  Isn't it
amazing just think about it
for a second .  The diversity of
the planets.  Everything that's
going on around the solar system
right now?
Wouldn't it be amazing if we
could just see it up close.
There's just one problem.
Humans can't go to another
planet.
Not even mars just yet.
Or can we?  This starts the
second part of my passion.
Augmented reality is delightful.
It helps you interact with a
world
that is within a whole new
experience
that is catered to your
environment.
ARCore is Google's platform for
augmented reality applications.
But even if we use ARCore to
help us understand the
environment, what do we
do about 3D rendering?
Okay so while it's not exactly
rocket
science, today 3D rendering has
a steep learning curve.
But if you are like me, you are
still
really passionate about space
and AR and
3D and rendering and graphics
and matrix math so you just
start coding.
And coding and coding and coding
and then you quickly realize
there's a lot of code.
>> How many of you have written
(inaudible).  First of all I'm
so sorry.  Second of all you
probably know how difficult it
is.  I've been doing this kind
of stuff for basically ten years
at Google.  And it's a pain.
>> LUCY ABRAMYAN: Here's my
point right here.  It's
difficult.
And we've noticed that there's
so much in common throughout all
AR Apps.  Things like streaming
the camera image to the
background or even just making
an object appear on the screen.
So be wanted to take care of
that so you don't have to go
through the pain.
>> I go through the pain.
>> LUCY ABRAMYAN: That's why we
built
the Sceneform SDK to make it
quick, simple and familiar to
any Android developer.
Sceneform is a 3D framework that
makes it easy for you to build
AR graphs.  It includes an
Android studio plug-in that
allows you to import, view and
even
edit 3D models.  The API offers
a high level way of working with
3D and it's tightly integrated
with ARCore.  So it makes it
especially easy to build AR
Apps.  Because it integrates
with the Android
view framework you can easily
add AR into an existing App for
create one from
scratch
.
The "New York Times" use
Sceneform in their new AR
articles.  You can download the
"New York Times" App today and
search for augmented reality and
not only read about David bowie
but also walk around a manikin
wearing his costumes.
Otto, the online furnishing
retailer used Sceneforms to
allow customers to see what a
piece of furniture looks like in
their living room before they
buy it.  If you are from a
European country you will be
able to download the App and try
it out.
>> And actually a couple of the
engineers from otto are in the
audience somewhere.  I just want
to thank them because they were
very patient with us when we
were working on fun.  They went
through all the early versions
of the API and it wasn't always
working right.  So thank you.
>> LUCY ABRAMYAN: Thanks for
helping us build it.  Yes.
I'm going Play this video again
because I love it.  Remember
that solar system I was talking
about that I wanted to bring to
you?  Here it is right inside
your living room.  And trust me
without the thousands of lines
of rendering code.  You can see
this code online right now
by going to our GitHub repo.
There are links at the end of
the presentation.
So let's walk through how we
built this App.
First we'll start off with
common concepts of AR Apps and
then show you code snippets
using Sceneform.
After we've covered the basics,
Romain will go into detail about
physically based materials and
give you all sorts of rendering
knowledge to help you
optimize and make beautiful 3D
objects
in your App .
The Sceneform API consists of
two concepts.
The scene and the view
.  The scene represents the
objects you are adding to the
world.
Like through 3D models that you
want to place in your AR App.
The view is where your scene
will be
drawn.  In this case it's your
device screen
and where the device is in the
world.  Render will draw the
scene from this perspective.
The view ties in to the Android
view framework or system and
that's your hook into the App.
As a developer, you will build
your
scene by defining the spatial
relationships of objects.
To do this Sceneform provide as
high level scene graph API for
defining the hierarchy of
objects and their spatial
relationships.  One analogy that
I like to think about is the
Android view hierarchy.
But instead of obviously in 3D.
Instead of view we use graph
nodes.  Each node contains all
the information
that Sceneform needs to render
it and to interact with it.  And
finally nodes can be added to
other nodes forming a
parent-child relationship.
In our solar system example,
planets
orbit around the sun, and moons
of these planets orbit around
the planets.
A natural way to define the
solar
system in a scene graph is to
make the
sun the root node and add
planets as the sun's children
and add the moons as their
children.
That way if you want to animate
the
MAERTSDZ earth orbiting the sun
the moon will just follow the
earth.  You don't have to do the
complicated math to figure out
the moon's relationship to the
sun while the earth
is orbiting it .
In this video, it is the same
solar system example that we saw
a little bit ago.
But we've also added touch
interaction.  Nodes can become
interactive by adding touch
listeners to them, obviously.
And we propagate touch events
through the scene graph the same
way Android touch events are
propagated through the view
hierarchy.
Nodes can contain #3SHGS 3D
models or 2D Android views.  You
can create an Android view just
as you would in your layout
editor and put it in the world
and interact with it like you
would any other App.  It is a
first class citizen of our scene
.
So how does an Android developer
usually
get started with Android studio.
I won't go too deep into this
because there is another talk
tomorrow morning
called "build, iterate and
launch" that will show you all
the steps.  But I want you to
know we have built a plug-in for
Android studio that allows you
to drop in 3D models built with
standard modeling tools like
Maya or you can download them
through Polly.  You go through
the import flow and
that converts the models in an
SFA and SFB format.  These are
particular to Sceneform.
The SSA is what's bundled into
your App.
So drop the SFA file into the
source
assets folder and you can ship
it with your App.
One thing we wanted to note,
yes, you can view and edit your
models right there in Android
studio.
>> And what's important to note
that is
we use the same renderer on the
device as inside Android
studios.  So what you see in
studio will be what you see on
the device.
One other thing to note.  There
are going to be more details
tomorrow.
The importer acts as a Gradle
plug-in.  For every asset that
you import inside your project
you are going to get a new
Gradle task.  Which means if
your designers give you a new
version of the asset all you
have to do is replace the file
in your project and the next
time you build it
will con convert the (?) And you
will be up to date.  You don't
have to worry about going
through a manual wizard every
time you get a new version of
the asset.
>> LUCY ABRAMYAN: Start coding.
Let's start off with our on
create method and mirror
activity just as you would.
Find the AR fragment, find
Sceneform's AR fragment.  This
takes care of setting up the
ARCore session for you and
manages the life cycle of
Sceneform.  And naturally it
will contain the AR view.  And
the view holds a reference to
the scene.  I want to note here
that you don't have to use our
fragment you can use the view
and, therefore, the scene
directly.
>> This is one of the powerful
things about Sceneform.  Because
it's just using the regular
Android view that happens to be
a surface view you can drop it
wherever you want in our
application.  It doesn't have to
be full screen.  And we don't
take over your application.  If
you try to do something (?)
Becomes your application.  It is
a very easy way to embed AR
inside an Android application
that already exists.  New York
times is a great example how far
you can push this.
Because they show AR view a web
view.  So they just put an AR
view behind the transparent web
view.  As you scroll the web
view the load contains into the
AR view.  It doesn't have to be
just a simple full screen
example like you are seeing
here.
>> LUCY ABRAMYAN: So let's
start loading all of our models.
In this case I have a to-do for
you to load the rest of them.
But I'll show you how to build a
3D
model.  In Sceneform we have two
types of renderables.
Renderables are the things that
are going to be rendered on the
screen.  I know we're very
creative with naming.  In this
case we want to load the sun
model which was dropped in to
our REZ ROU folder so you set
the source and build.
I also want to point out these
are completeable futures.  So it
will do the loading in the
background and you can accept
and handle as you would with a
completeable feature.
I should also mention Kotlin
here.  We can do all of this in
Kotlin but
all of the code snippets will be
in Java.
>> One thing we haven't done yet
is
built Kotlin extensions for
Sceneform.  But if you are
inclined to do so I would love
to see your code.
>> LUCY ABRAMYAN: So remember
earlier we showed you this graph
representing the sun and the
planets.
Keep the structure in mind
because we're going to be
loading and creating the scene
graph.
We've loaded all the models so
now let's build the solar
system.
We start off with the sun node.
Create a new node and set its
renderable to be the sun model
that you had loaded.  Next we
create the earth node.  We set
its parent to the sun.
Therefore building the scene
graph.  Starting to build the
scene graph.
Notice here that I have set the
sun to earth meter as constant.
In this case I've used 0.5
meters because I wanted to fit
the
solar system inside the living
room.  But we've set the earth's
local position relative to its
parent, the sun.  Set the
renderable that we loaded and
continue.
Now the moon.  Create the node.
Set the parent to earth.  And
notice here now that the local
position of the moon is earth to
moon in meters.  I think I've
set it to be 0.1.
It has nothing to do with the
sun.
Set the renderable as a moon
enderable and you are set.  Now
to animate their orbit you can
just use Android's property
animation system.  We've created
some evaluators for you to use.
Once we return the root node we
now have
the entire graph for our solar
system.  So let's bring the
solar system in to the scene.
All we have to do is parent it
to the scene.  And that is it.
Or parent the sun to the scene.
And the solar system is now in
your room.
Or we could do something else.
Anchors.  I don't know if you
know about ARCore anchors but
they are how you attach your
content to the world.
ARCore makes sure they are
anchored to the world.
You can get averageors from
ARCore's hid test based on the
user's touch event or with our
new cloud anchors you can use an
anchor that another friend has
created on another device.  Or
using anchors we've created an
extension to node called the
anchor node that just takes an
anchor and now brings
that anchor into your scene
graph.  Set the anchor node's
parent.  Easily.  Just to the
scene.  And then set the sun's
parent to the anchor node.
Notice how we've rearranged it a
little bit.  First we had the
scene with the sun as the root
node.  Now we've created the
scene, the anchor node, and then
the sun and the rest of the
solar system.
I was mentioning model
renderables before.
Now we'll talk about the 2D view
renderables.  To add 2D in to
your App, in this case I've used
a little info card that pops
up about a quarter of a meter
above a planet, say.  And you
want it to display some
information on it.
So I've created the node that
would hold the view renderable.
I've set it to a planet.  And it
will now float quarter of a
meter above the planet.
Wherever that planet is.  Start
off by building a view
renderable.
Notice instead of the REZ RAW
source I've set it to the view
ID.  And that's all there is to
it.  Now you have the 2D view
just as you
would have in any other
application and you can do
things with that view like set
the text.
Finally, if you want to drag,
scale and rotate objects, we've
made that really easy for you by
creating a transformable node.
The transformable node is an
extension
to node but it also understands
touch events and gestures like
dragging and scaling and
rotating ONTs.  So in this case
if instead of creating
a sun node I created a
transformable sun node, I would
just do everything else
that I did before but now we can
actually drag and move the solar
system.
I should mention that there is
-- there
was a talk earlier today about
UX interactions in AR.  So, if
you want to know more about the
best practices for UX, please go
back
and look at that talk.
I'll hand it over to Romain.
>> Let's talk about materials.
This is a simple part of
Sceneform.  But before you can
understand how to create your
own material we have to
understand the concept behind
physically based rendering.
So after import an asset through
the Android plug-in like Lucy
said you end up with two files.
A dot SFA and SF becomes.  The B
is the one that goes into your
application and that will run at
run time.
The dot SFA is a Json
description of the asset.  It
looks a little bit something
like this.
So this is the SFA from the moon
of the earth from our example.
You can see this attribute
called base color, normal and
metallic roughness.  Those point
to textures that are defined
somewhere else in the file.  I'm
not going to go into details
about
the syntax and the structure of
the file mostly because there is
excellent documentation on line
and there is the talk tomorrow
morning so you should check that
out.  What I want to talk about
is what do we -- what kind of
textures do you need to create
to be meaningful for the
color, the normal and the
metallic and RUCHness textures.
Before we do this we have to
talk about physically based
rendering.
It start becoming quite popular
over the past three or four
years.  It's now used in a lot
of games.  It's still fairly
uncommon on mobile.
The basic idea behind it is that
we're
relying on physical principles
to define all the behaviors and
all the equations that we use in
the rendering system.  So that
includes things like separating
the lighting code from the code
that defines the surface and it
doesn't impact the metals
itself.  It means we have to
take into account laws of
physics like the energy
conservation.  EE use physical
(?).  For instance when we
declare the sun
as a dynamic light in a scene we
use the unicode lux.
If you were to add a light in
your AR
scene it's just a light bulb you
can use watts or lumens as the
unit.
So it's a number of things that
are grounding in reality that
both help us validate our
rendering but also makes our
life easier because those are
things
we deal with every day and that
feel natural to us.  I'll show
you an example.
This is an example it's not in
AR but it has been rendered
using our rendering engine.  A
simple sphere.  You can see
reflections on the sphere.  What
you are seeing here in action is
a physical effect called the
planet
effect after 19th century
physicist.  And the closer you
are to the edge of the field the
more you can see the
reflections.  And this is a
natural phenomenon that you can
see everywhere.  This is a photo
I took in Lake Tahoe.  You can
see that close to the edge where
I was standing you can see
through the water.  And the
further away you get the more
you can see the reflections of
the water.  Again you can see
this on every object.  Every
object around you follows this
principle.  Might not be like
this at first but this is what
happens.  And we recreate this
physical behaviors in our
REBDZering engine to make things
look as realistic as possible.
So we follow a work floe format
called the metallic roughness
work flow.  If you look that up
you will see there's a lot of
information out there.
The metallic/roughness work flow
is available in a lot of tools.
Engine four uses it.
Blender has access as well.  The
way it works is when you want to
define a new material you are
actually trying to describe and
define a surface.  To define the
surface you are going to need
three things.  We're going take
them in this order for specific
reasons and we'll explain them a
bit.
The first one is you need to
define the metallic property of
the surface.  Often we talk
about metallicness but it's not
even a word.
So metallic at high level is
whether or not the object is a
metal.  We're going on see why
this is very important to us.
Then you are going to define the
color of the object.  We call it
the base color as opposed to the
disfuse color.  Those are terms
you might have seen in older
engines.
You need to define the
roughness.  Roughly it means how
shiny the object is.  And if you
want to go further there are two
other things you can define to
give your surface more details
and more natural appearance.
The first one is the normal or
the normal map.
It just helps break the evenness
of the surface.  The second one
is called the ambient OE
collusion or OE collusion.  So
first what is a non-metal?  I'll
spare you the equation.
This is actually fairly simple.
We have an orange object.  It's
drawn in gray to make the
diagram easier to read.  We have
light coming from a light source
and hitting the surface of the
object.  The light that hits the
object gets split in to to
continents.  The first one in
white is the reflected part.  So
those are all the reflections.
So in that orange ball that we
saw
before the edges you could see
those reflections that's this
part of the light.
Then the other part of the light
is refracted into the object.
And most objects around us they
absorb some of the light.  The
light enters the object, it gets
scattered, bounces around inside
the ONT and some of the light
will come out but not all of it.
This is what gives object
colors.  In that particular case
because the object appears
orange it just means that green
and blue components of the light
have been an southerned inside
the object.  That orange light
that comes out is
called the (?) Light.
The white is called the speck U
LAR.
This is an example of
non-metallic orange ball.
If you look at the reflections
here this is an environment
inside the classroom where we
have overhead white lights.
Even though the object itself is
orange, the lights appear white.
That's because they just bounce
off and don't enter the object.
They don't take the color of the
object in to account.
Then the rest of the object, are
the non-reflective parts are
orange as expected.
If you have a metallic object,
metals are conductors, and
they're called conductors
because when the energy hits
them in this case lights the
lights, the part of the energy
that's refracted into the
surface gets absorbed.  Just
gets transmitted into the object
and does not get scattered
outside.
There's no disfuse light you
only get reflections.  However
what happens with the reflexs is
they take the color of the
object.  So you don't get white
reflections anymore.  You get
orange reflections instead.
If we take the symbol we just
saw and
turn it in to met look again at
the overhead lights of that
classroom you can see they now
appear orange.  This is because
the rest of the light, the rest
of the speck U LAR light was
absorbed inside this object.
You can see another side effect
of this (?) That we just talked
about.  If you look at the edges
of the sphere you can see the
reflections are not orange
anymore.  They take on the color
of the environment.  Again a
very natural affect.  It feels
weird when you see it for the
first time in the rendering
engine, but rendering engineers
like me were obsessed about
their work.  It comes Christmas
time they look at the Christmas
tree and take a picture of one
of the ornaments.  I was holding
one of my phones on the side and
lighting the green metal ball
with an orange light from the
wallpaper on my phone and you
can see on the edge suddenly the
reflections are not green
anymore they take on the orange
light coming from the light
source.
What we just saw here can appear
weird when you see out the
computer for the first time but
this is perfectly natural and it
happens everywhere around you.
So the metallic property I
mentioned this is though first
thing you should decide.  And
you have seen why.  Because when
you define the color of the
object, when you define the base
color, depending on whether or
not the object is metallic or
not it's going dramatically
change the aspect of the
surface.  So you should always
decide first whether you are
dealing with metal or non-metal.
When it comes time to create the
actual texture the metallicness
of the object
can be defined as gray scale
texture.
That is between 0 and 265.
At 0 the object is not a metal
and at 255 when it's white the
object is a metal.  Most of the
time should be either one.
All the values in between are
mostly
used for anti-Al aliesing
purposes.
Certain alloys in real life
happens to be a mixture and you
can use intermittent values as
well but most of the time you
won't have to worry about it.
Very quickly, when a metal gets
rusty the texture becomes
non-metallic.
So if you are trying to create
soft edge that's rusty the rust
stains will be non-metal.  And
very often that's something you
will see tomorrow, you don't
have to use textures for
everything.  You can use
constants and very often get
away with not having a texture.
You can say either it's metal or
not.
Next step you have to define the
base colors.  So the color of
the object.
It defines either the diffuse
color of the object for
non-metals or the speck U LAR
color or the color of the
reflections for metallic OBTD
WHABTs.  What's quite difficult
to do is it must be completely
devoid of any lighting
information or shadowing.  We're
going to look at the example.
It can be hard because as human
beings we never see the actual
color of an object.  We only see
objects through lighting.  So
it's difficult to imagine what
it looks like.  But you can
quickly get used to it.
Whenever you use a tool like
photoshop to build your textures
make sure you are
working in the sRGB color base.
So this is a quick guide how to
build colors for objects.
Based on real world data, most
of non-metallic ONLTs use most
of the range of the brightness.
So whenever you pick a color in
the
color picker for non-metallic
object the value should be
between 10-240.  And there's
nothing as dark as zero.
There's nothing as bright as 255
when we deal with non-metals.
And metals, on the other hand,
are always fairly bright.  So
they are -- dark metals
basically don't exist.  So you
should stay in the range shown
up here.
I was mentioning you should not
have any lighting information
inside the base color of the
object.  You can see here a set
of swatches taken from real
world observation.  You can see
that gold for instance that's in
real life appears quite yellow
and saturated.  The base color
is not saturated.  All the
colors in the base color map
tend to be very pale compared to
what you actually perceive.
Here is another example on the
right
you can see a material
representing bricks.  On the
left you can see the base color
texture.  You can see the
difference once we light the
object all the contrast and
saturation appears.  But all
that information is not in the
original texture that we're
using to create this material.
So, again, you should work with
your artist.  Make sure they're
familiar with the metallic
roughness work flow.  Make sure
they at least understand the
base color map should not
contain any lighting or
shadowing.
Now I mentioned the (?)
Roughness.
Sim I way to define a surface is
like this.
It's infinitely smooth.  There's
no object in the world that's
that smooth.  What happens when
you have a smoother
object Rays of light that are
coming to each other bounce off
(?
) Each other as well so you get
sharp.
Rough surfaces have micro-facets
at the surface.
Think of those as tiny mirrors
that might not be in the same
direction.
When light comes in the Rays of
light can bounce off in RABDZ OM
directions and that creates
blurry reflections.
Those are examples.
At the top you can see a ball, a
yellow metal.
And we increase the roughness
zero to one.  At the bottom we
have a non-metallic ball and
increase it from zero to one.
We start with very sharp
reflection.  As we get closer
and closer to one the
reflections becomes so blurry
that we
can even perceive they are
reflections.
So this is a very powerful
feature because it lets you,
again, create things like
polished metals or, you
know, plastic that has been used
for quite while and become
basically rough.
So roughness is similar to the
metallic property.
It is a gray scale texture used
values between 0-255.  At zero
the surface is going to be
glossy or shiny.
At 255 extremely rough and you
won't be able to see reflections
anymore.  Be aware there might
be differences between different
tools.
So, if you specify roughness of
100 in blender that same
roughness might look different
in a different engine because
there are different ways of
doing computations.  You
shouldn't worry too much about
this just tweak the asset until
it looks right.  Sometimes the
roughness will be called
glossiness.  Glossiness is just
the opposite value so you can
just invert the texture in
photoshop for instance to get
the roughness map.
Next we want to add details.  So
save on memory and performance
we try to use smooth surfaces.
When you build your mesh made of
triangles.  Here we have example
of bricks that are completely
smooth.  So add details we can
use a normal map.  When you
apply to the object you get
to a little bit of shadowing and
more details on the surface.
I'm not going to go into too
much details because there's a
ton of information available
online so we're going to skip
that before we run out of time.
The only thing to know is that
the
colors inside of normal map
include a vector.
It's a direction not a color .
Next one is ambient inclusion.
Here we have bricks textured
properly.  They have a
roughness.  They have metallic.
They have normal map.
But we're like what we like
macro scale shadowing formation.
Because a brick has a depth.  So
it will create shadows on
itself.
The surface should be casting
shadows on itself.
Because we don't have access to
the triangles we create a black
and white texture that shows us
where the shadows should be.
Again that's called ambient
inclusion.  Let's see the before
and after.  That's after.
Before.  After.  So adds a lot
of detail and depth to your
object.
Ambient acollusion map is a gray
scale texture.  The value is 0
in the dark.  255 there's no
shadowing.  It doesn't affect
all the lighting.  I'm not going
to go into too much detail.  Any
time you create an object that
has
cracks or crevices you should be
using
an ambient OE collusion map.
We have the metallic, base
color, roughness and normal and
ambient OE collusion.  You can
create an object where
everything varies from pixel to
pixel.
Here we have a metal ball but
for some reason of the tiles are
missing and the reflections are
gone.
The three textures you can
create impressive variations
from pixel to pixel and create
most of the world
materials in a photo realistic
manner.
One thing you can do to
materials
especially use the GLTF that I'm
sure going to talk about
tomorrow.  You can pack the
channels into a single texture.
Ambient OE collusion, roughness
and metalic roughness can each
fit in one of the channels.
You can do this easily in any
good
photo editor.  And you can have
only one texture instead of
three and it's going to speed up
the load time and the rendering
as well.
Now I want to talk about
performance studio.
One of the features we have is
called dynamic resolution.
We always watch the time spent
on the GPU to render every PRAM.
Instead of dropping frames when
there's too much 20 render we
scientist we smooth the
resolution both on the
vertical and Hoar distantal
axis.  What this means for you
if you are building an AR scene
if you make it too complicated
and have too many ONTs and
materials too complex we're not
going to drop frames.  We're
always going to favor
performance.  But we're going to
lower the resolution of your
scene.  It works really well on
our phones because we have
really high density displays.
So it's really hard to tell when
this is going on.  I'm sure most
of you won't even notices you
are using the App.  Basically it
boils down to do you want to see
a complex scene at lower
resolution?  Or want to see a
simple scene at a higher
resolution?  The maximum
resolution we currently use is
10.
Even on devices like the pixel
2XL we're not going to use the
full resolution because there's
way too many pixels to be able
to drag physically based
rendering.
>> LUCY ABRAMYAN: I want to
call out that the renderer does
this automatically.
>> Yes you don't have to worry
about it.
When you create your objects it
can be really tempting
especially for the
artists to create -- to add a
lot of triangles to create
really smooth surfaces.  But
we're running all of this on
mobile phone so you should be
careful with the complexity of
the objects.  To give you a
rough idea what we call a hero
object.  An object you can get
really close to should have at
most 10 thousand triangles.
Even that, if you can avoid
using that many triangles it
would be great.  If you use 10
thousand in one object make sure
there's only one of them and not
one hundred of them otherwise
performance is going to suffer.
This is with our partners this
is one of the current issues
that we've seen.  Really tell
your artists to simplify the
models a much as possible.
Every time we have a triangle
that's
smaller than the pixel, the GPU
is going to do way too much
work.  I am not going to go into
details here because you
probably don't care but
basically we might end up doing
the work four times and we don't
want to do that.
The complexity of the scene.
Thankfully in AR you are
probably not going to add a lot
of objects.  But if you ever
create a scene for instance
where you have a model of a city
you might be tempted to put a
lot of objects in that city.
Every building or every car or
every pedestrian.  What we
recommend is at most you
should have maybe one hundred
objects visible at a time on the
screen.  The reason is because
we're going to run -- the CPU is
going to become a bottle neck.
It's not something that dynamic
resolution can help with.  We
avoid rendering anything that's
not on the screen.  We have a
lot of (?).
But if we have too many objects
on the
screen will be bound by CPU and
you will start dropping frames.
I mentioned the format called
GLTF .
It is a standard driven by crone
OES.  It is the committee behind
open (?) And Vulkan.
A lot of support GLTF websites.
One of the reasons why I like
GLTF is because in the standard,
the pack, the OE collusion, the
metallic and roughness inside a
single testing tour which is
something you should be doing
for performance reasons.
If you can ask your artist to
give you
GLTF models it is going to make
better for your models to
REPDZer.
One thing we didn't show you
what to do is you can art in
your scene and add many, many,
many lights.  This is an example
of a demo of our
rendering engine running on my
pixel.
I think we had 128 lights.
You can have many of them and
run at 60 frames per second.
If you add many lights make sure
#245I don't overlap.  Because if
you have two lights on the same
pixel we have to do the work
twice.  So, if you have 1
hundred lights on
one pixel we're basically
rendering 100 frames.  Use a lot
of lights, make sure they don't
overlap.  You can give us a
maximum sphere of influence for
each light.
Finally, if you use the view (?
).  You can put them in the
scene.  Super useful.
But every view is REBDZered in
software and for every view we
have to allocate what's called a
surface texture.  This is going
to cost memory.  It's going to
cost CPU time.  And it's going
to cost GPU time.  So try to
reuse the views as much as
possible.  Don't try to put too
many on the screen and don't try
to allocate too many at the same
time.
Finally all the usual advice
that we give you for performance
inside Android application
applies to AR obviously.  So
don't allocate in the render
loop.  Don't do too much work.
Be mindful of the size of your
IPK.
With that we're out of time.
There's a talk tomorrow morning
bill, iterate and launch AR
Apps.
There was another one designing
AR applications today.  We have
office hours.  There's a code
lab available online.  And
that's it.  If you have
questions you can find us after
this talk or tomorrow we'll be
around to answer all of your
questions.
(Applause).
Connection test.
Lawyer
Kaz Sato.
Realtime captioning on this
screen.
Aye
I
Grooveen naught
nauts
Me gelen.  Magellan.
Ma gelan
screen.
>> Hi everybody welcome to this
session.  The last one of the
day.  Everybody having a good
I/O so far?
(Cheering).  Nice.  Excited for
the concert tonight?  Yeah.  So
thanks for spending some time
with us beforehand.  I'm
>> LAURENCE MORONEY:
>> KAZ SATO: I'm Kaz.
>> LAURENCE MORONEY: We're here
to talk
about machine learning plus loT
equals a smarter world.  That's
a riff on a famous Computer
Science book.  Anybody know what
that ising a go
rhythms plus data structures
equals programs.  We wanted to
do a little bit of a riff on
that.  It's also really about
what's going on in the world
today that there's two major
friends going on.
One is the rapid rise of loT.
Number two is the rapid rise of
AI and machine learning.
They're intersecting with each
other to create some really cool
new scenarios.  So we warranted
to talk through a few of these
scenarios.  The first one we'll
give is let's take
a look at really cheap loT
sensors that will do something
like in this case we're going to
take a look at those that
measure air quality and how they
can push data to the clouds and
how we can use that for machine
learning.
>> KAZ SATO: Nd how the cloud
can be empowering for loT and AI
with products that help you
collecting data and
analyzing it and learninging.
>> LAURENCE MORONEY: The third
will be
as many of our devices are like
Raspberry Pis and handheld
devices what
can we do with device inference.
So we'll look at cool stuff
happening there.
First some numbers.  According
to IHS research there are
expected to be 31 billion
connected loT devices by the end
of this year.  That's a lot of
devices.
And those devices combined we
found the same research is
showing 27.
6 percent compound annual growth
rate of the data that they are
pushing to the cloud.  So 31
billion by the end of this year.
And every year the amount of
data they're pushing is growing
by 27.6 percent.  That's a lot
of data.  What are we going to
do with that data?  There's the
usual things.  Filtering,
sorting, querying, all that
stuff.  We can also use that to
start training models.  All of
that data and all those models
can then be used to generate
intelligence and to help us to
start making intelligent
decisions based on the data
that's being generated by our
devices.
The first scenario was thinking
about simple sensors that give
us smart solutions.
I just wanted something with
four S's on it.  Easier to
remember that way.  An example
of this is like these little
devices and if you have ever
done any kind of hardware
hacking and this is like a
device the one on the left is
called an EPP866.
It has input output bin minutes
and a WiFi circuit on it.  When
you combine it with the one on
the right that's an air quality
and gas sensor, now you can
start putting together something
quickly and cheaply that will
push data to the cloud.
An interesting story.  Kaz and I
had prepared this talk and
we rehearsing it last week with
the Vice President of our
division.
One of the feedback was you
don't have any small simple
sensors on there.  You are doing
lots of cloud stuff and mobile
stuff but you don't have any loT
sensors so you should build one
and put it in there.  This was
like last Wednesday.  The
environment that we live in now
is
so cool that we're able thanks
to ARD winnow and the maker
community to be able to build a
demo in a couple days.  And the
longest part of this -- can
anybody guess what the longest
time in
building the demo was?  It
wasn't testing it was waiting
for the parts to be shipped from
Amazon.  (Laughter).
I'm an Amazon prescriber and it
took two days and only took
three days to builds the whole
thing.  It is an amazing time to
be alive I think.  The amount of
things that you can do, the
amount of creativity and the
kind of things that you can
build -- I find it so cool.  I'm
really happy to be alive right
now.
Let's look at like an example of
how you would use one of these.
Consider a building like this
one.  And say in a building like
this we could put sensors like
this for air quality around the
building.  And when they're
round the building then we can
start tracking the air quality
in that building.  But, you
know, that's just an instant
status.  We can tell the stuff
here on the south side of the
building, the air quality isn't
great.  And then on the north
side of the building the air
quality is very nice.  What
would usually happen if you work
in an office like this?  PREEP
OL the south side are going to
adjust the THER mow stat the
fans will kick in and people on
the north side will be too cold.
Wouldn't it be great if we could
intelligently adapt the
building.  Or what if there was
a disaster and with our sensors
are going to show the carbon
monoxide leak.  The leak is
primarily centered around the
exit.  If people are being
driven towards the exit they
might be driven towards danger.
When we've got cheap sensors we
can say we can have an
alternative exit.
What if we go even further and
think about scenarios where
machine learning becomes
involved and we can start
predicting things.  Maybe we can
predict the best times of the
day to keep the fans on to
maximize air quality and reduce
our energy footprints.  Good for
the environment.  Or maybe if
there's a gas leak or something
like that we could predict the
path of the gas leak based on
testing and based on machine
learned models.  So emergency
responders would know where it's
safe to go and where it's
dangerous to go.  We all love
our emergency responders and
want to make sure they're safe.
Or maybe we could look at what
the impact by modeling what
would be like rearranging our
office.  What if we have more
people sitting in the north and
less in the south or what
happens if we host a big event
and this building is actually
one of the offices in Google
Seattle.  Up on the top
left-hand side there that room
called center of the universe is
where we host a lot of events.
And it would be good for us to
understand the air quality when
we do so.
So if you've got a lot of
devices like this there's a
product called cloud loT core.
The idea is it's fully managed
and allows you to easily secure,
connect, manage and ingest data
from all of your devices.  Then
once you have that then you can
start doing interesting things
like
pulling the data out using
query, using cloud ML, and cloud
data lab and studio to build
models then run inference on
these models and have analytics
behind that.
Let me give a dem owe of
environmental monitoring and
what would it look like.
This is a device I was talking
about.  This is a simple ARD
winnow device.  I'm not using
the WiFi in this case I'm just
using a wired one.
So I have a shield on top of the
ARD weano with a wired internet.
Then this little device is the
air quality sensor.  And so it's
like right now it's measuring
the air quality in the room.
It's measuring for particulates.
It's measuring for gases, carbon
dioxide, all that kind of thing.
So we kind of want to trigger it
by polluting the air a little
bit.  Any ideas how we can do
that?  I'll just breathe on it
because we all breathe out
carbon dioxide right.  So I'm
going to breathe on it.  I've
always wanted to do that in a
session.  If we switch to my
laptop.  On so my laptop we can
now see I have
a fire base running here and I'm
using fire base cloud fire
store.  On cloud fire store I'm
detecting and getting the
readings from this little
device.  So we can see the
readings up here once they come
up.  Look here at the reading.
Like 57.  That was a moment ago
when I breathed on it.  54.
I've gotten it up to seventy.  I
must have eaten something bad.
The usual background is 42.
What's going on here?  How is
this being done?
With ARD weano it's super simple
to write code in C.  Can we
switch back to the slides?  It
will be easier to see the code.
So if I go back to the slides
this is the kind of code you
would have written in C on an
ARD weano.
All I'm doing is reading pin
zero.  This is plugged in to
data pin zero.  I'm reading that
and every two seconds I'm
reading it again.  And then what
I am doing with that is
I'm posting that so URL and then
that URL is writing it to fire
base for me.  It's really that
simple to build a sensor to
start monitoring air quality.
Very, very cheap.  Very, very
simple.  Then when you aggregate
the data from all the sensors
together, if you've got
thousands in the cloud, you can
start building some really
intelligent solutions.  But
there's something to take into
account when doing loT.  That's
think in terms of security.
So data security is very, very
important.  Obviously these
things are just generating data
and pushing it up to my
database.  But a smart hacker
might be able to figure out how
I am doing that.  So you got to
think in terms of data security.
A pattern that I like to follow
for this and for good reason too
is instead of pushing from the
devices directly up to our
databases have something within
your fire wall that they are
pushing to and let that act as a
proxy and then that proxy will
proxy out to your databases for
if you them then you will have a
secure connection between that
proxy and the databases then
hopefully that secure connection
will be enough.  The reason for
that is also to do it
as an internal thing was that
the power limitations on these
things mean that a lot of these
will only support HTTP.
They won't support HTPS.
That's why in my code you would
have
seen I was just making a client.
server comment 80 in this case.
Because it's just an open HTTP
connection.  That was to my
internal proxy.
Things to consider, you know,
very cheap and easy to build
systems like this one.
Coding with something like ARD
weano and C is super simple.
There's tons of APIs and tons of
examples.  You can just adapt
and that's what I did.
I had never touched an ARD weano
and I'm not particularly smart
and it took just a couple hours
to figure out how to hack the
code they had provided to be
able to build this.
That's on a small simple sensor.
Now let's look at WHANs when you
go cloud scale.
>> KAZ SATO: That was very
simple scenario.  Let's take a
look at another scenario when he
we're have a little bit smarter
devices such as (?) What kind of
object do you have in the image.
Sensor flow provides an API to
do that.
That is object detection API.
By using object detection API
you can have delay builds of
each object in the image.  Or
you can have the boxes and the
squirrels.  And it's really
simple to use the API.
Example you can just download
the
file then you can pass your
images to the dictionary.  And
that's it.  So you get the
output dictionary that would
have the detection results such
as the number of the object you
have or classes objects or the
boxes and the scores.  It's so
sim.
For example you could have a
camera attached to a shopping
CART so that you can take a
picture of the inside of the
shopping CART and apply the
object
detection API to detect what
kind of items you are having or
how many of them you have in the
CART.
And we can use the cloud loT
core combined with cloud and
mission learning engine to build
a system that provides the
production level, scalability
and availability.
For example, you want to build a
system
for the shopping CART you can
have (?
) Use it the loT core to collect
all the data and store the data.
And we can use the Kubernetes
engine
as an orchestrater or
orchestrating everything
happening at the cloud site.
Finally the GKE will be sending
the
data to where we are arriving
the prediction with the API.
Let's look at the demonstration
.  I'd like to use the webcam to
show how we.  So this is how it
looks.  It's a very small CART.
Miniature CART.
We have Raspberry Pi and the
camera.
If you put something like this
is a fake eggplant.
I bought it in Japanese store
.  Or a tomato.  Then how it
would look like.
Please switch to your -- let's
wait awhile.
>> LAURENCE MORONEY: Do I need
to refresh?
>> KAZ SATO: Is it working?
Maybe network issue?  There we
go.
.  (Applause).  Thank you FOM so
easy to detect the object and
how many of you have in the
shopping CART.
So please go back to the slide .
So that was a very simple
scenario where
we just counted the items and
classified them.  But you may
think what's the point of using
cloud for this kind of
detection?  And actually that is
true.
You can run the object detection
API just inside the Tensorflow.
And you don't have to use the
cloud.  But if you can collect
all the data at
the cloud site with thousands of
daily clouds then you can
extract some collect identified
intelligence (?).
For example, you can (?) A model
with all the shopping items you
are adding to the CART.
Thousands of them.
You can predict what will be the
next item you will be putting in
to your shopping CART.  That
will be predicting the location
proximity starting from the
vegetables
and the fruit and meat, like
chicken, and spices and pasta.
Based on all the past history of
the shoppers.
And you can also have a small
display
with it showing recipe with the
next item to add.  That will be
working as a navigate over for
the shoppers.  Let's call it a
smart shopping navigator.
And what kind of model should we
design for implementing the
navigator?
At first we have to represent
what kind of items you have in
the CART.  So, if you have the
tomato in the CART we may have
one hot vector.
In this case you would have a
zero as a value in the vector.
If you put eggplant in the CART
you
would have
another vector.  Then another 1.
0 for chicken.
So this multiple vectors
represents the CART item
history.
So you would have a dictionary
for
shopping items and you can call
one hot
function to all the shopping
items of the vector.  And the
multiple vectors represents the
hot item history.  Now we have
the history.  How do you detect
changes in the history?
In this case you can use the con
VOE Lucien.
Or 1D con VO Lucien.  It is
usually used to detect the
certain products in a local
group of the (?).
For example if you have a 2D
image you can find some shape in
the image.
That is how it works.  But you
can also apply the con VOE
Lucien to one.
For example you can apply the 1D
con VOE Lucien on the CART
history.
They can predict what kind of
changes happen.
Then flatten the output to the
get the result.
You can call the 1CONV1D.
Now we have the CART item change
history.
And we may also want to take in
other factors such as
seasonality.  Whether it's
winter or summer and time of
day.  Because shoppers may want
to choose different food items
based on the season.  Whether it
is a summer and hot day or
whether it is a cold day.  So we
put everything into a single ML
PKS.
Which is a classic newer network
with three layers.  To predict
the next items to add.
With Tensorflow you can write
everything
into one tensor and define the
three layers of the MLP and
that's it is.
Let's look at how the smart
shopping navigator works.
If you put the eggplant then it
should
detect the eggplant.
>> LAURENCE MORONEY: I see a
shadow.
>> KAZ SATO: So you are
watching the same screen I am
watching here.
At the right side you see what
kind of recipes and items
recommended.  So look like the
assistant recommends pasta
eggplant baked.
And I want to make a pasta.
So I would put the tomato
.  Now it will show the other
things you
have to add would be -- I
already have
it but -- eggplant, tomato.
And I want to make a pasta
.  Somehow it doesn't show
pasta.
I can try putting just chicken.
So you can just follow the items
on the screen so you can find
all the items to make the
eggplant tomato pasta.  That's
how it works.  Thank you.
Please go back to the screen.
The slide.
As you have seen on the
demonstration by showing the
recipe ideas and next item to
add it works just like a (?) For
the shoppers.  The shoppers can
just follow the next item to add
to fill the CART with all the
items to cook with a certain
recipe.
That was the example how the
cloud can be empowering for the
loT devices not only for
collecting data but also you can
analyze it and learn some
collective intelligence from it.
It's not just an loT anymore.
This demonstration was actually
built by grooveen naughts.  They
have open source everything on
GitHub.  If you are interested
please go to GitHub and search
with smart shopping
navigator to find out what (?).
They also provide Magellan
blocks
where you can have user
interface to build the whole
data pipeline.
Data and analyzeding it and
running the model.  With that I
direct back the stage to lawyer
EPS.
>> LAURENCE MORONEY: Thank you
Kaz.  Pretty cool stuff right?
(Applause) .
Now the third scenario we wanted
to look at was on device
inference and training.  Like
there's a few different types of
devices you can do inference and
training on.  For example on a
mobile phone or tablet.  You can
do it on a Raspberry Pi.
Or you can do it on an Android
things device.  There's a really
cool video of doing it on a
mobile phone or tablet that I
put at this QR code.  So take a
look at this code and watch this
video.  I'm not going to show it
here but the idea behind the
video is if you went to the
Tensorflow summit you would have
seen it.
But it's farmers in Tanzania who
don't
have cloud connective and rely
on a plant called KA SAVa.  If
the plant gets diseased it can
kill and impact an entire crop.
It's hard for humans to eyeball
it and see it but they built a
machine learned system that they
wave their phone over the leaves
and they can diagnose diseases
early.  It's really, really
cool.  That kind of on device
inference without cloud
connectivity is possible through
Tensorflow light.
You can also do inference and
training on Raspberry Pi.  I
have a car that I am going to
show in a moment that's driven
off a Raspberry Pi.  If you in
the Sanbox area you would have
seen cars like this one
self-driving around.  There's a
camera at the front.  What I
would do is manually drive the
car, record what I am doing,
then based on the telemtry I am
sending to the car to drive it
around and the corresponding
video that's giving us the
features and labels that we want
that the car will remember and
use that to self-drive.  Can we
switch back to slides for a
moment.
Finally there's the third one
which we'll see in a moment on
Android things device.
All this is made possible
because of Tensorflow light.
And I strongly recommend check
out Tensorflow light and the
talks on Tensorflow light.  But
the idea behind Tensorflow light
is if you want a train a machine
learned model we have a bunch of
converters that will flatten
that model and shrink it to make
it more mobile friendly.
There's an interpret ERTD core
used to execute that model.  So
you can do inference on the
model.  For example things like
if you want to do image
classification it will do that
locally without round tripping
to the cloud.  Then all the STUF
that's needed like operation
kernels and card ware
acceleration to take advantage
of the mobile hardware that you
have.
It runs on raspberry Pi, iOS
and, of course, it runs on
Android.  It works great on
pixel.  If you want to see a
demo I can show
realtime inference on the pixel.
Here is a video I shot of me
doing realtime inference.  It
saw the coffee mug correctly.
Here this mug looks like a
mixing bowl
so at some points it felt like a
mix and go.  I know that's
horrible placement for my show.
Here it was able to recognize a
mouse.  This is what it would
look like running on Android.
And so for the self-driving car
that I've been talking about,
you can see on the right is the
RAZ Perry pie.
On the left is a pulse wave
modulation controller.  That
drives the car itself.
So I have Tensorflow light
running on the Raspberry Pi and
that will actually drive the
car.  This is built on a project
called donkey car.  And if you
want to go and take a look at
donkey car in details about
donkey car they're at this URL.
Should we take a look at what it
would look like to train the
car?  So if we can switch to my
laptop
please.
So I've actually started up the
Raspberry Pi on the car.  And
there's a little web server
running on that.  Let me go and
see if I can access it.
Hopefully it will obey.  Oh no
it's refusing to connect.  Hang
on.  Sorry.
So what I am doing is it runs on
Python so I'm just running the
Python code.  Sorry Kaz to make
you hold it so long.  This is
booting up the web server that's
on the car that I would then use
to train and drive it.  So it
will take a moment just to boot
that up.  What will happen if I
want to control the car when I'm
training it obviously it's hard
to do it on it so it has a web
server.  It's connected to a hot
spot on my pixel.  And my
laptop's connected to the same
one.  So it's starting up that
server.  It looks like that
server is done.  Yep.  Here it
is.  As Kaz moves it around you
will see.  If I were to try and
drive the car.  I made a bit of
a mistake if you have been to
the sandbox you would have seen
the cars they're using are real
small.
I didn't read the specs properly
and I bought this one.
I don't dare put it on the floor
because it will take off and
land three rows back.  This is
what it looks like if I'm
driving and training it.  I can
steer and control it like this.
So it's you know what it's doing
right now is recording what it
would see on the webcam from the
car actually moving and storying
all that stuff that would
then use to train a Tensorflow
model for that specific area.
When you see the cars in the
sandbox they're on this figure
YAR track.  We train them in
that way then instead of
launching it in training mode as
I have it now we just launch it
in drive mode and they drive
themselves.
You can build one of these as a
donkey using the donkey car
project.  This one is a little
bit more expensive.
But they generally cost maybe 2
hundred dollars total.  And you
can build a self-driving car and
it's all open source.  It's
really, really cool.
Queen go back to the slides
please?
The motor on the car is really
cloud so I'm going to turn it
off.  So that's what it's like
to train a donkey car.
That's kind of with on device
inference you can have it,
believe it or not, a model
self-driving car.  I think
that's really cool JIESHTHS the
next thing was Android things
that I mentioned.  Did everybody
get one of these?  Right.  So
these are just so cool.
This is like just a little --
this one isn't actually a RAZ
BERie pie it is a -- Raspberry
Pi but a similar concept.
With Android things being able
to execute stuff and with
Tensorflow running you can start
doing inference.  Has anybody
done the code lab?  Have you
tried it out to do inference?
Try it out and build it.  This
afternoon back in my hotel, you
know, on this device I kind of
pointed it at a water bottle and
I thought it was interesting
that it gives you three things
that it thinks it is.
It thought a water bottle, a pop
bottle or toilet tissue.  Then I
tried it on this one.
And it said a coffee mug, a cup
or measuring cup.  Particularly
the way the handle is placed I
thought it would be interesting
to try to fool it.  I thought it
might think it was a pitcher
because sometimes when I do mugs
like that it classifies it as a
pitcher.
Then this one I tried on my
little
French Android and I thought he
was a piggy bank, a tea pot.  I
guess he is a tea pot the way he
is standing.  Or maybe even a
spotlight.  Maybe it's the shape
or something.  But that's the
stuff that's built in.  When you
assemble this device that App is
actually running on here and
that App is open source.  One of
the really cool things you can
do is the image model that App
is trained for you can retrain
that for your own images.
I've been working on a version
of it I'm going add to the car
and maybe we'll talk about it at
a future I/O where I'm
retraining the car to recognize
things like traffic lights.  So,
if it sees a red light it will
STOM if a green light it will
go.  All the code is available
with this kit when you get it.
For those of you watching online
check out Android things.  You
can buy these kits and they're
relatively cheap and so touch
fun.
The code lab that I mentioned if
you are here at I/O you can try
it out.  If you want to try it
on your machines
at home, the URL is at this QRL
code.  Have a Play with it.
It's a lot of fun.
So in recap we spoke a little
bit about loT and AI and the
things happening.  The explosive
growth of actual devices.  And
the amount of data they're
producing.  Then the things you
can do with that.
We looked at the sensor data on
ARD weana.
We looked at cloud scale AI and
device inference.  There's a
whole bunch of things you can do
to take a look at.
Things you can try out.
Number 1, writing data from your
loT device to cloud storage.  If
you want to explore the
Tensorflow object detection API
which is was Kaz
was using when it was detecting
tomatoes and eggplants you can
find details at this link.  LoT
and the cloud ML engines.
Details at this link.  And this
one.
And Tensorflow and Tensorflow
lite and all the mobile
scenarios here were based on
Tensorflow lite.  You can learn
about that at this link or
attend the talks.  Finally
exploring Android things itself.
I find it super cool.  It's
really nice because if you are
already an Android developer you
can start building stuff using
your existing skill set.  When I
was doing the thing for the ARD
weano I had to give myself a
crash course in C.  But if you
are already an Android developer
and used to using Java or Kotlin
to build your introduced Apps
you can start building with that
too.
We just want to say thank you
very much.
Feedback is always welcome.
We'd love to hear it.  And it's
at this URL.  Thank you.
(Applause).